COMMITTEE TO ORDER WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND BEFORE WE GET STARTED -- I
JUST WANT TO SAY TO MY
COLLEAGUES UP HERE ON THE DAIS
AND OF THOSE OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE YOU WILL SEE MANY OF US
WEARING JEANS TODAY.
WE ARE STANDING IN SOLIDARITY
WITH RAPE SURVIVORS MANY OF YOU
MAY NOT KNOW BUT A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO IN ITALY.
A JUDGE RULED THAT A WOMAN'S
RAPE WAS NOT A RATE BECAUSE SHE
HAD ON TIGHT JEANS SO SHE MUST
HAVE CONSENTED TO TAKE HER JEANS
OFF.
SO TODAY WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH RAPE VICTIMS THAT WE WANT
TO ONE DAY BECOME SURVIVORS SO
WELCOME EVERYONE -- WE HAVE
FOURTEEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY THERE ARE THREE ITEMS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM SIX SB THREE TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL ITEM NINE SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS THIS
COMMITTEES OMNIBUS BILL.
ITEM ELEVEN SB SIX THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR GLAZER WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH A SPECIAL ORDER THIS
MORNING.
SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR TO
ROSS SO.
AND DUETO THE AGENDA AND THE
LARGE CROWD OF WITNESSES FOR
THIS BILL AND OTHER BILLS WILL
BE LIMITING TESTIMONY TO TWO
PEOPLE TWO MINUTES EACH PER
PERSON.
ALL OTHER WITNESSES I WOULD ASK
YOU WHEN YOU COME TO THE
MICROPHONE TO STATE YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU KEEP GOING ON OUR
WONDERFUL SERGEANTS WILL CUT YOU
OFF -- SO WHAT WITH THAT.
LET'S GET STARTED SENATOR ALSO.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACT IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO VERY LITTLE
HAS CHANGED IN THE LAWS
GOVERNING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER THE LIMIT ON THE NUMBER
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS ORIGINALLY NO
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED STATEWIDE.
AND A MAXIMUM OF TEN IN ANY
DISTRICT HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
ALTERED WITH OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOLS
STATEWIDE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
AND NO SERIOUS GROWTH WILL
LIMITS ON GROWTH.
CLEAR ISSUES HAVE ARISEN THEIR
REQUIRED CALIFORNIA TO ENGAGE IN
THE DEEPER EVALUATION OF THE
CHARTER SYSTEM WITH IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
A FIVE YEAR PAUSE ON NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS PROVIDES FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SET UP
POLICIES.
MEANT TO PRESERVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND FOR CAREFUL
EVALUATION OF THOSE POLICIES.
THE PAS WOULD END UP UPON
COMPLETION OF A SYSTEMATIC
STATEWIDE EVALUATION OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
THIS WILL PROVIDE ALL OF US THE
TIME IN THE SPACE TO RECONSIDER
WHETHER OUR CURRENT.
FRAMEWORK FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS IS
WORKING AND REFLECTIVE OF OUR
VALUES.
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT HAS NOT
BEEN SERIOUSLY EVALUATED OR
REFORMED IN NEARLY THIRTY YEARS.
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL A CHARTER SCHOOL MORATORIUM
WOULD BE ENACTED ONLY IF THE
FOLLOWING IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT ARE NOT
ADOPTED.
ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS LOCATED
WITHIN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MUST
BE APPROVED ONLY BY THE
DEMOCRATIC BODY ELECTED TO
OVERSEE EDUCATION WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DISTRICT.
THE ELECTED SCHOOL BOARD WILL
HAVE COMPLETE DISCRETION
REGARDING WHICH PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TO PLACE WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION.
NO SCHOOLS WILL BE PERMITTED TO
LOCATE WITHIN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY ANY
OTHER JURISDICTION WITHOUT THE
CONSENT OF THE DISTRICT
CONTROLLING THE JURISDICTION.
THE OVERALL FINANCIAL ACADEMIC
AND FACILITIES IMPACT A
NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS MUST
BE A CONSIDERATION.
BEFORE A NEW CHARTER SCHOOL IS
APPROVED BY A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF STATE WIDE
AND DISTRICT CHARTER SCHOOL CAPS
THAT CREATE REASONABLE LIMITS IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE THE VIABILITY
AND THE SUCCESS.
OF EXISTING DISTRICT SCHOOLS.
SISTERS AND BROTHERS THE
STRENGTH OF EVERY DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY IS INSEPARABLE.
FROM THE STRENGTH OF ITS SYSTEM
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION.
OUR BILL IS B. SEVEN FIVE SIX
ENABLES MEANING FULL EVALUATION
AN ANALYSIS OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND CREATES THE NECESSARY SPACE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF VITAL
REFORMS AND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT.
FINALLY BEFORE I INTRODUCE OUR
WITNESSES I WANT TO SAY MADAM
CHAIR I AM AWARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
AND I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH YOU.
IN ADDRESSING CONCERNS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE SO THAT THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
TODAY WE HAVE THREE WITNESSES
HILDA RODRIGUEZ WITH MY ON A
CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT FROM LOS
ANGELES.
DOCTOR ROCK SENATE MARATHI
BRUSHY EDUCATION CHAIR FOR THE
SAN JOSE SILICON VALLEY CHAPTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA AND DOUBLE ACP.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
WE ALSO HAVE AN EXPERT IN THE
FIELD CLAIRE CRAWFORD FROM THE
ORGANIZATION IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND RESPOND TO THE
OPPOSITION'S POINTS.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS SO WHEN
THIS IS IN SUPPORT BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO MINUTES EACH.
ONE MINUTE I'M SORRY WE HAVE A
QUORUM SORGEN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILL
CARE CHIANG TO WRESTLE HERE
LASSEN HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HERE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS IN
BATTLE TO GET SCHOOLS OF MINE.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FIFTY SIX I AM A FOUNDING PARENT
OF THE ACCELERATED SCHOOL AND
WALLIS ANNENBERG HIGH SCHOOL ALL
THREE OF MY CHILDREN ATTENDED
THESE TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
A GROUP OF THREE INDEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES ANGELES
THAT ARE AUTHORIZED BY LAUSD MY
GRANDSON IS CURRENTLY ATTENDING
XCELERATED CHARTER SCHOOL
ELEMENTARY I. T. K. THROUGH SIX
SISTERS SCHOOL OF THE
ACCELERATED SCHOOLS.
I HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED
WITH THE ACCELERATED SCHOOL
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR I WAS
ELATED BY WHAT I WAS TOLD ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT I WOULD
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE AND
WOULD BE PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE INVOLVED IN THE DECISION
MAKING.
INITIALY I WATCHED.
BUT THIS EXPERIENCE WAS SHORT
LIVED.
THE TRUTH IS THAT I WAS MISLED.
BY THE CHARTER SCHOOL INDUSTRY.
THEY CAME INTO MY COMMUNITY AND
THEY PROMISED US THINGS THEY
PROMISED TO SERVE ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE KIDS.
BUT THEY'D BE DON'T.
MY TRAUMA BEGAN WHEN PARENTS ARE
SCHOOL OBSERVED A HIGH TEACHER
TURNOVER WE LOST THE MAJORITY OF
OUR TEACHERS AND AS PARENTS WE
ORGANIZE AND BEGAN TO DEMAND
ANSWERS FROM MARCOLE FOUNDERS.
I DISCOVERED THE MAJORITY OF OUR
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE NO EDUCATION
BACKGROUND AND THEY DON'T LIVE
IN OUR SURROUNDING COULDN'T
NEIGHBORHOODS.
BUT THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION
IN FUTURE THIS HAS BEEN
CONCERNING FOR ME.
I'M NOT RELATE TO THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY.
I MADE A TERRIBLE MISTAKE.
I MADE THE MISTAKE OF ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT SCHOOL BUDGETS
AND HOW FUNDS WERE BEING SPENT
TO HELP OUR KIDS.
IN MY TWENTY FOUR YEARS WITH
THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS I HAVE
SEEN AND EXPERIENCED THINGS THAT
MAKE WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A FUTURE A HUGE PROBLEM AND
A LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN I HAVE SEEN
THE RULES AND THE REGULATIONS
THAT CURRENTLY GOVERN CHARTER
SCHOOLS IGNORED AND DISREGARDED.
AT THE AT CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH
LITTLE TO NO CONSEQUENCES AND IT
HAS NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES.
MY YOUNGEST SON WITH
DISABILITIES AND NINE WERE
UNABLE TO GET THE CHARTER SCHOOL
TO PROVIDE HIM SUPPORT THE
CHARTER SCHOOL MY CHILDREN
ATTENDED COUNSELED MANY STUDENTS
OUT WITH DISABILITIES TELLING
THEM.
THAT THING.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS TO MEET THE
STUDENTS NEEDS SO IT'S BEST TO
ROOMMATE FOR THEM TO REMAIN IN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ALSO FALSIFIES
GREAT SO IT SEEMS THE STUDENTS
ARE DOING WELL.
WHEN IN FACT THEY'RE NOT I HAVE
PERSONALLY BEEN THREATENED BY
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION DIRECTOR
AND BY MY SCHOOLS CO FOUNDERS
FOR SPEAKING OUT?
ABOUT PROBLEMS THAT I HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND OUR SCHOOLS DO NOT
GET ENOUGH FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT IT'S IF STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS LIKE MINOR
PUSHED OUT OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
DISTRICT AT THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
DISTRICT SCHOOLS ASSUME HIGHER
FINANCIAL BURDEN.
IT IS NOT FAIR.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM HARMS THAT
ONLY FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
BUT ENTIRE THIS ABOVE THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM OF PUBLIC EDUCATION WHEN
I NAIVELY.
TRIED TO SEEK ASSISTANCE FOR MY
SON THAT WAS HEARD IN MY
CHILDREN.
WE WERE SUFFERING I WAS BLOCKED.
I POSTED THE PAINFUL EXPERIENCE
OF MY FAMILY ON FACEBOOK ON THE
FACEBOOK PAGE OF THE CART
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION.
POSTED MAR DRAMATICS EXPERIENCES
WITH MY BLOCK [inaudible]
I WOULD.
MY EXPEDIT X..
READING EGGS.
NOT ALIGNED WITH THE SCENE THERE.
WERE TRYING.
IN MY COMMUNITY.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL LAW IS BROKE
IT STUDENTS OF COLOR IN POOR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN TARGETED
BY CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND CHILDREN.
LIKE MINE.
MOST HARMED BY THESE BROKEN
CHARTER SCHOOL LAWS THE ONGOING
WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE IN THE
WILD WEST OF THESE CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS ROBERT STUDENTS OF
COLOR OF MILLIONS OF FUNDING.
OVER THE YEARS CHARTER SCHOOLS
MAY HELP ME HELP SOME KIDS.
BUT THAT'S NOT MY EXPERIENCE.
THEY HAVE DONE DAMAGE THEY HAVE
DONE DAMAGE TO MY COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE TO STOP THE BLEEDING
BEFORE WE CAN HILL WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A MORATORIUM ON YOUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE NEED MUCH
STRONGER SYSTEMS OF LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
OUR STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING THERE
IS A DIRECT HARM THAT HAS
OCCURRED WITH MY CHILDREN.
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
CHARTER SCHOOL MURDERER WILL
GIVE US THIS TIME.
IT'S TIME TO BRING THEM ENSURE
THAT THESE FLAWS IN THE CURRENT
LAW ANSWER FIX BEFORE. FOR MORE
DAMAGE IS DONE OUR URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB. SEVEN
FIFTY SIX OUR CHILDREN ARE NO
LONGER GAINEY KEEP PIGS WE
CANNOT AFFORD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MOVING TESTIMONY -- SHE USED UP
ALL OF THE TIME PLUS SOME SO I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU THIRTY SECONDS
OKAY IT WAS TWO MINUTES FOR EACH
AYE BUT VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
SO YOU HAVE THIRTY SECONDS.
I THANK YOU MY NAME IS DOCTOR X.
ON A MARRIAGE SHE I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND EIGHT AND DOUBLE
ACP WE ARE CO SPONSORING SB
SEVEN FIFTY SIX TO ESTABLISH A
MORATORIUM.
ON NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS IN OUR
STATE.
THE UNREGULATED GROWTH OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAS LED TO
INCREASED SEGREGATION INTO
INEQUITABLE RESOURCE ALLOCATIONS
THAT HAVE LEFT STUDENTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WITH DISPROPORTIONATELY
FEWER RESOURCES.
A MORATORIUM ON NEW CHARTER
AUTHORIZATION BUT PROVIDE TIME
TO STRENGTHEN CHARTER
ACCOUNTABILITY LEGISLATION AND
PROPHECIES AND ENSURE THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT
EXACERBATE SEGREGATION
SELECTIVELY RECRUIT AND ENROLL
NOR DENY YOU TO QUALITY TEACHING
AND LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ALL STUDENTS.
DESERVE.
AB THE INCREASING FREQUENCY OF
SCHOOL CLOTHES OPENINGS AND
CLOSURES WITH IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS CREATES
INSTABILITY AND COMMUNITY
FRACTURING WHAT IS THE COST TO
THE STATE TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND YOUR COMMUNITIES OF THE
OPENING AND CLOSING OF SCHOOLS
THAT HAD RED FLAGS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
WHAT IS THE COST TO TAXPAYERS OF
THE STAFF TIME TO REVIEW CHARTER
PETITIONS THAT GO THROUGH LINK
THE AUTHORIZATION PROCESS THESE
ONLY TO BE SHUT DOWN DUE TO
FINANCIAL MISMANAGEMENT?
WHAT ARE THE EDUCATIONAL IMPACT
TO STUDENTS ATTENDING CHARTER
SAID ABRUPTLY CLOSE ORDER
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS WHOSE FUNDS
FOR SERVICES OR DECREASE BECAUSE
OF THE HIGH COST OF CHARTER
EXPANSION?
I'M SORRY THE TIME AYE AYE.
THREE MINUTES HAVE COME FROM
SANDERS I'M REPRESENTING I'M
SORRY BUT WE'RE VERY CLEAR WE
HAVE A VERY PACKED AGENDA SHE
TOOK FIVE MINUTES YOUNG I HAD
FOR TOTAL SO THINKING.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION LOOK FOR TO WORKING
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YU VERY
MUCH I WOULD ASK OTHERS IN
SUPPORT TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU SUPPORT
THE MEASURE.
MADAM CHAIR SEVEN BRAMBLE HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OR CO
SPONSORS I'M HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IT ROUGHLY ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THE LAURA STRAND FLOORS IN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OR CO
SPONSORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
INGRID CANAL UNITED TEACHERS LOS
ANGELES AND A PARENT OF TWO
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHEA LAWMEN PROUD PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATOR AND ROWLAND HEIGHTS
CALIFORNIAN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EIGHT FOUR YOU'RE RETIRED --
GRANDPARENT OF NINE
GRANDCHILDREN ALL.
ATTENDING PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING GINA WEBB POLL I'M
FROM LANCASTER AND PARENT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS THANK YOU.
DONT STOP FOR WEST SACRAMENTO
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES A CHARTER AND WE
SUPPORT.
PROUD THIRTY YEAR EDUCATOR
CHARLES SHANNON WITH YOUR DAD
YOU CATERS ASSOCIATION AND FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEXANDRA KHANDAN APPARENT IN
SACRAMENTO THREE CHILDREN ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATED IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WHEN THE HOMES FROM SALMON DINO
I AM VERY PROUD GRANDPARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN ONE IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND ONE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL?
WITH PUBLIC EDUCATION AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SERGIO MARTINEZ
PROUD TEACHER UP OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS HACIENDA LE POINT DAY
IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TO THE FOLKS AT THE
TABLE ONE OUT ON AS WELL.
I'M CLEAR CRAWFORD WITH IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION IF WE CAN
MAKE A LITTLE ROOM AT THE TABLE
.
WE WENT A LITTLE OVER ON OUR
SUPPORT SO I WILL GIVE YOU THE
SAME DIFFERENCE SO YOU HAVE SIX
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THE CENTER ON REINVENTING PUBLIC
EDUCATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CLOSER TO YOU. EIGHT THANK YOU
YOU WELCOME MORNING MY NAME IS
ROBIN LAKE I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER ON REINVENTING PUBLIC
EDUCATION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON IN SEATTLE.
HERE TODAY IS A RESEARCHER NOT
AN ADVOCATE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
OR DISTRICT SCHOOLS.
I AM AN ADVOCATE FOR EVIDENCE
ABOUT -- WHATEVER WILL HELP
STUDENTS SUCCEED.
OVER THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I'VE STUDIED HOW DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN CO EXIST AND
EVEN WORK TOGETHER TOWARD SHARED
ACADEMIC AND FINANCIAL GOALS.
CITIES LIKE INDIANAPOLIS WHERE
SPEND SOME TIME SHOW WHAT'S
POSSIBLE AND FOR DECADES --
INDIANAPOLIS PUBLIC SCHOOLS LOS
MIDDLE CLASS STUDENTS TO NEARBY
DISTRICTS.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS STARTED
LEAVING AS WELL WHEN THE
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF INDIANAPOLIS
STARTED AUTHORIZING CHARTER
SCHOOLS AS AN ECONOMIC
REVITALIZATION STRATEGY.
INSTEAD OF FIGHTING FAMILIES
CHOICES THE RESPONSE FROM
INDIANAPOLIS PUBLIC SCHOOLS THE
DISTRICT HAS BEEN TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL CHARTER SCHOOLS.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO DISTRICT
BUILDINGS IN CENTRAL OFFICE
SERVICES.
IN EXCHANGE THE DISTRICT
RECEIVES A PORTION OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FUNDS AND AND IS
USING AUTONOMY.
AS AN IMPROVEMENT STRATEGY FOR
ALL OF ITS SCHOOLS TO FREE
EDUCATORS TO TRANSFORM THEIR
SCHOOLS.
I PS IS NOW GROWING IN A ROMANCE
AND IMPORTANTLY IN QUALITY
OUTCOMES.
THE EXPERTS -- AND AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
IN CALIFORNIA AND OTHERS REALLY
AGREE -- WHEN WE LOOKED ACROSS
ALL THE EVIDENCE THAT FISCAL
STRESS HAS ALWAYS BEEN?
I WILL CONTINUE TO BE A REALITY
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WITH OR WITHOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS
THE INDIANAPOLIS SHOWS THAT
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
CAN COME TOGETHER TO MAKE MORE
HIGH QUALITY CHOICES FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE FOR STUDENTS.
TEMPORARY TRANSITION AID CAN
HELP DISTRICTS ADJUSTING THE
REVENUE REALITIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY FROM THE STATE CAN
HELP DISTRICTS BE MORE NIMBLE
AND EFFICIENT.
BUT HOLDING ONLY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HOSTAGE BY LIMITING
ACCESS TO SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
THEM WHILE.
IS NOT.
A SOLUTION.
OPEN ENROLLMENT LOSS FOR
WHATEVER REASON CONCERTS
DESTABILIZE DISTRICTS HOWEVER
STUDIES THE INFLATE FIX COSTS DO
THIS IMPORTANT DEBATE A
DISSERVICE.
BY INTRODUCING HYPERBOLE WERE
RIGOROUS ANALYSIS IS NEEDED.
THE QUESTION I THINK BEFORE --
BEFORE ALL OF US IS IS WHETHER
WE CAN PUT PLATE PUT IN PLACE
SYSTEMS THAT ENABLE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADAPT.
AND IMPROVE HOW THEY SERVE
STUDENTS IN THE FACE OF THESE
REALITIES THAT WILL NOT BE GOING
AWAY AND INSTEAD -- WILL
REINFORCE THE SCAPEGOATING THAT
REALLY HELPS NOBODY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING CARLOS MARQUEZ HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION HERE
REPRESENT OUR STRENUOUS
OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX WHICH PLACES IN
AND YOU IN AND TENABLE POSITION
IT HOLD YOU HOSTAGE TO DISMISS
ENTIRELY THE WELL DOCUMENTED
ACADEMIC GAINS THE CHARTERS ARE
ACHIEVING WITH FOLDABLE STUDENTS.
BY FOR CLOSING ON NEW HIGH
QUALITY SEATS FOR FIVE YEARS OR
TO SANCTION INTENT LANGUAGE THE
PLACES YOU'RE COMMITTEE ON
RECORD SUPPORTING EQUALLY
EXTREME POLICIES THAT IF ENACTED
COULD RESULT IN THE CLOSURE OF
EXISTING HIGH QUALITY SCHOOLS.
IMPOSING ULTIMATUMS ON A
LEGISLATIVE BODY IS DELIVERED OF
AS THE SENATE UNDERMINES THE
DEBATE WE SHOULD BE HAVING WHICH
IS HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
MODERNIZE THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT. TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP SCALE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
INNOVATION ACROSS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND REIMAGINE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS IN
COLLABORATIVE IN SUSTAINABLE
TERMS.
PROPONENTS OF SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
DOWN PLAY THE TIME FRAME OF FIVE
YEARS SO LET'S INTERROGATE THAT.
FIVE YEARS IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHETHER OR NOT TODAY'S
GENERATION OF THIRTEEN YEAR OLD
BLACK AND LATINO BOYS WILL BE
WEARING A CAP AND GOWN OR A
JUMPSUIT.
IN -- IN FIVE YEARS TODAY'S
KINDERGARTENERS WILL
MATRICULATED TO FOURTH GRADE WE
KNOW THAT BY THIRD GRADE IF YOU
AREN'T ABLE TO READ.
IT'S A PREDICATE FOR THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE TIME
FRAME OF FIVE YEARS IS
ABSOLUTELY CONSEQUENTIAL BUT
THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE INTENT
LANGUAGE IT GETS WORSE IF IT WAS
AN ACTED AS SUBSTANTIVE POLICY.
IT WOULD DISMANTLE EXISTING DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS AND THREATEN
EXISTING HIGH QUALITY CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND FOR WHAT WHY IS IT
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF SB SEVEN
FIVE SIX FEEL SO PASSIONATELY
THAT THIS BILL MUST PROVE MOVE
FOR TODAY.
WHEN THE CHARTER TASK FORCE IS
JUST WEEKS AWAY FROM RELEASING
ITS FINAL REPORT AND BASED ON
WHAT PREMISE WE KNOW THAT 75% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT CERTIFIED
QUALIFIED BUDGETS OVER THE LAST
YEAR?
HAD NO MORE THAN TWO CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND A THIRD HAD NO
CHARTER SCHOOLS WITHIN THEIR
GEOGRAPHY.
IN FACT THERE'S LITTLE CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
THE CAUSAL DRIVER OF FISCAL
DISTRESS.
A BODY OF INDEPENDENT RESEARCH
BACKS THIS UP SO WHETHER IT'S
TRANSITIONAL EIGHT OR SURPLUS
PROPERTY AUTHORIZING
AUTHORIZATION REFORM MORE
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE STAND READY.
WITH REAL SOLUTIONS THAT IMPROVE
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM FOR ALL KIDS
BUT WE REJECT SB SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE IS THAT SOLUTION AND WE
URGE YOUR KNOW ABOUT
[inaudible]
Q..
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'LL
PLEASE LINE UP STATE YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND IT WHETHER
YOU SUPPORTER BUT OPPOSE THE
BILL.
LET'S LET'S GIVE IT JUST A
SECOND SINCE IT'S A LITTLE NOISY
.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE READY PLEASE
PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRUNCH A
JONES ABAFT CHARTER SCHOOL
CAPITAL IBM IN K. TWELVE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FROM THE ORIGINAL PARENT
EDUCATOR WITH INNOVATIVE
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CAPRICE YOUNG SUPERINTENDENT OF
LEARN FOR LIFE DROP OUT PROGRAMS
AND A STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS.
MY HAVE A RIGHT NOW.
WITH AT VOICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. TWENTY DAILY READING
IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
SPECIALISTS FROM NOVA ACADEMY
RECENTLY IN MARCH DISTINGUISHED
SCHOOL AWARD.
DR RAMONA BISHOP TWENTY FIVE
YEAR EDUCATOR TEACHER ALL THE
WAY TO SUPERINTENDENT NOW
PRESIDENT AND CEO ELITE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK SANDERS REPRESENT IN
SEBASTOPOL INDEPENDENT CHARTER
SCHOOL IN THIS POSSIBLE UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM CARE ST FRANCIS CAR WITH
GIL WORRY HOLLISTER WATSONVILLE
PREP SCHOOLS AND THE CHARTER
SCHOOL OF MORGAN HILL AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SYSTEM.
JUDY A DEER ADMINISTRATOR FOR
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL IN
TEMECULA CALIFORNIA AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M REGINA NELSON I AM A
MOTHER OF FOUR BOYS WHO ARE WITH
INSPIRE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
ROSARIO MARQUEZ PARENT WITH
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AM SEVENTY MITCHELL I'M A
TEACHER WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND A MOTHER OF A
DAUGHTER AT CALIFORNIA
MONTESSORI PROJECT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
DR ELLEN ROSE NOW GREAT VALLEY
ACADEMY'S FOUNDER IN MODESTO AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M CANDACE IN EITHER FROM
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
EIGHT CHILDREN WE HOME SCHOOL
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AUDREY
IVERSON I'M FROM CORONA
CALIFORNIA I HOME SCHOOL THREE
OF MY CHILDREN WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOSH WHO
WAS ON THE HOME SCHOOL CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M JEDIDIAH WELLS I'M A STUDENT
WAS INSPIRED NORTH AMERICA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LUCAS WELLS AND I
MY NAME IS KEVIN AND I OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
HERE IS WEEK I'M A PARENT FROM
INSPIRED CHARTER IN ELK GROVE
AND I OPPOSE.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX WHEN I WAS
SIXTEEN YEARS WORK I AM A
STUDENT WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELINDA WELLS
AMY PRIOR PRIVATE SCHOOL TEACHER.
A PRIOR PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR
AND I AM NOW A PARENT UP INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE'VE BEEN.
TEACHING THROUGH INTO THREE
CHART THROUGH INSPIRE FOR OVER
TEN YEARS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING AND HILDA SOLIS
MONTH IT'LL PARENT FROM LOS
ANGELES NAY OPPOSES ABOUT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GALINA
AND I HAVE TO CHARTER SCHOOL
CHILDREN THROUGH INSPIRED TO
SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS.
BUT A SUCCESSFUL IS SUPPOSED TO
BE IN THIRD GRADE MY CHILD IS IN
THE FIFTH GRADE VETERANS BY
CHARTER SEEM AN OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREA FOR IS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL I AM A FIRST
GRADE TEACHER AND I ALSO HAVE A
CHILD WHO IS THROUGH SUTTER
PETER.
HI MY REINTEGRATION APPARENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JASMINE SUPPORTS A
STUDENT FROM THE VALLEY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OKAY FOR WITH PACIFIC CHARTER
INSTITUTE AND SECRETARY BOARD OF
EDUCATION BOARD MEMBER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JEFF RICE WITH THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING SEVENTY
FIVE PERSONALIZED LEARNING
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DR DON WILSON -- ADMINISTRATOR
FOR THIRTY YEARS WITH LA U. S.
D..
A PARENT WITH A CHILD THE WINTER
AT LEAST IN CURRENTLY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE CHARTER
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I A OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE DID THE CHIN THE
SHIVER I PEOPLE'S THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AN INTELLIGENCE
LANGKAH AND FOR MY KIDS
ATTENDING COMING DOWN TO CHECK A
NAME AND I'M STRONG THEM POLLS
HAS BE SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MY MY NAME IS ART ON THE SCHOOL
BOTH AND I GO TO SEE WHERE YOU
MAY SEE NGUYEN MIDDLE SCHOOL
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER TO SLING
GOAL AND I GO TO SEE AWAY.
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
AND THE ISSUE í
THIS BILL [inaudible]
MY NAME [inaudible]
I MY NAME IS MY CELL NUMBER
ALICE I MEET PARENT WITH CELL
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND AYE
OPPOSED SYSTEM.
MY NAME IS HEATHER FRIENDS I'M A
PROUD CHARTER PARENT BUT I'M
ALSO A FORMER PUBLIC TRADITIONAL
AND A CURRENT -- CHARTER
ADMINISTRATOR AND I BELIEVE IN
CHOICE FOR CHILDREN SO I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PHYLLIS SCRIBBLE FOR
AND THE FATHER OF SEVEN KIDS AND
AYE OPPOSED THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER STOCK CAL
AN EDUCATOR AND PARENT INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOL NAY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS ANY
BROWN EMMETT CURRENT STUDENT
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RYAN JOE BAMBRICK
SALARIES STUDENT INSPIRED
CHARTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA JOB I'M A
CORPORATE ATTORNEY AND I HOME
SCHOOL FAMILY GIFTED KIDS ARE
BOTH RESCUE IN FULL SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ADVISED ME THAT THEY
COULD NOT MEET MY CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL -- NAME AND I WAS
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICELLE HATE AND
I HOME SCHOOL TEACHER AND PARENT
AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS SAM WALKED THERE I'M
A STUDENT AT SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY INTERNATIONAL CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I POST THIS BILL.
KIANA HER TYRONE I'M A STUDENT
AT S. V. I. CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY INTEREST TO CONTINUE NOW AND
I'M AS SOON AS VERY TRUST GOING
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN ABOUT TIME
I AM A STUDENT OF I THE THING
CASTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALLEY IS MEDIA AND I
AM A STUDENT OF AYE LEE
LANCASTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY EVEN SEND
AND I'M A PROUD EDUCATOR IT IDLY
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CENTRAL CALL I
AM HIGHLY HER I'M A STUDENT FROM
HIGHLY CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
LANCASTER I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M WENDY ACKLAND HOME SCHOOL
MOM OF THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE
WORLD THE PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
INVOLUNTARY HOME SCHOOL CONSIDER
SUPPORTING OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
CHARTER SCHOOLS COLORS.
AND WE OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HI I'M TAKING A COLOGNE I'M A
PARENT ADVOCATE SPECIALIST WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TRUST CISCO PARENT OF FOUR
CHILDREN IN A POSITION.
YOU'RE SURE BUT PARENT OF TWO
SACRAMENTO POSED AS BILL.
TITANIC PRIMARK CAM PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S EMMANUEL I FELT THAT
CHILDREN AND GRAND CHILDREN AND
THREE BRENT BRENT CHILDREN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS PETER CALL SOMEONE I
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BORIS NORK I AM A
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS PAULA VON FADEN FROM
DICK'S IN CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
SON ENVISIONS AN EDUCATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME.
MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS THE LESSER DIANNE NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEANNA DIRE I
AM AN EDUCATOR WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOSHUA DILUTES
BUYERS STUDENT AND I THIS BILL.
I WILL GO TO PULL FROM TO COME
IN THE I DIDN'T MIND DOING IT.
TOO CHECK.
IN CHILDREN I AM OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KARENA BULLISH
CROSS FIVE TWO CHILDREN AN EPIC
IN WEST SACRAMENTO AND I PULLED
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AN OCCASION CHECK
AMONG STUDENTS HAVE VISIONS IN
EDUCATION I POSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING ON MOTHER EXPO IN
BECAUSE I HAVE TWO KIDS AND I
POSITED BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ERIC JOHN INCOME
MY ELEMENTARY TO MIDDLE SCHOOL
WAS WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOL
CALLED COMEDIA CHATTERING AND
THEN I GRADUATED FROM SOUTH
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL AS WELL --
WITH HONORS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL PRISTUPA
HI IN THE PAST AT TEN ENKIWI
COMMUNITY CHARTER AND CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO SISTERS ATTENDING.
IN A STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TATIANA THEY'RE
GONNA EDUCATOR AT GATEWAY
COMMUNITY CHARTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL AS WELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY SOME
LINCOLN AND I AM A SUPPORTER
FROM GATEWAY COMMUNITY CHARTER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS WELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIMOTHY
PRISTUPA PREVIOUS STUDENT OF GCC
CHARTERS DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE BRANAGH
CREDENTIAL TEACHER OF EIGHTEEN
YEARS WORKED IN PRIVATE PUBLIC
ANSWER NOW CHARTER SCHOOLS THEY
WERE PROVISIONS IN EDUCATION AND
MY CHILDREN ARE IN HORIZONS
CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NO BRAND AND I AM
WITH VERIZON CHARTER SCHOOL I
BELIEVE STUDENTS AND PARENTS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE THEIR
EDUCATION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI HI MY NAME IS LEANNE BRANCH
AND IN A MISSION FOR HER ASIAN
SHE CHARTER SCHOOL IN ROSEVILLE
AND I OPPOSE.
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KNUCKLES NETWORK
I'M THE MOTHER OF THE SIX IT'S
THREE OF THEM ATTEND IN A VISION
EDUCATION HOME SCHOOLED AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THIRTEEN AND A TEN
I ATTEND REVELLI CHARS GONNA PUT
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AND THE GLORIA
INVOICE SHOULD READ NOW IN THE
GOING TO CHURCH -- VISION HOME
SCHOOL AND I PULLED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THAT THE ONLY AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHERRY KOONING CAM TO
CHILDREN WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
I'M MORE COULD NICK AND I ALSO
POSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LAW DIMINISH SAFE
UMBILICAL HIM.
HI OF ON FOR THE FOR IN THE
POLLS THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANATOLY LISCO
AND I'M FATHER FOR KEYS WHO IS A
ATTENDING -- HORIZON CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TAMMY
FOR A FORMER EDUCATOR AND A
TRADITIONAL DISTRICT PUBLIC
SCHOOL I AM A PARENT OF CHILDREN
THAT WERE IN A TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND A PARENT OF A
CHILD AND CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
AM CURRENTLY A CO FOUNDER EVEN
OPPOSITION MANY STRAIGHTER AND I
OPPOSE.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KRISTIN KRAUS -- FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR AT SORT CHARTER ACADEMY
IN SAN MARINO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DEBBIE TARVER CEO
FOUNDER OF LIBOURNE ELEMENTARY
PREPARATORY ACADEMY AND AS OUR
TRIALS.
ARE PREPARATORY ACADEMY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TIFFANY
SATIN I AM THE ADMINISTRATOR AT
DOES IT FEELS PREPARATORY
ACADEMY AND THE MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN ATTENDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HELLO HELLO
CUSHION.
AND I'M FOR THE FULL SIX KIDS
I'M OPPOSE OF THIS BILL.
HI I'M TRISH LANCASTER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF SORTS
CHARTER ACADEMY FOR CHAIR OF
SPOT PREPPING TEMERIN DINO.
AND A CURRENT PARENT OF A
STUDENT WHO GOES TO GORMAN
LEARNING CENTER IN REDLANDS HIGH
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M BARBARA HALE AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SICK MORE
ACADEMY AND WILL TOMORROW AND A
JACKET OF DIRECTOR FOR SYCAMORE
COUNTY THAT WILL BE OPENING IN
CHINO HILLS.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CRISTINA LASTER PARENT UNION
PRESIDENT FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AT AND PARENTS OF CHILDREN LIKE
YELTSIN ARE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING JENNY I WAS A
PUBLIC SCHOOL PARENTS IN LOS
ANGELES AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ADRIN AS A JOKE AND
I'M EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NATASHA LOCAL TO COME
A SCHOOL TEACHER AND A PARENT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO ALEXANDER COULD CATCH A
PRO LIFE SAN FRANCISCO FORMER --
EMPLOYEE OF IN SF U. S. D. HIGH
RISK HIGH COMPLEX SCHOOL
OPPOSITION.
BACK TO CARRY HAWKINS ASH
ESQUIRE WITH MAKING MAYES
ACADEMY AND WE RISE TO STATE OUR
OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS THE
DAUGHTER OF RITA AND I UP CLOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MOTHER OF A DAUGHTER READ --
I'M FROM PALM SPRINGS CALIFORNIA
NEW YORK UNIVERSITY BACHELOR OF
FINE ARTS I'M HERE WITH INSPIRED.
BY THE MOTHER OF HIS BY OF A
CHILD THE CITY'S BUYER CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE HIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALINA CONDONING GO
I AM A MOM OF TWO FUTURE
STUDENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A VOTE THE **** CA
AND I'M SHOWING UP US THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MENTIONED THE
LOCK AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE
MASTER OBVIOUS I AM A PARENT AN
EDUCATOR IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME DOES HE ON A NEW CAR I
HEALTH NINE GRAND DAUGHTERS AND
CHIU THOSE SOUNDS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ERIC HAGEN HI MADE
A MINISTRY -- AN APPARENT OF TWO
WITH RESTAURANTS HERE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND CURSED.
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M JODY JEFFERSON
ADMINISTRATOR FOR WESTERN TERROR
CHARTER SCHOOLS I'M ALSO A
PARENT OF TWO STUDENTS AT THAT
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NINA I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S VERY TEARING
CONFIDENT ON MOTHER OF THREE AND
WARY THINNING -- PACIFIC CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS ALL BIRTH.
I AM -- FOR THE SIX CHILDREN.
APPLE STRONGLY THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
I HAVE A THREE TO THAN THAN FIVE
INCHES IN I SUPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS VITALI I'M A
FATHER OF TO AND A STRONG THE
APPLES THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS IN TURN OFF --
I'M FROM WHERE SACRAMENTO AND I
HAVE -- TWO BROTHERS ARE --
ATTEND CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS WILLIAM BURGER
I AM AN ADULT EDUCATOR AS WELL
AS A FATHER OF THREE CHARTER
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
I AM ONE OF PEOPLE WHO RECEIVED
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX SINGLE TERRY
I'M AN ADMINISTRATOR AT
EXCELSIOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
DECEMBER DINO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING HI SEEK MORALIS L.
FOR HE MORE SCIENCE TEMPLE OF
AMERICA WE IS MORE GENERIC AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M TOM ALL SHOCKED
AND I MOTHER OF THREE KIDS
[inaudible]
STRONGLY OPPOSE SPILLED.
GOOD MORNING QUOTES WATER FORTY
SCHOOL STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THE MORNING CATHERINE TERRACE
CIRCA POSING -- SEVEN FIFTY SIX
I WANT TO HAVE A CHOICE AND I
WANT MY CHILD TO HAVE A CHOICE
IN EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS AN INDIVIDUAL AND
HAVE TWO KIDS AND I FELT.
MY NAME IS OLIVER DON'T MIND
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU JUST ENTERING WERE ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME IN OPPOSITION ONLY.
OKAY MY IS PRETTY HILLARY
PASTORS SHALLOW TABERNACLE
CHURCH AND I OPPOSE.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MYERS WINDOWS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
YES MY NAME IS MARIA SYLVIA AND
I'M FROM SHILOH TABERNACLE
CHURCH AND AYE OPPOSED.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX AND FOR MYSELF I
HAVE A CHILD WHO WAS BEHIND ANY
REGULAR NOW AND NOW I TAKE YOUR
NAME IN OPPOSITION ONLY THANK
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO
TESTIFY.
MY NAME IS GINNY SANTANA PASTOR
SHILOH TABERNACLE CHURCH I WILL
POST TO SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
HI COUNTER MAUREEN SHILOH
TABERNACLE CHURCH PASTOR IN
CHAPLAIN AYE OPPOSED.
AND YOU COULD OPEN FOR MAGICAL
COME ON THE OPPOSED.
TO SEVEN FIVE SIX I AM GET
CARLSON STRONGLY OPPOSED.
KERRY CARLSON INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOLS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SERRA GRECO PARENT OF THREE
STUDENTS AT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL IN THREE STUDENTS IN ST
WIND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AMYLIN PARKINS INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
CARE PARKING INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL. THREE STUDENTS AND
FAMILY LIAISON OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
HIS.
KIANA GRECO FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
SUZANNE ACCORDINGLY PERRIN OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO WERE
EDUCATED THROUGH CHARTER HOME
SCHOOLS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
READER TO ZERO PARENTS OF TWO
FOURTEEN CHARTER SCHOOLS NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
INEVITABLE SHOOK OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX EVELYN A BROWNISH
FROM SHINGLE SPRINGS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND KATIE NOVICK APICAL CHICKS
ARE.
AND I AM ABOUT THIS BILL AND MY
MOST.
THREE WHICH FROM A COOL CHICK.
PINEAPPLE THIS BILL.
BRITISH -- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JACKIE TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIAL TEACHER INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
I RECALL A SHAMAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M RICK -- I'M SO FEE ADDED.
AYE AS CLOSE THIS BILL.
I AM BROKEN CAMBRIDGE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MARCY CAMBRIDGE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I MAKING CAMBRIDGE AND I OPPOSE
THIS.
COLUMN MARCHANT PARENTS
SUPPORTER INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARIN MARGIN INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
END OF A DARN ON THE SUPPORTER
FROM THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
ACTION MARGIN FROM INSPIRE AND
AYE OPPOSED TO SPILL.
MY NAME IS AUSTIN MY ACTION I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HELLO I'M NOT A
FLORA'S I'M A STUDENT FROM LPS
OAKLAND IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MYNAME IS NOT.
MY NAME IS -- I'M FROM LPS
OAKLAND AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MORNING REX FORTUNE FOUND IN
FOURTEEN SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
SACRAMENTO AND I PULLED
[inaudible] NINE AND I AM
BECAUSE THIS.
I'M JUST A BIG ERA -- FROM
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
PLACES BILL.
CURSING VOID FROM STRUCTURES
WILL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MASON VOID FROM CHART INSPIRED
HER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MARCY VOID A CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIAL TEACHER INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE MIDDLE OF US BECAUSE LOCAL
RESIDENTS ARE A LAMB AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO ONE OF THE S. P. NUMBERS
HERE MANY OF BEING A PRESENT ON
THE ONE ON THE AC HE THEY
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
HAS.
WHAT I MEAN NUMBERS GLOW YET IT
REPRESENTS A LET'S QUIT LASSIE
IS HE?
THE OAKLAND CALIFORNIA THE
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA CAME UP ON GO
ON A LATE IS SEVEN IS HERE TO
SING WHEN THEY SAY.
HI MINIMALIST MONEY A LOT OF
GUYS SO YOU MOTHER THOSE IS TO
THE END THIS.
WILL NOT A UNITY KILEY SCHOOL
YOU LOOK AT A LOOK LIKE HOWELLS
AND LET'S SEE THAT THEY'LL PLAN
HAS YES.
MAIL PONGAL ALLOWABLE BUT HE
SOON IS V. [inaudible] SEVEN
FIVE FIVE SIX MY NAME IS
VERONICA RAINA I'M FROM GRANITE
BAY CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE NINE CHILDREN. FOUR OF
THEM ARE HOME SCHOOLED THAT
SOUNDS MA'AM NEWMAN OPPOSITION.
YES OPPOSITION I THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO TESTIFY. FOR THOSE OF YOU
JUST COMING IN WE'RE ASKING FOR
YOUR NAME AND OPPOSITION ONLY
PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS FERNANDO AND I'M
REPRESENTING MY SCHOOL SHE IS
SHE AND I'M OPPOSED TO SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX SOME ALUMINUM AS
IT IS SEND THEM ON MON SOMETHING
WHAT A PERSON OF THE LESS WELL I
SEE A CITY.
CSE.
ALL THANK I'VE FOR NOW NOW BLOOM
WHAT I SEVEN THINK [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
SENATE.
YET THE THING WHEN THE SAFE. FOR
THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI -- MY NAME IS ANNE AND I'M A
STUDENT FROM AMERICAN INDIAN
PUBLIC CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL AND
I'M HERE -- TO IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA AND I'M A STUDENT FROM
AMERICAN INDIAN PUBLIC CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO POLLS AS
BEEF.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME'S
WILLIAM PERRY I TEN AMERICAN
INDIAN PUBLIC CHARTER HIGH
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND AND AYE
OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
AND GIVE THE NEW GUY HOW MUCH
HARDER LAWMEN AYE OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
MARYLAND MARTINEZ I GO TO UNITY
HIGH SCHOOL AND CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
DANTE VEGA I AM A STUDENT FROM
UNITY HIGH CHARTER SCHOOL IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
AS HIS HIM FOR THE SIX HI MY
NAME IS LOSE MONEY.
AND I GO TO OPEN UNITY HIGH
SCHOOL.
CHARTER AND AYE OPPOSED TO THIS
SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
JEFF CREWS AND I'M FROM LOCAL
UNIT HIGH SCHOOL FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE AS PEACE
HAVE.
FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS LESLIE
BECAUSE I AM FROM OAKLEY UNITY
HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS AARON
I'M A STUDENT AT UNITY HIGH
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HI MY NAME IS
TEACH ON REASON I COME FROM THE
OBVIOUS OAKLAND FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
CAROL I AM A STUDENT AT UNITY
HIGH SCHOOL IN OAK AND OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE AS BE.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS A
MILLION JACKSON I'M A PUBLIC
CHARTER LAMB OF THE VISION
ACADEMY IN OAKLAND CURRENTLY IS
UC BERKELEY STUDENT AND I OPPOSE
SB FIFTY SIX SEVEN FIFTY SIX
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE THE TO HEAL I
MAY PUT CHARTER LOVE NIGHT.
OF FROM A BOOK SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES I CURRENTLY ATTEND UC
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME'S
JENNIFER.
MY NAME IS AN ESTIMATE OF SALMON
UP A PRO PARTING OF LIGHT HAS --
CHARTER COMMUNITY TENER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A THREE
SEVEN FIVE SIX OKAY.
HAVE AN INCENTIVE RAZA NUMB --
COMMUNITY HIGH SCHOOL ALUMNI AND
I OPPOSE SB THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
FOR THE FOLKS THAT JUST CAME IN
WERE ASKING FOR NAME AND
OPPOSITION ONLY PLEASE.
GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS CORPS
APPEARS YOU -- AND I DO NOT
AGREE WITH THE US BE -- SEVEN
FIVE SIX HI CHRISTINE RAINER --
I'M A THERAPIST AND PARENT OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL ALSO.
HI MY NAME IS GETTING THE SEVEN
AND I'M A FULL SEVEN SIX AS
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME CHEN
YOU CONCERN HI.
A PORTION NORTH.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI I VILLAGE IN
THE DOOR.
NO.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
THE CHANNEL -- TOOLS OF SEVEN
FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS THAT IS THE
STUFF THAT I OPPOSE.
THE SEVEN FIFTY SIX HELLO MY
NAME IS -- IN A CLINICAL FROM
WEST SACRAMENTO MOTHER OF SIX
KIDS -- OPAL'S STRONG GLOBAL'S
FROM SAYS BE SEVEN FIFTHS.
FIVE SIX HELLO MY NAME IS THE
FINISH OF CHEN CAUGHT ON
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MADE TO
CONTINUE I OPPOSE.
A BILL. SEVEN FIFTY FIFTY FIVE
THE SIX HELLO MY NAME THE TOWN
THE KITCHEN GONE MOBILE.
SEVEN FIFTY MY NAME IS INNA.
MY MOTHER I DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JANA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KARENA IN OUT MOTHER
OF TWO AND OPPOSE BILLS AS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HI MY NAME IS THE
NEW ERA.
I DON'T SUPPORT [inaudible]
SB. SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS A
NEW LOW I DON'T OPPOSE IT IS
THIS BILL ON THE FLOOR.
MY NAME IS PETER GOMEZ AND I
POSES BILLS.
HAS BEEN SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME ELIMINATION GOT INCOME
MOBILE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME MODEL KIT
NOT BILL. FOR SEVEN FIVE SIX MY
NAME IS RICHEST LOVE LOW AS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME A PLUS
CAREER PULLED THROUGH NO.
HIS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HI MY NAME IS
PETER.
I DON'T KNOW OPPOSE HIS BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
THIRTY ON THE FORM NO ON SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX I EUGENIA AND OF
THE POST IS SEVEN FIVE IS.
SIX MY NAME IS SET THE SLOB AYE
OPPOSED [inaudible]
SEVEN FIFTY SIX THANK.
MY NAME IS A RESPOND THOROUGHLY --
POST.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX SIMEON GANT WITH
THE FORTUNE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME HIGHLY
SEE DOUBLE HUNG.
HAVE POST IS C. B. IS BEING.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME AT NUMBER
THE RULES NO IS TO BE A SEVEN
FIFTY SIX MY NAME WITH LIKE THE
MEDICAID OFFICE [inaudible]
I A NO [inaudible] SEVEN B..
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI MY NAME IS
THERE IS A HUGE INCOME.
FINAL BILL IS BI.
SEVENTY TWO SIX MY NUMBER
NINETEEN UP MOST.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME THE
THERE'S THE BILLABLE PERSONAL AS
V..
SEVEN FIFTY SIX PETER RECORD
THROUGH [inaudible]
LOW.
SB. SEVEN FIVE SIX FOR THOSE IN
THE AUDIENCE IF YOU WANT TO SHOW
THAT YOU LIKE SOMETHING WE DO
THIS WE DO NOT CLAP.
I IMMEDIATE COVERAGE YOU I'M NOT
VIEW IS.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX I KNOW OTHERS DO
SO ON FOR HIM.
THE PERSON COOLEY.
MY NAME IS THAT A COUPLE OF A
AND AYE OPPOSED.
SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS THE
DEALER GULLIVER.
I LOAD OF OPPOSITE.
VIEW.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME VICTOR
ECHO A LIVE.
UP BULLS AS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS
MARGARET FORTUNE ON THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO FORTUNE SCHOOL
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX I AM ARENA I AM
AGAINST THE SB.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SIX HI MY
NAME IS A RENOWNED ALEC AND I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO ASK AS A
PARENT TO VOTE NO LITTLEFIELD
SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME WILL LADY -- NO C. B..
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS LATEST
OF CORDOVA I AM NO FOUR SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS.
NOR IS BE -- SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY
NAME IS SURGERY WILK I AM
FRIENDS ELEVEN KIDS -- FROM CO A
CHARTER SCHOOL.
I'M OPPOSE.
SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA SINCE SKI I'M HERE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS
GLOBAL SOLUTIONS KALRA AYE
OPPOSED TO VIEW.
THE AS BE IS.
SEVEN FIVE SIX AND I'M SORRY TO
SAY YESTERDAY AND SEND ALONG
MA'AM JUST NAME IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO TESTIFY WE
GOT YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE VISIT NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE HEROES NO YES WE
ARE.
AND I'M IS THERE A POND AND I
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS LUKE
BE WHERE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CODY BILL AND I
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS MIKE
IF YOU'LL AND I OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS AMY
BIEHL AND AYE OPPOSED SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX I AM AARON HUNT
AND I OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS
GRAYSON NINE POSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX I AM RONNIE
EARNING POACHING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS SHERRY.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HANNAH ALCORN AND I
OPPOSE BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS JACK
COPS ANDI OPPOSE THE BILLS SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS MY
NAME IS MAGGIE HOBSON AND I
OPPOSE BILL SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS MANY
HOPS AND I OPPOSE BILL S. P..
SEVEN FIVE SIX HI MY NAME IS
MARGIE TO GEORGIA FROM CLEAN
DALY CHARTER HIGH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MONICA FLOORS WHAT
THEN I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY WENT OFF
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ANIMAL I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS CASEY CARPENTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AYE HELENA VERY AND I
MY NAME IS VICTORIA MCINTYRE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A SPELL.
MY NAME IS KAYLA TO GEORGIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMILY MARTIN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE HAYCOCK AND I
MY NAME IS JANELLE SHERMAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DARCY BILL YES I WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OLGA TURN OAKLAND
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NAY ALLOW LESKO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALPHA COULD YOU KNOW
FROM END OF A TETHER SCHOOLS LA
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX THE NUMBER IS
MEDINA PLEASE ALWAYS ON MY MIND
THEY WANT US TO THE AFTER THEY
LEFT THE SQUARE LAST END OF A
CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN A POOR ONE UPPER BREAST SIZE
IS VERY.
SEE THE COMPLETE BY.
SIX HELLO THERE YOU SEE THAT ARE
MEANT THAT FAMILY COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT MANAGER AT THE V.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN EAST LOS
ANGELES STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION
OF SEVEN FIVE SIX GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JOHN IKE AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WESLEY
CHARTER SCHOOL HERE IN THE
THOMAS -- NEIGHBORHOOD OF
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS STEVE
COREBANK OF FOUNDING PARENT OF
WHAT'S THE CHARTER SCHOOL ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND A RESIDENT
OF DISTRICT SIX THANK YOU.
ALEXA GREENLAND'S CAN VOTER
CHARTER SCHOOL SAN DIEGO PARENTS
AND CHARTER SCHOOL EMPLOYEE.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU CHOOSE
CHILDREN OVER POLITICS AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WAIT ASH BRENNER ALL TO SCHOOLS
SAN DIEGO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX I LOVE SOME OF
THE KAMAL MARTIN REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT.
PARENT URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX THIRTY GRAF
SUPERINTENDENT VISIONS IN
EDUCATION STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING TO ADD A WHOLE LE
SACRAMENTO BOARD OF EDUCATION
TRUSTEE FOR AREA FOR
INTERPERSONAL PARENT HERE IN%
SACRAMENTO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SPELL THANK YOU.
JOHN GERARD CHIEF ACADEMIC
OFFICER PROVISIONS AND EDUCATION
STAND AGAINST THIS BILL.
CAROL REMAIN ON MY DAUGHTER GOES
TO INSPIRE CHARTER SCHOOL AND
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE AND I AM
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I VOTE NO FIRST.
NO FOUR SEVEN FIVE SIX LONG LIVE
CHARTER SCHOOL.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA DID THAT
AND I POST THIS BILL
[inaudible]
HI MANY.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN MULLIN AND
I AM IN EXCEL STUDENT AND I FELL.
HI -- GABRIELLA MULLIN AND HER
MOM AND WE HOME SCHOOL THROUGH A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO KEEP HIM IS LOPEZ
HAVE ASSIGNED ACOSTA FOURTEEN
SCHOOL IN THOMAS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELISE ERA AND
I'M A PARENT I HAVE FOUR IS BY
YOUR PUBLIC SCHOOL AND STOCKTON
SO I OPPOSE AND THE SB SEVEN
FIVE OF SIX HI MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER ALSO NINE WITH ROCKET
SHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LET ME NUMBER IS THAT ON THE
COLORADO DOUBLE DON'T KNOW I
LAYS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
ADDRESS LEBRON AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING ROCKET SHIP AND ALL
THE ADVOCATING FOR ALL THAT THE
CATION.
IN I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
WELL.
MY NAME IS OLIVER OF SYRIA AND
THE GUY COME FROM OUR CONCORD
AND I AM A PERSON FOR THE THIS
MAYOR.
HI AND COULDN'T DELAY ANY I HAVE
TO GET FROM ROCKET SHIP CONCORD
AND THEY'RE ENTITLED INFLOWS
GREAT AYE OPPOSED TO SPEND THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRIS ABOUT BRAIN
WITH ROCKET SHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ME NUMBER IS PAUL LET ME HOLD I
WROTE COULD YOU AND CONCORD
EMAIL BONE GORDAN ALL.
IS B..
SEVEN FIVE SIX THE NUMBER IS A
SILLY THING WHILE MEDIAN
ROCKETSHIP IMMOBILE ONE NOISE V.
C..
HELLO ME NUMBER IS THE ANNA.
AMY CALL VIOLET SCHOOLING
CONCLUDE THAT OKAY CHEAT THE
MOBILE WHAT ALLIES BE.
CHARLIE MEN SKIP BAY AREA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALEX THROUGH ENGINEER I OPPOSE
BILL.
WITH ONE ARM AND SHOOK AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALICE CORRECTION GO
AYE OPPOSES BILL.
CAMILLE VOELKER PARENT AND
TEACHER WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EMILY IN THIS IS EMILY AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M WAS
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LEAH CLOSE GONNA
CLOSE THIS BILL.
TIME TO GET A LOCAL.
I AM STONE APPLES. SEVEN FIVE
SIX MY NAME IS I'M ENGLISH CALL
THE FATHER OF FOUR I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL MS B..
SEVEN FIVE SIX OUR RECORDS OFTEN --
BOTH HIS BILL. THREE SHOULD YOU
PRESIDENT -- INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL OPPOSED HIS BILL.
WHEN IN THE JOURNAL DOING
KNOWING THIS BILL?
I LEVEL AND THAT IS A AND
OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA THIS IS HOPE
SHE'S IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
INSPIRED THANK YOU FOR OPPOSING --
AS P. [inaudible]
SEVEN FIVE SIX THIS MISSION.
I'M A PARENT OF THREE KIDS AND I
STRUGGLE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
IGOR CORE PLESSER -- CHARTER.
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
SB SEVEN SIX I OPPOSE IT.
MY NAME IS OXANA AND I'M A
PARENT OF A CHILD.
AND ASK YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE CHOOSE OUR CHILDREN OVER
POLITICS THANK YOU.
ELAINE I'M A GROWN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HEY THERE MY HORN ALL BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS TRACY
SUCH WELL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER DRAKE AND
I AM THE MOTHER OF A DAUGHTER
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MCKINNEY I'M
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I TO STUDENTS
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM RUNNING YELLIN FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M FROM SAN
PIETRO MY DAUGHTER IS A STUDENT
WITH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRYSTAL DUNN I
AM WITH AYE THE CHARTER SNAP TO
KIDS AND STRONGLY OPPOSES THEM.
AND HI MY NAME IS TRACY TERMS
DOWN THERE AND I'M WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I POSE SB. SEVEN
FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY HOPE SEE I'M
A PARENT OF FOUR BOYS WITH
INSPIRED CHARTER AND I OPPOSE SB
SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE PETERSON
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST WITH KEPT AREA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
SENATE BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX WHEN IS IT IS AN
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S DOESN'T MEDINA.
AND I OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN AYE OPPOSES
Và.
MY NAME IS ALI NAY POSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS DAISY AND
AYE OPPOSES.
MY NAME IS CLAY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WELL IN THE POLLS IS
DUE.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TREVOR AND I OPPOSE
MY NAME IS NATE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VICTOR AND I OPPOSE
PLAY IS IN GERMAN OF THE BOARD I
OPPOSE.
SB SEVEN FIVE SIX PLEASE.
TAKE PLEASE CONSIDER MY POSITION.
MY NAME IS ANDREA AND OPPOSE
THIS BILL -- MY NAME IS -- JOE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SURGE SENSOR AND I
OPPOSE BILL.
MY NAME IS JOHNNY AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OFFERED ON AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAULINE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AARON I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS WITH ALL THE
LOPEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS ALISA AND AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MASON I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS THE LARGER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANNE AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
I MEAN NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN IT TO
MY MOTHER WHEN I WAS GOING TO
KEEP HIM UPON WEST LA.
MY NAME FOR ME IF I BOTH THE PEW.
HI MY NAME IS SHIRLEY TURNER
POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL -- MY NAME IS JASMINE
I OPPOSE THIS BILL MY NAME IS
HERE AND I POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LISTEN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MERRY BILL AND I PULL
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BE.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS
WALTER A MOTOR FROM THE SUNDAY
THEY SOUND AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ABOVE AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SECRETED IN THE AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL MY NAME IS ON A
TOTALLY AYE OPPOSED HIS BAIL.
MY NAME IS A LEAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS YOUR M. OPPOSES THE
BILL.
MY NAME IS ANNA I OPPOSE THIS
MY NAME IS OLGA AND OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS I'M NOT I AM BOYS
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EILEEN I'M ALMOST
FOUR I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GALINA AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA AND I'M
STONE WHAT PULLED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OLGA I AM OPPOSED
VISITED.
MY NAME IS RUSSELL AVAIL AND I
POSE AS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS DIBBLE
AYE OPPOSES BLOOM.
MY NAME IS EUGENE I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A COMMON AYE OPPOSED
TO HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FRANCINE I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MONIQUE PHILLIPS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TO KILL.
MY NAME IS TO GO BE PHILLIPS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KIMBERLY WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF
GATEWAY COMMUNITY CHARTERS WE
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH PLATZ I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KELLY PLATT AND I
JULIA JONES I A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS VIA VOICE AND I
HOME SCHOOL WITH THREE KIDS
THROUGH CORPS PLASTER CHARTER
FOUGHT PLASTER SCHOOL -- AND
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS JORDAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO SWOOP EDUCATOR TEACHER.
HOME SCHOOLING MY CHILDREN PRO
CHOICE NO ON TWO FIFTY SIX MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE BE TO
VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA I HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY HOME SCHOOLED MY
CHILDREN FOR SIX YEARS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ICE OF STANDING ALL STUDENT NAME
IN OPPOSITION I AM RACES I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLEVIATE TOOK I'M
INTENDING INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW ALONG AN
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARK LANDFILLS TO
SPILL.
MY NAME TO OPEN A POSSIBILITIES.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIE CARPENTER
AND I'M A STUDENT AT INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME STANDING CARPENTER
AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
THE NAME IS ALLEY ON A CARPENTER
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSH -- CARPENTER
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SUSIE AND ANY CAN I
OPPOSE A SPELL.
MY NAME IS LOSING ON A CAMPUS
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SAM NUNN AGAIN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANET CAN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GALINA STOP I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS BEN CHAVEZ AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND BIG
GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
MANY.
MY NAME IS KERRY SHATTERS
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS DEAN OF RUSSIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M I'M COMMITTEE NOTED THAT I
ATTEND GIPSON SICKLY JUSTIN
ATTENDS ON SEIKALY SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY IN AYE OPPOSED
TO SPELL.
I'M AS WELL THE RATE IS I TANK
IT CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JENNA
CANALIS I ATTEND CASE STACEY
INSIDE AS A AND I'LL BE
ATTENDING SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY.
BUT I POSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M NICOLE HERNANDEZ AND I
ATTEND CASE TO SEE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
NOT IN A SALON DEAL KIP CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
KATHY WILSON KIP -- ACTUALLY
POSES BILLS WELL.
US ZERO SALAS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL AS WELL -- CAESAR
THE CON AND I OPPOSE HIS BILL.
TURNING ON A OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M HOMES EARLY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THIS IS A PARTICULAR POSES BILL.
I'M DANIEL HERNANDEZ AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER TAKE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND OPPOSE HIS BILL.
LAYLA ALASKA'S AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY A BILL FROM ACADEMY OF ON THE
CHARTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BRENDA SALAS AND AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX ALL UNITS OF AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOCELYN BOTTOM LINE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WHENEVER AN ANGEL PERFORMED MORE
BUT THEN ON THIS YT THIS THING
BECAUSE THEY IF SOMEONE WILL
FIND IN THE PRESENT DAY.
MUCH BETTER THAN HE IS BUT THEN
ON SEVENTH AT THE SCENE WITH HIS
FACE.
HI HANDLING NOT IS AN AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THE MOST YES AND THERE WAS A
BILL.
NOW ON SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX ON THE ONE KING
SANTIAGO I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HAVE ANY PRINCES CUTS ROCKET
SHIP WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA MILES AND
THE MOTHER OF THREE KIDS
VISITORS IN THE OLD IN THE
CHARTER COR PLACER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK.
MIND NAME IS RICKY.
I KNOW. FIVE B.. SEVEN FIVE SIX
BECAUSE MY FATHER SO HE DOESN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH HERE POSTAL
SERVICE.
SUSAN AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
VICTORIA MAKE SURE TO CORA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OKAY AS KIM OPPOSING THE BILL AS
BE -- SEVEN FIVE SIX PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
THANK YOU.
HERE NOW IS AN OPPOSE HIS BILL.
THE CHANNEL -- UP WAS THIS BILL --
ANGELINA RIVER NEW YORK AND MY
DAUGHTER IS AN EXCELLENT STUDENT
ENVISIONS AN EDUCATION AND I
WANT MY DAUGHTER TO HAVE A
CHOICE PLEASE VOTE NO ON SEVEN
FIVE SIX MY NAME IS SIGN A
GLADYS AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME ONLY ZUCKERMAN I OPPOSES
A BILL OF MYNAME IS ALICE
GLADYS I'M A FATHER OPPOSE THIS
BILL SMILE THE ALL.
MY NAME'S UREA OPPOSED HIS BILLS
AND BY.
SIX MY NAME IS SURE WHAT THEY
SEE AND I OPPOSE BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS THE OF
THE CARE ADAM AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME WILL IN DELIVERING YOU
I'M FATHER HAIKOU FOR KEYS AND
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
UNDER MUCH OF I AM REALLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS YURI WOULD AGO -- IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
TO BILL THIS IS BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME'S MOBILE
SOME SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL
COUNCILMEMBER FROM RICHMOND AND
AN ORGANIZED WITH ACE AND
RESPECTFULLY FOR MANY
COMPLICATED REASONS I ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SYLVIA OPENING AS A MEMBER
COMMUNITY.
AT SUN WITH A INCOME CALL
TELLEMENT TREE SCHOOL AND WE
STRONGLY APPROVE. SEVEN FIFTY
SIX AND PLEASE REGULATE CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
A LITTLE I'M FROM LA -- BUT A
LOT OF MINORITIES DON'T HAVE
RATIFICATION SO I'LL POLLS --
SEVEN FIFTY SIX FOR MY KEYS AND
CASE AND I ARE BOTH OF THESE MEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANITA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE OF
THE AND THE NUMBER OF MONEY UP
IT'LL TELL.
MAIL PHONE LAW AND THAT LICENSE
IS SEVEN SEAT THE THING WITH AND
SEE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LILIA ME
THAT AND I OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS ALL I
AND I OPPOSE SEVEN FIFTY SIX SB
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY KIDS GO TO
SCHOOLS PLEASE DON'T CLOSE THEM.
MY NAME IS A FIGURE NOW WHICH I
AM A STUDENT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SMARTER GREEN OF A
CHIN I AM FROM INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
I'M HERE ARE YOU SKIN I AM A BUS --
AS BE.
SEVEN FIVE TO SIX GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SIX ON ALL COUNTS CAN.
ON THE OPPOSITE.
HAS BE SEVENTY SIX THE SIX MY
NAME IS OLGA I AM OPPOSE AS THE
SEVEN FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS
HELENE A MOTHER AND I OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI AM CENTER
MARK.
FIRST GENERATION MEXICAN
AMERICAN I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CHERYL BURKE HARD AND I OPPOSE
SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX TINY OTHER
SUNSHINE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
UNLESS THE ZERO SKIN UP CLOSE TO
SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX IT IS THAT IS
THAT A BOOK OF I AM OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
A GENESIS THREE NINE MARBLES
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SEBASTIAN COGNITIVE AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TAMMY
STANTON I'M FROM LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING CAMINO NO WAY ABOUT
CHARTER ECONOMY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SO IN MINNESOTA CAMINO KNOW WHAT
CHARTER ACADEMY AND I OPAL WAS
THIS BILL. EIGHTY RAMIREZ CAMINO
CHARTER CAN I MEAN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME ISN'T.
MARIA BUT I NEEDS K. INSPIRED
CHARTER PAYMENT IN A STRONGLY.
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ITALIA OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN EVERY WAS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FLORA CUT AT THE
CHANCE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PATTY
LOPEZ I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA AND I
OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ANDREA TO ME ON I OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE PARENTS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHAT SCHOOL
THEY WANT THEIR CHILDREN TO GO.
TO THANK YOU.
HI I AM A STUDENT FROM INSIDE AS
I WAS A COUNTY JANET POSES.
THIS BILL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME VISIBLE PRESENCE
SENIOR CAN AS SENATE THE
COLLEGIATE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
OF MY NAME'S HARLEY THAT SAYS TO
ME I'M A STUDENT I COULD SO THE
COLLISION I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
MY NAME'S BRIANNA GOMEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ADAM KAY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELENA DRIVING YOU CAN
AYE OPPOSED AS BE SEVEN FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS
MAHDI NOT AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS OLGA
POWER BUTTON IS STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL SB.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE SIX HI MY NAME
IS MERION KILLIAN I'M A RETIRED
PUBLIC SCHOOLTEACHER AND I AM
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OLGA
BECAUSE TO I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSING THE BILL SB SEVEN FIFTY
SIX I'M FROM CHARTER INSPIRE
SCHOOL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELA CHILDREN
AYE OPALS THIS VIEW.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALEX
TOLD ME AND I AM HERE TO WILL NO
ONE IS THE SEVEN FIVE SIX BILL
THANKS.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALEXANDER KISSES
AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL SEVEN
FIVE SIX THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME IS VICTORIA KIDS
AND I'M OF COURSE BILLS.
SEVEN FIVE SIX GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALL OF THIS GOING AYE
OPPOSED BILLS SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS AN
ARABIAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX MY NAME IS MATT
RABY AND I OPPOSE ALL BILLS THAT
GIVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CONTROL OVER THE CITIZENS.
HI MY NAME IS A LEAN AND
GOVERNOR CAN I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN AT HER EYES AND CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I POSIT STILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS YELENA
BELLS CAN I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LEE --
THE DISCO -- BULLETS IN THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE TEA
ON THE FOR DO YOU CAN WORK FROM --
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL SB SEVEN FIVE
SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M THE TNT OF TRIANGLE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BE.
SEVEN FIVE SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
TINA SELENIUM COOK I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA KOREAN AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KATIE TO OAK AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A LITTLE AND I'VE
BEEN LEAVING SICKER ME UNLESS
SINCE THE MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
THREE AND MIKE HE'S GOAL TO
CHARTER SCHOOL SALIVA PULLS
VIDEO IS B.. SEVEN FIVE SIX I'M
MARC GROSSMAN -- STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX FAMILIES OF
RUSSELL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
SB.
SEVENTY SEVEN FIVE SIX I'M IN A
LOT COVENANT DOES THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SVETLANA BECAUSE
LOW MORE SUN I HAVE FIVE KIDS
AND I POSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA MAY HUGH --
I'M A TEACHER CALIFORNIA
MONASTERY PROJECT AND I HAVE
KIDS IN A CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL WHO TOOK.
TIME AND THIS. SEVENTY FIVE SIX
BILL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL MANNING IS
GOING TO REGION.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE BECOME
CLOSE I'M FROM ORANGE I'M A
PARENT AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLIVIA I AM A
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA CAMPOS.
I AM A STUDENT IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
JOHNSON I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
NAME JOIN ORTEGA IS STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS NEXT MONTH SO I'M A
FATHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JULIE FULLERTON COSTA MESA
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
JAMES FULLERTON I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOSHUA COLEMAN
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
I VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ME BRANHAM AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DONNA BRANDON AND I
PLEDGE TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS NOW A BRAND AYE
OPPOSES SPELL.
MY NAME IS ELLA BRENNAMAN AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA BRANNEN I'M A
PARENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A GERMAN ASIK AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NAME IS CAME FROM A SECOND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME INFORMATION ON SECOND I
AM.
MY NAME IS RACHEL MONASTIC I'M A
PARENT AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
I AM AN EIDETIC FROM ROSEVILLE
AND PERRIN AND I'M OPPOSE IN
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS OLGA.
BY AND PRINT -- I WILL PUT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIA ASYLUM FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME SAID LINE UP WITH THE
JOKE I'M FROM ANTELOPE AND I
BOUGHT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE SELLARS ON
FROM SIMI VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SCOTT BARTON THE PRINCIPLE THE
PRESCHOOL UC SAN DIEGO AND I
POSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MELA FOR CHECK
PARENTS FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DENNIS OLIVER CHICKEN
AYE POSES BILL.
MY NAME IS THE TOWN I'VE GOT A
FULL I'M A PRESCHOOL TEACHER IN
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LONG NMBER
OF COLA I'M A PARENT OF THREE
AND FROM SAID SACRAMENTO AND
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE PRATT
I'M A MASTER OF EDUCATION WITH A
CALIFORNIA CRINGED CREDENTIAL.
AND I HOME SCHOOL MY FAMILY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME STEVEN PRATT I'M A
HOME SCHOOLING PARENT FROM
FULSOME AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN I AM A
PARENT OF A STUDENT AT HIS HOME
COLLEGE PREP AND APPLES AS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATASHA ROBINSON
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE SEE.
THREE HELLO MY NAME IS CHELSEA
NAY CABBAGE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS FRANCESCA ROSE
BAR SKI I'M CONCERNED PARENT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARYLAND AGAIN YOU
AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MENDELSOHN LESS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
DOCTOR PAN.
I THANK THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
AND SEND DRAWS A PRE SHEET -- US
THE CONCERNS THAT -- EVEN THE
PROPONENTS -- HAVE -- BROUGHT UP --
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE I
THINK WE THE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THEIR CHALLENGES ACTUALLY AND
BOTH SYSTEMS RIGHT IT'S IT'S AND
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
AS MY SICK BOTH SYSTEMS I WOULD
SAY IS THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE --
EXCELLENT PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THERE ARE SOME WHO NEED HELP --
WE HAVE A CENTERS SCHOOLS WE
HAVE SOME THAT ARE.
NOT SO -- SO I THINK IT'S LESS
ABOUT.
JUST THE SYSTEM BUT AT SAME TIME
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE OVERALL.
THE CALL INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BUT CHALLENGES
WHERE -- RESOURCES ARE TOO
FRAGMENTED ACROSS -- POTENTIALLY
WITH MULTIPLE SCHOOLS -- WE MAY
HAVE CHALLENGES WHERE -- YOU
HAVE -- THAT SOMEONE.
THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT LOCAL
CONDITIONS -- AND I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD.
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT SORT OF THE WAY
YOUR BILL STRUCTURE TO SIR LIKE
WELL WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS WE
SHOULD HAVE THE CITIZENS BE MADE
MORE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL RIGHT --
AT AT THAT SCHOOL BOARD LEVEL
WHERE YOU'LL BY ELECTED SCHOOL
BOARDS BY.
THE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
LIVING IN THAT THE COMMUNITY WHO
ARE IN THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
AND AND LEADERSHIP AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE A PRIMARY ROLE AND
AND AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS.
ABOUT SCHOOLS AND PLACEMENT AND
AND AND AND RESOURCES -- AS SO I
GUESS. ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS
THAT ARE WHEN ISSUES CONCERNS I
HAVE IS IS THAT SO WHAT THIS
BILL SAYS IS THAT SIR.
MORATORIUM ON LESS AND THERE'S A
SET OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THE
UNLESS OUR AND IN MANY OF WHICH
ACTUALLY FRANKLY I FAVOR RIGHT --
AND I GUESS I WOULD FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE AND SAYS SAYING WHAT
WE HAVE A MORATORIUM UNLESS AND
WE'RE WAITING.
FOR BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S SOME
BILLS ON THE CELL LEADER LOOKING
AT SOME OF THESE THINGS. TO JUST
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARDLY GO OUT
AND SAY WELL ACTUALLY WHAT WE
WANT IS THAT WE'RE GONNA SAY.
CHARTER SCHOOL DECISIONS SHOULD
BE MADE AT THE LOCAL THAT THE
UNLESS PART GREAT THAT THAT THE
CHARTER SCHOOL DECISION YOU KNOW
THAT.
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER TO
APPROVE OR NOT A CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT'S WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARY RIGHT.
THAT SHOULD CERTAINLY BE
DECISION MADE BY THE ELECTED
LEADERSHIP -- THAT THE SCHOOL
BOARD -- THAT THEY SHOULD TAKING
CONSIDERATION WHAT THE RESOURCES
ARE.
AND THAT PERHAPSYOU KNOW I
THINK ONE FOR IS ANOTHER
PROVISION IS IS THAT THE THAT
THE THAT THERE'S THERE'S SOME
STATEWIDE EXAMINATION APPRECIATE
THAT THERE'S A REPORT COMING OUT
FROM THE ON THE GOVERNOR HAS A
TASK FORCE THAT.
WE'RE HOPING TO HEAR FROM AND
AND AND AND AND AND I GUESS
SEVERAL WEEKS -- AND A COUPLE
MONTHS -- WHICH ACTUALLY
HOPEFULLY WILL ALSO INFORM Là
JUST.
EITHER LEGISLATION OTHER
LEGISLATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AS WELL.
SO I GUESS I WANTED BECAUSE
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO AND
REALIZING TIS IS THE COMMITTEE
MEETING RIGHT HERE AND I HAD
SOME OPTING TO DISCUSS WITH
BILL'S PROPONENTS IN OPPOSITION.
TO THINKING ABOUT RE FRAMING THE
BILL THIS WAY -- MOVING FORWARD
AND AND AND MAKING AMENDMENTS --
TO IT THAT WILL NOT BE TAKEN UP
HERE BUT THE FUTURE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD REFLECT THAT.
TYPE OF APPROACH IS IS SAYING A
MORATORIUM UNLESS STATE ASK FOR
WHAT YOU WANT GREAT IT'S
BASICALLY WE WANT.
LOCAL DECISION MAKING WE WHAT
DOES WE WANT THAT KIND OF
EVALUATION IS BEING DONE.
AND THAT AND THAT WE WANT TO
POWER THE THE THE THE THE AND I
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
BELIEVE AND EMPOWER THE THE
PEOPLE IN SCHOOL DISTRICT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE.
BASICALLY MAKE THE DECISIONS
THAT NEED NEED TO MAKE -- ABOUT
ABOUT -- THESE DECISIONS SO I
WENT TO SUPPOSE THAT THE DOCTOR
PAN AS THE CHAIR -- I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY OF THESE AMENDMENTS
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS FOR
SENATOR DORADO TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES IN CONCEPT ON HER WAY TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
CORRECT BECAUSE THEY THEY SAID I
TELL I DON'T HAVE ANY AMENDMENTS
SPECIFIC AMEND ITS EITHER OKAY I
THINK IT THIS IS BASED ON THE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH -- BUT
WITH -- FOLKS -- BUT I THINK
IT'S A SORT OF A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND SO I I WANTED TO
POSE THAT -- BECAUSE I THINK I
WOULD FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
TAKING THAT KIND OF APPROACH
THAN.
THE CURRENT APPROACH WHICH IS
ACTUALLY DOING IS READING A
MORATORIUM AND THAT SAYS UNLESS
CERTAIN THINGS HAPPEN BUT AND
SAID LET'S JUST GO FOR THE
THINGS WE WANT AND THE SPECIFICS
WILL YOU KNOW.
I'M SURE YOU WILL GET WORKED OUT
OF ARTS IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFIC.
AMENDMENTS BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT
WOULD BE TAKING PLACE BUT THE
WORK ON ON THAT APPROACH WHICH
IS I. THANKS VERY MUCH IN LINE
WITH WHAT AT LEAST THE BILL.
AS I LOOK AT IT -- THIS TRYING
TO COMPLEX ANYWAY.
UNDERSTOOD SENATOR RUSSELL YES I
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU --
CENTER PAN AYE I DID SAY EARLY
IN MY OPENING REMARKS THAT I'M
AWARE OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CONCERNS -- AND I COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND WITH THE
CHAIR ON ON THESE CONCERNS
WITHOUT GETTING INTO OBVIOUSLY
ANY PARTICULARS RIGHT NOW -- AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
ANOTHER QUESTION YES GO AHEAD
NOT THAT THANK YOU SO -- SO I AS
I I'VE.
I'VE YEAH SAID IN TERMS OF
PARTICULARS I THINK AT LEAST IN
CONCEPT.
THE AGE ON SUGARS YOU SURE
THERE'S AGREEMENT THAT ON ENDS
ON THE PROVISIONS IN YOUR VERY
BILL -- THAT THAT THAT'S THE THE
THINGS WE'D BE LOOKING AT
CORRECT US YES OKAY ARE IN
CONCEPT THANK YOU BOTH.
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I WHAT
I WANT TAKE EVERYBODY FOR COMING
TO TESTIFY PARTICULARLY -- THOSE
CONSTITUENTS FROM THE TWENTY
FIRST SENATE DISTRICT I KNOW
THAT'S A SIX MAYBE A SEVEN HOUR
DRIVE AND PARTICULARLY ENJOYED
MEETING THE CHARTERS -- SCHOOL
STUDENTS YESTERDAY IN MY OFFICE.
I'M A PUBLIC OF I'M A PRODUCT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AS ARE MY
CHILDREN.
AND BUT I SUPPORT SCHOOL CHOICE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S GREAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS BAD CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS AVERAGE CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
AND CLEARLY -- THERE'S BEEN
PROBLEMS AROUND AUTHORIZATION IN
THE RE AUTHORIZATION PROCESS AND
SOMEBODY WHO'S PRO SCHOOL CHOICE
I ATE I ATE KNOWLEDGE I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO FIX IT --
THE CHAIR HAD A BILL EARLIER
THIS YEAR THAT'S ALREADY PASS
OUT OF THE SENT OVER OVER ON
THIS ON THE SENATE SIDE TERMS OF
GOD GREATER TRANSPARENCY WHICH I
THINK WE NEED.
AND AS MENTIONED BY DOCTOR PAN
GONNA SERIES OF BILLS A LOT OF
THEM INCORPORATING BUT YOU WANT
TO DO THAT SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
COMING HERE -- THE FIVE YEAR
MORATORIUM I MEAN THAT'S JUST
TAKING A SLEDGE HAMMER -- TO THE
PROCESS AND YOU KNOW THE
OPPONENTS MENTIONED THIS IS A
DELIBERATE DELIVERED IT
DELIVERED OF BODY WHICH I AGREE
WITH WHICH I I APPRECIATE.
I DON'T A FIVE YEAR MORATORIUM I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW YOU GET THAT
I JUST THINK THIS USE IN THE
COURSE OF POWER GOVERNMENT. TO
DENY A STUDENT CHOICE SO -- NOT
AND OBVIOUSLY NOT NOT CAN BE
WITH YOU TODAY -- AYE AYE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL
RADICALLY CHANGED MOVING FOR AND
WE'LL WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS --
PEOPLE ASK ARE YOU FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE STATE'S
GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION AND
I SAY NO BECAUSE BOTH A YOU KNOW.
ELECTIONS HAVE CONSEQUENCES AND
AND THIS IS WHAT THE MAJORITY
PEOPLE WANT I REALLY DON'T
BELIEVE THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WANT TO SEE.
THE BILL INNOVATION OF OF
SCHOOLS SCHOOL CHOICE SO NOT TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY HOPE YOU THAT
YOU WILL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. TO COME TO SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BENEFIT ALL
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER WILK
IF I CAN JUST -- COMMENT BRIEFLY --
THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THIS IS ABOUT LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING.
AND WE'VE NEVER STOPPED TO DO
THAT.
AND MOVE FORWARD IN A MUCH MORE
DELIBERATIVE INTEGRATED WAY AND
FUNCTIONING AS ONE SINGLE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM IT'S BECOME.
TO AND BUT THE RESOURCES.
COME FROM THE BROADER US SYSTEM.
AND THEY GO. TO TO SYSTEMS
THEY'RE COMPETING.
AND THAT'S NOT THE WAY PUBLIC
EDUCATION SHOULD FUNCTION.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CHOICE AND COMPETITION THAT
BASICALLY.
IS GOING IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
SO -- I'M A BIG PUBLIC EDUCATION
PERSON AS WELL THAT'S WHY JUMPED
INTO THIS THIS IS NOT A POPULAR
POSITION TO TAKE -- I HAVE MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS I HAVE OBVIOUSLY
MANY PUBLIC EDUCATION
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS WE HAVE
NONTRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T ALL
FUNCTION THE SAME WAY THIS PILOT
SCHOOLS MAGNET SCHOOLS IS ALL
KINDS OF SCHOOLS.
AND SO.
THERE'S A PARTICULAR SET OF
RULES AND REGULATIONS.
THAT HAVE APPLIED ONLY TO THE
CHARTERS AND MY ONLY.
POSITION HERE IS LET'S TAKE A
PAUSE.
SO THAT WE ALL PUT THE BEST
PRACTICES FORWARD AND FIX WHAT'S
WRONG.
AND SO I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHERE I'M COMING FROM AND
THAT'S WHY I JUMPED INTO.
INTO DOING THIS.
DID YOU WANNA.
NO OKAY I THINK SENATOR DRAWS
OAK WAS AT ALL SENATOR WILK.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU SAID
BUT FIVE YEARS IS NOT  PAUSE.
FIVE YEARS JUST NOT A PAUSE --
WE'VE DONE THIRTY YEARS WITHOUT
ANY.
ANY REFORMS THIRTY YEARS WITHOUT
IN THE ROOF RELEASE SIGNIFICANT
REFORMS SO.
THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT.
THAT WAS FAIR THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND I HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY EARLIER -- WILL BRING
RUN AROUND A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS -- AND I I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR -- FOR
RELEASED THE INITIATING THIS
CONVERSATION A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THERE IS A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY ACROSS THE STATE IN
THE SPACE -- A BIG -- DEBATED
SAY THE OBVIOUS -- BIG PUBLIC
SCHOOL ADVOCATES.
AND I KNOW THAT'S THAT THE GOALS
AND DESIRES THAT YOU HAVE AND I
AND I SHARE THEM -- AND BUT THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S WRONG
WITH OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS IS MUCH
BROADER THAN THIS ISSUE OF
CHARTERS.
AND I THINK IT'S SENATOR PAN
MANSION IN HIS REMARKS ND
OTHERS -- THAT ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM WE HAVE THE STRONG ONES.
CHARTER'S STRONG PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND WE ALSO HAVE ONES THAT ARE
JUST NOT DOING SO WELL.
AND THAT REQUIRE OUR ATTENTION
AND BUT IT'S AND IT'S MORE THAN
JUST ABOUT CHARTERS -- IT'S
ABOUT FINANCES.
IT'S ABOUT QUALITY -- IT'S ABOUT --
AT TEACHER TRAINING.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT --
AND THAT'S WHY I APPLIED TO YOUR
EFFORT TO GET INTO THE SPACE AND
INITIATE THESE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
YES LOOK AT HOW LOUD PORT IS TO
WHAT WE DO IS A STATE HOW MUCH
MONEY WE DIRECT TO IT IT'S IT'S
HUGE AND THE MORE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAVE THE BETTER.
AND I AND I DON'T -- IGNORE --
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE RAISING
AS IMPORTANT AND BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT KNOW THAT MIKE
OBSERVATIONS TODAY ARE NOT GOING
TO SURPRISE YOU.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GONNA
SURPRISE OTHERS BECAUSE WE I
TALKED ABOUT THEM IN JANUARY
WHEN WE PASSED THE TRANSPARENCY
BILL THAT.
ARE CHAIR -- ADVANCED AND WE HAD
THE CONVERSATION HERE IN
EDUCATION AND WE HAD THE
CONVERSATION ON THE FLOOR AND MY
OBSERVATIONS THEN -- APPLY NOW
WHICH IS THE THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNIZE SOME CONCERNS IN THIS
SPACE SUPERINTENDENTS RECOGNIZE
SOME CONCERT IN SPACE.
AND IT CREATED THIS TASK FORCE
TO WORK IN THIS AREA TO TRY TO
BRING PARTIES TOGETHER AND HAVE
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
WE COULD DO BETTER ACROSS THE
BOARD -- AND I THINK WE SHOULD
ALLOW THAT PROCESS TO GO FORWARD
AND NOT.
INTERFERE IN IT UP THROUGH
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS THAT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WHEN WE CAN ALWAYS
INITIATE THEM WE CAN ALWAYS STEP
IN AFTER WE HEAR THOSE THOSE
THOUGHTS IN THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT OF
IT.
SO MY MIND REMAINS OPEN.
ABOUT SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU HAVE RAISED BUT FOR ME AT
LEAST AND I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
GOING FORWARD WITH THAT
LEGISLATION I'D RATHER GIVE IT
THE LEGISLATION APPLIES -- AND
LET THE AT THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CHARTER COMMUNITY.
OF THE TEACHER COMMUNITY OF THE
STATE LEADERSHIP CONTINUE THEIR
WORK I HOPE THAT THAT IT'S
CONSTRUCTIVE WORK.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
THEIR THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS IF
THERE ARE ANY -- IN A IN A FEW
WEEKS AND THEN WITH THAT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SET UP SENATOR PAN.
I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT WERE
CLEARED THAT YOUR BILL ONLY.
THE DRESSES SEXUALLY NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS RIGHT SO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT CLOSING EXIST I
MEAN ASIDE FROM OUR SCHOOLS WHO
DON'T BEAT THE THE USUAL PROCESS
WOULD NOT CHANGING THAT SO IN
TERMS OF EXISTING CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
UNLESS THEY UNDERTOOK NEATLY
UNDER PERFORM AND AUTHORIZES ARE.
YOU ALRIGHT HE SAT RIGHT IT SAID
THIS IS THIS IS NOT NEW RIGHT
OKAY JUST WANTED.
TO BE SURE THAT SOMETIMES THERE
ISN'T THERE ARE
MISUNDERSTANDINGS.
THANK YOU CENTER PANCER ALSO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
COLLEAGUESUP I KNOW THIS IS A A
TOUCHES EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
WE HAD -- MEN AND WOMEN AND
FAMILIES TESTIFIED TODAY -- AS
PARENTS AS THE CHILDREN
THEMSELVES AS THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES AS EDUCATORS WE ALL
CARE ABOUT PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
IT'S BECOME.
UNFORTUNATELY -- NOT THE
ENVIRONMENT IS HAS NOT BEEN
THERE. TO MAKETHE CHANGES TO
FIX THE FLAWS TO MOVE FORWARD
AND TO MAKE PUBLIC EDUCATION
EQUAL FOR EVERYBODY ACROSS THE
BOARD SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. TO TAKE THAT
PAUSE IN A A AND HOPEFULLY WITH
SOME REFORMS OVER A VERY VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT WE CAN -- MOVE FORWARD AND
MAKE OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION THE
BEST SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
YOU CENTER AYE ROTH AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO HAVE A
MOTION.
SO I JUST SAY THAT WITH YOUR
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THE WHAT
WE DISCUSSED -- AND RECOGNIZING
ACTUALLY THAT -- WELL WE ARE
GOING SPEC TOGETHER SUPPORT THAT
THIS WOULD STILL BE A VEHICLE
FOR THIS DISCUSSION I WILL MOVE
THE BILL AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN TO WRESTLE.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE NO MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU ALL WHO CAME OUT TODAY.
OR I MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
ON TO CENTER PORTANTINO I THINK
I SAW HIM DOWN THERE
[inaudible]
OF SENATOR PORTANTINO WILL AT
THE ROOM CLEAR A LITTLE BIT.
AND I GET ON THE MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR
WHO NEEDS TO PRESENTS OF YOU CAN
EXIT THE ROOM QUIETLY THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL.
I JUST DON'T FEEL STRONGLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU HAVE TO
BILLS UP WITH US TODAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH SB EIGHTY SIX
I WOULD EXCELLENT ADAM AS YOU
EXIT PLEASE BE QUIET.
WE HAVE FOR THE BUSINESS TO DO
CENTER PORTANTINO BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
SINCE SINCE THIS IS THE MORNING
OF EASY BILLS.
I FIGURED I WOULD -- START WITH
ANOTHER EASY BILL -- AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT I'M SO EXCITED TO
BE HERE THIS MORNING THAT WHEN I
JUST STEPPED OUTSIDE I TRIPPED
ON THE STEPS.
AND HAD THE MOST AMAZING
[inaudible]
ROLL.
I FELL AS GRACEFULLY AS I COULD.
THIS IS A TRUE STORY I SAID TO
THE AUDIENCE HOW MANY PEOPLE SAW
ME FALL AND EVERY HAND WENT OUT.
SO I ALTHOUGH WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE
OKAY YES I Y. ONLY TWISTED MY
LEFT ANKLE MY RIGHT KNEE AND MY
BACK BUT OTHER THAN THAT.
IT'S ALL GOOD WHICH BRINGS ME TO
SB EIGHTY SIX WHICH REQUIRE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONDUCT AGE
APPROPRIATE LOCKED DOWN AND
MULTI OPTION DRILLS FREE SCHOOL
YEAR SO KIDS DON'T TRIP.
WHEN THEY LEAVE THE BUILDING --
I DO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT --
WHEN I PUT IN THIS BILL I WAS
NOT AWARE THAT MS BATES HAD A
SIMILAR BILL AND CERTAINLY I'M
GOING -- TO AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO FOR HER AND WORK WITH
HER AND YOU KNOW HAVE DEEP
RESPECT FOR HER.
AND WOULD NOT OF INTRODUCED A
BILL IF I'D KNOWN SHE WAS
ALREADY ON THIS TOPIC SO JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT -- SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAVE
BECOME AN ALL TOO FREQUENT
OCCURRENCE IN THE UNITED STATES
UNFORTUNATELY -- AND CALIFORNIA
IS NOT IMMUNE TO START DESPITE
OUR STRONG LAWS -- LOCKDOWN
DRILLS ARE BEING INDUCTED BY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FOR PAST
TWENTY YEARS THEY ARE CARRIED
OUT AT THE DISCRETION OF EACH
SCHOOL AND ARE NOT MANDATED FOR
FREQUENCY.
LIKE FIRE AND EARTHQUAKE DRILLS
A WASHINGTON POST ARTICLE CITES
A STAGGERING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO GUN VIOLENCE WHILE ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE BUT
TRAGICALLY ANOTHER HUNDRED FORTY
THREE HAVE.
BEEN KILLED IN TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR HAVE BEEN INJURED
WHILE ON CAMPUS AND AT THE AYE
REPORT REVEALED SCHOOLS WERE THE
SECOND HIGHEST RISK LOCATION.
FOR AN ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENT
FREQUENCY OF FIRE DRILLS ARE
MANDATE AND REGULATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO ONCE A
MONTH IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AND
NOT LESS THAN TWICE A YEAR IN
SECONDARY SCHOOLS EARTHQUAKE
DRILLS ARE MANDATED AND
REGULATED TO FOUR TIMES PER YEAR
IN SCHOOLS.
AND DESPITE THE FREQUENCY OF
FIRE DRILLS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS NO
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN KILLED IN A
SCHOOL FIRE IN THE U. S. --
SINCE OUR LADY OF ANGEL SCHOOL
FIRE IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT SB
EIGHTY SIX WHICH ENSURE
ADMINISTRATORS TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
MORE EQUITABLY PREPARED BY STAFF
BUSHING A MINIMUM FREQUENCY.
OF AGE APPROPRIATE LOCKDOWN
DRILLS AND I WITH THIS
PERSPECTIVE WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ME AND RE
GAY ROUTE SHOW FROM THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES
SINCE IT'S ONLY YOU IF YOU NEED
TO TAKE FOR YOU MAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS HOWEVER I'LL BE BRIEF --
AND WE COULD WATCH A WITH -- IN
POTS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT LA UNIFIED SUPPORTS.
L. LA UNIFIED'S SORRY.
LA UNIFIED SUPPORTS SB EIGHTY
SIX SOMETHING SENATOR PORTANTINO
FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE FORWARD
WHILE LA UNIFIED CONDUCTS
MONTHLY FIRE DRILLS THINKING
THROUGH AID AND MONTHLY
EARTHQUAKE DRILL SINKING.
TO TWELVE LOCKDOWN INCIDENTS ARE
A MUCH MORE COMMON OCCURRENCE
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SCHOOL
YEAR.
THERE WERE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
TO LOCK DOWN INCIDENTS HAD LA
UNIFIED SEVENTY NINE FIRES
REPORTED AND THANKFULLY IN ZERO
EARTHQUAKE INCIDENTS THAT'S FAR --
ARE LOCKDOWN PROCEDURES ARE USED
TO PROTECT STUDENTS IN A VARIETY
OF SIR CONTENT BECAUSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE DNGER
IS OUTSIDE.
INCLUDING GUNSHOTS HER NEARBY
AND POLICE ACTIVITY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AS A RESULT WE
BELIEVE THAT LOCKDOWN DRILLS
WORK TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
AS BE EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
BROUGH BACK THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR GLAZERS.
AN ANSWER PAN UPSET SENATOR
PORTANTINO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR SO THE BILL HAS BEEN
CHANGED NOW THAT.
ONLY AT OR IT DOESN'T REALLY
RIGHT MANDATE.
A LOCKDOWN DRILL ONCE A YEAR
FOUR TIMES A YEAR NOW IT SIMPLY --
ENCOURAGES THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY AT THEIR DISCRETION TO
CONSIDER DOING THAT AND AGE
APPROPRIATE WAY IS THAT RIGHT.
DO NOT USURPING LOCAL CONTROL ON
THIS CHOICE YOU'RE JUST GIVING
THEM GUIDANCE.
AND WHAT YOU THINK COULD BE A
HEALTHY THING TO DO RIGHT.
GOT IT GREAT HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL TO APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS CENTER PAN.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
SEPERTI I APPRECIATE -- THE THE
CHANGES TO THE BILL AND I AND
ALSO -- INCORPORATING SOME OF
THINGS I ALSO MENTIONED WHEN.
CENTER BATES BILL CAME BOARD WE
WANNA BE SURE WE PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN -- THAT INCLUDES FROM --
THE ANXIETY OR STRESS OF
THINKING THAT SOMEONE'S GOING TO
COME AND SHOOT THEM IN SCHOOL --
AND WHATEVER -- DRILLS WE DO
NEEDS O BE DONE AND APPROPRIATE
MANNER THAT DOES NOT -- THAT MAY
NOT THAT THE BILL ITSELF IS NOT
HARMFUL TO OUR CHILDREN SO I SO
THINK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
DRESSING THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PANCER WILK ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
NO MA'AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
PORTANTINO BEFORE YOU CLOSE YOU
ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
OKAY VERY GOOD YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY S. RIVAL.
VERY GOOD MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE SB EIGHTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WELL HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL SO
THAT OTHER -- MEMBERS CAN ADD ON
OR IT SENATOR PORTANTINO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM SEVEN SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I KNOW I'VE GOT SOME
WITNESSES COMING UP YEAH TAKE
YOUR TIME.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR -- FOR TAKING
SO MUCH TIME IN OUR DISCUSSIONS
LEADING UP TO THE COMMITTEE I
KNOW THIS IS A BILL THAT -- SHE
IN THE COUNCIL MEMBERS HAVE PUT --
ACTION CUT SENATORS HAVE PUT
SIGNIFICANT TIME IN LOOKING OUT
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS AND I
APPRECIATE.
THAT THIS BILL HAS GENERATED
SUCH THOUGHTFUL INQUIRY AND
RESEARCH AND TIME SO I
APPRECIATE THAT -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- TEENAGERS.
IN OUR COUNTRY ARE SLEEP
DEPRIVED.
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC
AND ACCORDING TO CONCLUSIVE
MEDICAL RESEARCH THE PRIMARY
CAUSE OF THE EPIDEMIC.
HIS EARLY SCHOOL START TIMES
THAT ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH THE
BIOLOGICAL SLEEP.
NEEDS OF ADOLESCENT CHILDREN
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL UPDATE CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATION CODE.
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH PARAMETERS
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL START
TIMES.
THE REGULAR SCHOOL DAY BEGINS
ACCORDING TO THE BILL NO EARLIER
THAN EIGHT THIRTY AM OR LATER AS
RECOMMENDED.
BY THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND MANY OTHER HEALTH AND
MEDICAL ORGANIZATIONS.
DESPITE DECADES OF OVERWHELMING
AND COMPELLING EVIDENCE OF THE
HARM TO TEENS HARM TO TEENS FROM
EARLY WAKE UP TIMES THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA SECONDARY
SCHOOLS ABOUT 80%.
STILL BEGIN BEFORE EIGHT THIRTY
AM SO EARLY THAT THEY PREVENT
MOST TEENS FROM GETTING THE
DOCTOR RECOMMENDED NINE HOURS OF
SLEEP. FOR THEIR GROWING BODIES
AND BRAIN NEEDS ACCORDING TO THE
CDC THE AVERAGE SECONDARY SCHOOL
START TIME IN CALIFORNIA IS.
EIGHT OH SEVEN AND MANY STARTS
START SCHOOL FIRST PERIOD BEFORE.
SEVEN THIRTY EARLY SECONDARY
SCHOOL START TIMES HARM
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
MANY MANY WAYS.
INSUFFICIENCY AMONG ADOLESCENTS
CAUSES HIGHER RATES OF
DEPRESSION.
ANXIETY SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND
ACTIONS BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS
OBESITY DIABETES DROWSY DRIVING
CAR ACCIDENTS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND SPORTS INJURIES.
THESE EARLY HOURS ARE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER.
TWO CAUSES OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE CAR ACCIDENTS AND SUICIDE.
THE STATUS QUO ALSO CAUSES WORSE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT SLEEP TO PROVIDE
APPROBATION AMONG ADOLESCENTS
STUDENTS BECAUSE THE SLEEPING IN
CLASS.
DIFFICULTY PAYING ATTENTION
FORGETFULNESS ABSENCES MORE
TARDY'S MORE DISCIPLINE ACTION
WORSE GRADES AND TEST SCORES AND
HIGHER DROPOUT RATES IN THIS IS
NOT ANECDOTAL.
DATA THIS IS HARD COLD FACTUAL
DATA.
THE STATUS QUO IS ACTUALLY
WIDENING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
AND HEALTH DISPARITIES AT OUR
STATE BECAUSE EARLY STARTS ARE
PROVEN TO HER DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN THE MOST.
FRANKLY THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS ON
JOSH ON SO MANY LEVELS MANY
STUDENTS SHOW THAT DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN AREADY GET LESS SLEEP
THAN THEIR MORE PRIVILEGE PEERS.
THEY FACE MORE OBSTACLES GETTING
UP EARLY BELLS ON TIME.
AND THEY ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY THE HARM OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY INAPPROPRIATE
START TIMES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS ACCORDING TO-THE CDC LATER START TIMES ARE
THE SINGLE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH INTERVENTION LET
ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
LATER START TIMES ARE THE SINGLE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTION WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF CHILDREN TO COMBAT THE
ADOLESCENT SLEEP LOSS EPIDEMIC.
THERE IS AN EXPANSIVE EVIDENCE
SPANNING DECADES THAT ONE SCHOOL
START LATER TEENS GET MORE SLEEP.
THEY ARE HEALTHIER THEY'RE
HAPPIER THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE LESS LIKELY
TO GET IN CAR ACCIDENTS THEIR
ATTENDANCE GOES UP THEIR GRADES
GO UP AND GRADUATIONS GROW UP.
AND IN CALIFORNIA INCREASE
ATTENDANCE MEANS INCREASED
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE FUNDS
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS A 1%
INCREASE IN ATTENDANCE IN THE LA
U. S. THE WOULD INCREASE. TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THEN AS IF
IT WERE NOT ENOUGH THE RAND
CORPORATION PROJECTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WILL GROW
BY ONE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS AS A
RESULT OF THE HIGHER GRADUATION
RATES FEWER CAR ACCIDENTS FEWER
DISCIPLINE BETTER PRODUCTIVITY
WITH LATE START.
AND EVERY YEAR THE EVIDENCE JUST
KEEPS AMOUNTING.
AFTER A RECENT STUDY OF THE
SEATTLE PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT A
LARGER URBAN DISTRICT WHICH
ADOPTED LATE START.
CONFIRMS THE PREVIOUS FINDINGS
WITH THE SHIFT TO LATER STARTS
THEIR STUDENTS ARE GETTING MORE
SLEEP GETTING BETTER GRADES AND
ATTENDING SCHOOL MORE OFTEN
ATTENDANCE IMPROVED THE MOST
THAT SCHOOLS WITH THE MOST LOW
INCOME STUDENTS LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN.
ATTENDANCE IMPROVED AT THE
SCHOOLS WITH THE MOST LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
STUDENT ATHLETES ARE ALSO A BIG
BENEFICIARY I'M SURE SOMEBODY
WHO WILL OPPOSE THIS BILL WILL
MENTION THE IMPACT ON SPORTS AS
A NEGATIVE.
HEALTHY SCHOOL START TIME HAS
WELL HELPS OUR ATHLETES.
THEY GET HURT LESS AND THEY
PARTICIPATE MORE -- IT'S JUST
STAGGERING THE IMPACT AND AGAIN
AS A PARENT.
OF A STUDENT ATHLETE AND A
PARENT WHO SEES OTHER KIDS
WANTED TO PERFORM PERFORMANCE
INCREASES AND INJURIES DECREASE.
WE KNOW THAT HEALTHY SCHOOL
HOURS WORK THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
WELL RUN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE NATION THAT THRIVE WITH
LATER AGE APPROPRIATE START
TIMES AT THEIR MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE HEALTHIER AND SAFER
STUDENTS AND SUCCESSFUL SPORTS
PROGRAMS THE DATA AND EVIDENCE
IS VERY CLEAR.
EARLY MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
START TIMES POSE A PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY RISK. TO OUR STATE
YOU ARE USED DESERVE EQUAL
PROTECTION FROM THAT HEALTH RISK
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FREQUENTLY SETS HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
REVEALED THE DANGERS OF ASBESTOS
LEAD SMOKING IN ON YOU MEAN I
STUDENTS THE LEGISLATURE ACTED.
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN SO TO
THAN THE LEGISLATURE.
CAN AND SHOULD ACT IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE AUTHORITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S SIX MILLION PUBLIC
CHILDREN FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK OF DEVELPMENTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE.
EARLY SECONDARY SCHOOL START
TIMES I'VE OFTEN BEEN ASKED WHY
I AM SO PASSIONATE ABOUT.
THIS PROPOSAL PEOPLE COME UP TO
ME THEY SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT BACK AGAIN YOU KEEP -- ON
THIS AND YOU KNOW.
I JUST READ TOO MANY STORIES IN
TOO MANY PAPERS AND SEEN TO MANY
FAMILIES OF HIGH SCHOOL KIDS.
WHO HAVE TAKEN THEIR OWN LIFE?
AND I DON'T WANT TO READ ANOTHER.
ONE I JUST DON'T WANT TO READ
ANOTHER ONE AND TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO AFFECT
THE LIVES POSITIVELY OF THOSE
KIDS -- I JUST CAN'T A GOOD
CONSCIOUSNESS BRING THIS BACK
TODAY I HAVE DR RAFEAL POLITE --
FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF SLEEP
MEDICINE I HAVE JOY WAIT FROM
THE SCORCHED START SCHOOL LATER
IN HIGH SCHOOL PARENT ENGAGEMENT
GROUP I KNOW THE PTA.
IS HERE BECAUSE THEY'RE ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE PROCEED YOU CAN DECIDE
WHO WANTS TO START [inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL.
BEFORE ICE BEFORE I SAID I
PLEDGE ACTUALLY WANT -- TO ADD
TO THE HOSTAGES SENATOR WILL
COULD JUST ACT OUT THANK OF WAS
LEADERSHIP AND APOLOGIZE FOR
LETTING MY PASSION GET THE
BETTER OF ME THE LAST TIME WAS
FOR HIS COMMITTEE -- ANYWAY I AM
A PROFESSOR AND PHYSICIAN
SPECIALIZING IS THE MEDICINE FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR AN
INDISPUTABLE THAT ADOLESCENTS
ARE SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC SLEEP
DEPRIVATION WHICH IS CAUSING
THEM HARM.
SCIENCE TEACHES US LESSONS ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO SLEEP
DEPRIVATION BECAUSE THERE IS A
BIOLOGICAL SHIFT IN THEIR BRAIN
RHYTHMS THAT HEIGHTENS THEIR
LIVES AT NIGHT WHICH FORCES THEM
TO FALL ASLEEP LATER.
THERE ARE DECADES OF PEER REVIEW
DATA SHOWING THAT.
THIS IS A WORSENING PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL.
HAVE YOU PUT A THAT INSUFFICIENT
SLEEP AMONG STUDENTS HAS NOW
INCREASED TO WELL OVER 70%.
A RECENT REVIEW ENCOMPASSING
NEARLY 600-100-0600 THOUSAND
TEENAGERS FROM THE SLEEP
DURATION IS AN INDEPENDENT RISK
FACTOR INDEPENDENT OF MOOD
INDEPENDENT RISK FACTOR FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF SUICIDALITY.
THE LUIS SUICIDAL BEHAVIOR IS
FIRST SAW STIPULATIONS OF EIGHT
TO NINE HOURS.
MOST TEENAGERS ARE LUCKY TO GET
EVEN SEVEN HOURS ON SCHOOL
NIGHTS. ONE FORTY FOR TEENAGERS
SCHOOL START TO EARLY.
THIS HAS LED TO VERY SERIOUS
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS INCLUDING DECREASE
SCHOOL PERFORMANCE MEANT AND-MENTAL HEALTH ALONG WITH
INCREASED CAR ACCIDENTS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
RESEARCH HAS CONSISTENTLY SHOWN
THE DELAYING THE SCHOOL START
TIME AS IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF TEENAGERS.
THE BIOLOGY OF THEIR STEEP
CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE TREATED AS
AN INCONVENIENCE.
THE WAY TO THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE IS SO COMPELLING THE
PROFESSIONAL HELP SOCIETY TO
TAKE NOTICE.
AMERICAN KENNY PEDIATRICS
STANFORD PACKAGING HOSPITAL
NURSING ORGANIZATIONS MENTAL
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS CAN YOU
SLEEP MEDICINE NATIONAL SLEEP
FOUNDATION.
ON AND ON OF ALL AGREE TO
STARTING SCHOOL LATER WILL
IMPROVE.
THEIR ALICE'S QUALITY OF LIFE
ECONOMIC PERFORMANCE PHYSICAL
MENTAL HEALTH THERE ARE ZERO
THERE ARE ZERO HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSING THIS BILL.
NOW YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRANSLATE TO SITES IN TO SOME
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY AND SEND
THE MESSAGE THAT WE ALUE THE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN OVER ALL
OF THE CONCERNS.
ARE YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND THANK YOU FOR SERVING ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT COMMITTEE.
EVEN FOR KIDS WITH GOOD SLEEP
HABITS EARLY SCHOOL START TIMES
MANDATE THAT MOST TEENS WAKE UP
AT TIMES THAT DOCTORS SAY
INCREASE THE RISK FOR ILLNESS
SUICIDE AND CAR ACCIDENTS.
MANY CHILDREN SUFFER DAILY AND
HAVE A WORSE QUALITY OF LIFE
BECAUSE OF IT.
I'M SURE WE ALL AGREE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM SHOULD ALWAYS MAKE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY BUT THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE.
CURRENTLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
THE OPTION.
OF GOING AGAINST ACCEPTED HEALTH
AND MEDICAL EXPERTISE AND
CONTINUING THE PRACTICE OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY INAPPROPRIATE
START TIMES FOR ADOLESCENT
CHILDREN.
WE DON'T BELIEVE PROTECTING
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND SAFETY
SHOULD BE MERRILEES OPTIONAL.
WE THINK ALL CHILDREN REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ZIP CODE INCOME OR RACE
DESERVE EQUAL PROTECTION FROM
KNOWN PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS.
AND EARLY MIDDLE SCHOOL START
TIMES ARE PARTICULARLY HARMFUL
TO GIRLS WHO ENTER PUBERTY
EARLIER THAN BOYS.
DECADES OF EVIDENCE AND LIVED
EXPERIENCE SHOW THAT EIGHT
THIRTY AM OR LATER START TIMES
WORK FOR FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE I'M SORRY
ABOUT 20% OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
ALREADY START AT EIGHT THIRTY OR
LATER WITHOUT ISSUE.
AND MORE FAMILIES ARE PROVEN TO
BE ABLE TO GET THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL WITH EIGHT THIRTY OR
LATER START TIME ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
NORMALLY DEFERRING EDUCATIONAL
ISSUES TO LOCAL CONTROL MAKES
SENSE.
BUT WITH THIS STATE WIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM IT HAS NOT SERVE
THE PUBLIC GOOD.
ADOLESCENT SLEEP DEPRIVATION AS
A PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC
PRIMARILY CAUSED BY PUBLIC
POLICY.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT HEALTHY
SCHOOL START TIMES WILL TAKE
EFFORT.
AND IN SOME CASES THEY'LL TAKE
RESOURCES.
BUT WE THINK THAT THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN IS WORTH THE
EFFORT.
MANY DISTRICTS NATIONWIDE HAVE
PROVEN THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO
HARM TEENS HEALTH AND SAFETY TO
RUN AN EFFICIENT SCHOOL DISTRICT
I HAVE A THRIVING
EXTRACURRICULAR PROGRAM OR AN
EFFICIENT.
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT.
AS ADULTS IS OUR MORAL
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT CHILDREN
AND TODAY YOU WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE POWER TO DO
JUST THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
BECAUSE OF OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA REPRESENTING OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS.
DONNA ARE TWO CABBAGE ORANGE
COUNTY PTA.
THE LARGEST PTA DISTRICT IN THE
UNITED STATES REPRESENTING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLEEP DEPRIVED
CHILDREN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TOM NELSON VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE THIRD DISTRICT PTA
REPRESENTING -- EIGHT COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY SCHOOLS PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I READ A CALPERS FEDERAL
PSYCHOLOGY AN EXPERT IN SLEEP ON
CHILD SLEEP AN APPARENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL PUT THEIR CHILDREN
FIRST THANK YOU.
ALONG GOT LAID ON HIM -- NINTH
GRADER AMADOR VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL
AND MY MISLEAD THE PRICE STUDENT
AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE VOTE YES
ON SENATE BILL NUMBER.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT MY NAME IS
SUE CHILLING AND I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL PARENT ENGAGEMENT GROUP
AND STARTS TO SCHOOL LATER.
AS A RETIRED PSYCHIATRIC A
COMMUNITY HEALTH NURSE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT MY NAME IS
LAURIE MORALIS I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN THAT WENT THROUGH
THAT SAM ONE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THE PARENT
TEACHER ORGANIZATION.
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR I SUPPORT
THE SPELL.
DIANNE WILL FIND THAT THE CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRIST IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND I SEE THE
DEVASTATION NOT SLEEP
DEPRIVATION CAUSES AN URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M APRIL IN ROW I'M A PARENT
OF TWO STUDENTS WHO GRADUATED
FROM THE ST ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND A ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE PTA
DURING THAT ENTIRE EDUCATION AND
I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M IN DEL CORE I AM THE CHAPTER
LEADER FOR START SCHOOL LATER
SACRAMENTO WHICH IS A GROUP OF
STUDENTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SUPPORTING THE BILL I'M ALSO
WITH THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED.
SUPERINTENDENT PARENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE URGING YOU TO SUPPORT
THE BILL FOR THE CHILDREN.
HI ELIZABETH MUCKLER OBGYN
PARENT OF THREE USED TO BE
TEENAGERS IN SACRAMENTO AND SAN
JUAN SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO MEMBER
OF NEIGHBORHOOD WELLNESS
FOUNDATION DEL PASO HEIGHTS WE
STRONGLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL.
HI AM CURTIS POLLENS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AMERICA CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MORTON CARVEL HALL AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AND DOCTOR DIAMOND
LANE HERE BEHALF AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HELLO I'M DR RAJIT SHARIA --
SACRAMENTO PEDIATRICIAN HERE ON
BEHALF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M DR CATHERINE FITS
WATER ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS A SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO DR CITY AND STUART PART OF
THE AMERICAN CAN GET PEDIATRICS
LOCAL PEDIATRICIAN AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI I'M CHRIS STROLLER -- FIVE
IT'S THREE KIDS IN THE SOMEONE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I AND
THEY'RE IN THEIR TWENTIES NOW I
ALSO SERVED AS A PTA PRESIDENT
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS AND ON
NUMEROUS -- COMMITTEES AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL UP FOR AN
IMPROVING EDUCATION RATES
SUPPORT MY NAME IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
UP YOUR SEATS [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
OKAY YOU HAVE TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH I WILL LET YOU
DECIDE WHO'S GOING TO GO FIRST
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA SENATORS
MY NAME IS SCOTT ASIK I'M A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER OF THE NEW
TEMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO.
ARE FROM OUT OF TOWN YOU DRIVE
THROUGH OUR DISTRICT ANYTIME
YOU'RE FLYING IN AND OUT OF
SACRAMENTO.
I'M HERE NOT ONLY ON BEHALF OF
THE FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS OF
IN THE THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT ALSO HERE TODAY.
AS A SINGLE PARENT OF TWO
TEENAGE KIDS ONE IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND ONE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
WHILE I AM NOT GOING TO DISPUTE
THE SCIENCE I DON'T HAVE A PHD
AND SLEEP SCIENCE AND I
CERTAINLY CAN RELATE TO SLEEP
DEPRIVATION AS MY STARBUCKS
ADDICTION ADDICTION WILL ATTEST.
MANDATING LATER START TIMES WILL
CREATE AN INCREDIBLE HARDSHIP
FOR SINGLE INCOME FAMILIES FOR
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR MY STUDENTS
AND FROM MY KIDS PERSPECTIVE.
BUT WHEN.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT TIME MY KIDS
SCHOOL STARTS I STILL HAVE TO
GETTHEM TO SCHOOL BEFORE EIGHT
O'CLOCK BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY I GET TO WORK ON TIME I HAVE
A FULL TIME JOB.
I'M A SINGLE PARENT AND AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL IT'S A
BALANCING ACT AND I STRUCK THAT
BALANCE BUT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER SCHOOL STARTED EIGHT
EIGHT THIRTY NINE MY KIDS ARE
STILL GOING TO HAVE TO GET UP AT
THAT SAME TIME.
THE DIFFERENCES INSTEAD OF BEING
AN ACADEMIC INSTRUCTION
ENVIRONMENT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
IN AND I'M INTENT ON ATTENDED
ENVIRONMENT THE NON STRUCTURED
ENVIRONMENT AND THEY'RE STILL
GOING TO BE GETTING UP IT WON'T
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT ARE
LAUDABLE GOALS AND I SUPPORT
THOSE GOALS.
PLEASE ALLOW LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
THAT ARE IN TOUCH WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES THE TIME IS UNIFIED
60% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE FAMILIES
LIVE IN LOW INCOME.
LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY LINE AND
QUALIFY FOR FREE OR REDUCED
LUNCH THESE ARE THE FAMILIES
THAT THIS BILL WOULD HURT THE
MOST BECAUSE THESE ARE THE ONES
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE.
TO SUPPORT GETTING THESE KIDS TO
SCHOOL AT A LATER TIME AND STILL
GET TO WORK ON TIME IN SUPPORT
OF FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CINDY
GARDNER I'M FROM ANOTHER WORLD
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IS
IN THE MOUNTAINS OF SAMBAR NAY
DINO.
AS SUCH OUR ELEVATION OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS FROM WITH
FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED FOOT LEVEL
TO THE SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED FOOT
LEVEL.
OUR MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL ARE IN DEAD CENTER AT THE
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOL FIVE
FOOT LEVEL HIGH SCHOOL STARTS AT
SEVEN TEN IN THE MORNING.
ELEMENTARY AT EIGHT TWENTY IN
THE MORNING MIDDLE SCHOOL AT
NINE TEN IN THE MORNING WE
PLAYED AROUND WITH DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL.
RIGHT NOW THE BEST SCENARIO IS
AT SEVEN TEN AM START TIME FOR
ELEMENTARY THAT WOULD REQUIRE R.
T. CARES OUR FOUR YEAR OLDS. TO
GET TO A BUS STOP FOR PICK UP AT
SIX THIRTY IN THE MORNING IN THE
MID IN THE DARK IN THE SNOW IN
THE MIDDLE OF WINTER.
WE'VE ALL THAT WOULD ALSO CREATE
EIGHT NOT EIGHT THIRTY START
TIME FOR HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL WOULD START AT
NINE THIRTY SO.
ACTUALLY IT IN THE THE HIGH
SCHOOL WOULD START AT NINE
O'CLOCK IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
WOULD START AT TEN OO SEVEN
THOSE KIDS THE LAST DROP OFF
POINT WOULD BE SIX O'CLOCK AT
NIGHT SO THINK ABOUT THE
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
PRECLUDED -- FROM THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN AND THE NEXT
THING IS IS THAT IF WE TRY TO
DUPLICATE OR DOUBLE OUR BUSES TO
GET EVERYBODY AT A DECENT START
TIME.
ITWOULD COST US THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME ONE
POINT THREE MILLION ON GOING.
THAT WOULD PUSH US INTO
INSOLVENCY SO TO COVER THESE
EXPENSES WHAT WOULD IT REQUIRE.
LAYING OFF TWELVE TEACHERS
INCLUDING THE ENTIRE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
ONE ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL FOR
COUNSELORS FIVE LIBRARIANS THREE
TWO SECRETARIES IT WOULD REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE.
OUR VIRTUAL CREDIT RECOVERY
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS OUR MOST --
ACADEMICALLY AT RISK KIDS WOULD
ALSO HAVE TO CUT DRAMA BAND
CHOIR AND MY FAVORITE ATHLETICS
REALLY DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
WE WOULD ALSO HAVE TO CANCEL OUR
TEXTBOOK ADOPTION.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A LOCAL
DECISION LOCAL CONTROL WHAT
WORKS FOR BASS FOR US.
OUR OUR START TIMES ARE IN LIKE
SYBIL WE ARE PHYSICALLY UNABLE
TO CONDENSE THE PICKUP TIMES
BECAUSE LITERALLY OUR BUSES ARE
PICKING CUT KIDS UP IN THE
FARTHEST REACHES OF THE
MOUNTAINS WE WORK WITH OUR C. H.
B.. FOR THE MOST AFFECTED BUS
ROUTES REMEMBER WE DON'T AVE
SIDEWALKS SO OUR FOUR YEAR OLDS
WHEN IT'S SNOWING AND THERE'S
BERMS TEN TWENTY FEET HIGH IT'S
SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED FOOT LEVEL
AT SIX THIRTY IN THE MORNING.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE WE CAN ACCOMMODATE.
THE START TIMES IN A CONDENSED
FASHION.
AND WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS IS
ENCOURAGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL -- BELIEVING THAT ITS LOCAL
DECISION MAKING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS OPPOSING MADAM.
IN OPPOSITION GO AHEAD MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS SOUTH BRAMBLE
HERE O BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE COULD
PROBABLY SUPPORT A PILOT PROGRAM
WE ARE OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION BEST OF ALL
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS ARE
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE BILL FAILS
TO RECOGNIZE A LOGISTICAL FISCAL
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY IMPACTS.
OF IMPOSING THE CITY MANDATE
THANK YOU PAYMENT OPPOSITION
PLEASE.
SURELY DOWN THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL RIGHT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND IN TORRANCE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION.
THE TROUBLE WITH THE COMPTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
A STEVE ALL COMING OFF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
CANELO HALLERAN WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN
OPPOSITION AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
CATHOLIC PRIDE WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ALSO POST.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF ROSS -- CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION.
ALEXANDER ALEXANDER KHANDAN --
SACRAMENTO PARENT OF THREE AND A
HIGH SCHOOLER IN OPPOSITION.
SERGIO MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION BOARD OF
DIRECTORS STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION.
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTYDISTRICT
ADVOCATE FOR BETTER SCHOOLS IN
OPPOSITION.
CAROL CHANNING WITH THEIR IN
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION C. TEAM
MEMBER IN OPPOSITION.
SHEA LIMóN SO SHE XIN ROLE IN
EDUCATORS IN OPPOSITION.
INGER AGAIN NOW SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S CONSTITUENT I
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE A LOCAL
CONTROL ISSUE THANK YOU.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT PULL TEACHERS
SENSATIONAL LANCASTER STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
YOU THAT ARE THE BIGGEST BECAUSE
MINE CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT IN
LOS ANGELES IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
IT FULLY RETIRED TEACHERS --
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THE INJURY SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING AND HEARING THEN I'M
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE I ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR INPUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE MY INPUT.
FIRST I WAS A YOUR RIGHT CENTER
PORTANTINO I'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ON THIS BILL.
AND IT'S BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE I READ THE
ENTIRE BOOK THAT YOU PRO
PROVIDED US WITH I MADE MY OWN
NOTES.
AND WHILE THE MAJORITY OF IT
DOES SUGGEST THAT SLEEP TIME IS
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPORTANT I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT.
EVEN IN THIS REPORT THAT YOU
GAVE US IT TALKS ABOUT ACADEMIC
IMPROVEMENT IS ACTUALLY NOT
STATISTICALLYSIGNIFICANT ENOUGH
TO LIST.
IT TALKS ABOUT -- THERE'S MORE
THAN JUST CHANGING START TIMES.
THAT PARENTS NEED TO HELP THEIR
KIDS GET MORE SLEEP THE PARENTS
NEED TO TAKE THEIR KIDS OFF OF
THEIR PHONES THAT KIDS PARENTS
NEED.
TO TAKE AWAY THE TELEVISION TIME
SO.
I APPRECIATE IT I READ IT.
MY CONCERNS FOR THE BILL OUR ONE
AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
THAT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
ALREADY HAS THE RIGHT TO DO THIS
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
ALREADY DO THIS.
AND I THINK THE EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS UNIQUE AND IN DOING
RESEARCH ON THIS BILL WE FOUND
THAT SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
STARTED A LATER START TIME.
AND IT WORKED AND THEY LOVE IT
IN THE CONTINUE AT OTHER STARTED
IT IT DIDN'T WORK AND THEY WENT
BACK.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY HARD TO SAY
THAT ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE HEARD
A LITTLE BIT TOM FROM ROOM OF
WORLD.
ABOUT THE SCHOOL BUSES WHEN YOU
AND I MET I SHARED WITH YOU THAT
MY OWN COUNTY OF SAMBAR TO DINO
WOULD HAVE TO DUPLICATE THEIR
BUSES TO A COST OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
I JUST DON'T THINK THOSE ARE
INSIGNIFICANT.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED BECAUSE WE
HAVE TEACHERS STRIKING FOR
SMALLER CLASS SIZES FOR
COUNSELORS FOR NURSES SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
WE ARE FACING IN OUR OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW K. THROUGH.
TWELVE AND I JUST WORRY THAT
THIS IS NOT THE BEST THING TO DO
AT THIS TIME I APPRECIATE YOUR
PASSION -- I TO AGREE WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE ANY KIDS COMMIT
SUICIDE.
BUT I WORRIED THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO HAVE SO MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THEY WERE GOING TO
FIND OURSELVES IN A WORSE
POSITION.
THAN WE'RE IN NOW SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- SO I
WAS IN NO ON THIS.
ON THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR.
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR OF
CONTACTING ME IN AND I LOOKED
INTO IT MYSELF.
I'VE TALKED TO A LOT OF OF
PHYSICIANS.
I'VE TALKED TO A TON OF PARENTS
ACTUALLY IN THE DISTRICT
CONTACTED ME.
AND ULTIMATELY AFTER REVIEWING
THE RESEARCH I AM BEGINNING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE -- I'M WILLING TO
TRY SOMETHING NEW FOR STUDENTS
THE SCIENCE DOES SHOW THAT OUR
STUDENTS CAN BENEFIT.
FROM A LATER START TO THEIR
SCHOOL DAYS AND I AM SUPPORTER
OF THAT BUT I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT I DID -- I HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION REGARDING THE LOCAL
CONTROL ISSUES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO VISIT THIS
AT A LATER DATE IF IT'S NOT
WORKING BUT AT THIS POINT I AM
WILLING TO TO GIVE THIS A CHANCE
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
PASSION SO TODAY WILL BE A
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG OTHER
DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A BUT
SO FIRST WIFE SAID THAT -- NO
I'M A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
BECAUSE THE THE DATA -- ON ON
THIS ISSUE IS EXTREMELY STRONG --
AND THIS IS THIS IS A
PEDIATRICIAN AND SOMEONE.
TO SCIENTISTS AND CERTAINLY I
KNOW THAT MANY OF THIS THERE'S A
THERE'S A CAN DOWN THERE'S
BASICALLY CONSENSUS AND AND THE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD TO LOOK AT
PEDIATRICS AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND SLEEP IN WE'VE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THEM HERE -- I RECOGNIZE
FROM THE OPPOSITION I APPRECIATE
I HAVE A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
FROM MY OWN SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE
WHO'S OPPOSED.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT I HEAR
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL IT'S
GONNA BE HARD TO DO THIS.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT WILL BUT
THERE THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
IN A BE HARD BUT WE TALK ABOUT
AND BELIEVE ME I'M SOMEONE WHO
WANTS TO SEE MORE SCHOOL NURSES
PSYCHOLOGISTS SMALLER CLASS SIZE
AND SO FORTH AND THOSE ARE GONNA
BE VERY IMPORTANT -- THAT WHAT
WHY ARE WE TRYING TO GIVE OUR
KIDS EVERY CHANCE AT SUCCESS.
AND THE DATASHOWS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THIS.
AND PART OF THE REASON FOR
SAYING THAT WHAT WE SHOULD DO
THIS ACROSS THE STATE YES PEOPLE
ARE CHALLENGED WITH TRYING TO
GET TO WORK WELL ACTUALLY IF
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
STATE WAS DOING THIS.
I THINK WE'LL SEE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS IN WORKPLACES
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
NOT JUST A COUPLE PARENTS WERE
TRYING TO DO THIS.
IT'S OUGHT TO PARENTS NEED TO
WORK WITH THEIR CHILDREN AROUND
A CHRONIC SINCE SCREENS YES THEY
DO -- BU THE SAME TIME WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS WE'RE
WORKING AGAINST BIOLOGY WHEN WE
SAY WELL IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO TELL OUR KIDS THEY
NEED TO GET UP EARLIER THAN
THEIR SLEEP CYCLE THAT THE
PROVIDENCE SHOWS WITH THE SLEEP
CYCLE IS.
SO -- WE HAVE TO THINK IS OUR
SCHOOLS FOR STUDENTS OUR
STUDENTS FOR SCHOOLS AND OUR
SCHOOLS ARE FOR STUDENTS THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT'S BEST FOR
STUDENTS AND CERTAINLY I THINK
THE DATA ON THIS IS IS IS
COMPELLING.
THAT -- THIS IS SOMETHING OUR
STUDENTS NEED AND WE GOTTA
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE THEIR
SYSTEMS WORK WITH THIS SO THAT
WE'RE NOT WORKING AGAINST IT I
MEAN WE CAN TRY TO GET MORE
PSYCHOLOGIST WE CAN DO MORE
SCHOOL NURSES WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT WARY WORKING
AGAINST THE BIOLOGY.
AND SO WITH THAT -- I'M STRONGLY --
NOW IS THAT I CAN GO OUT THERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I
WOULD ACTUALLY MOVED TO BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IS TO MAKE
A COMMENT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION I
MEAN YOU'VE NOT LET UP ON THIS
ISSUE SINCE SINCE LAST YEAR AND
I AGREE DOCTOR PAN AYE AYE.
I FIND A LOT OF THE EVIDENCE --
COMPELLING GOT TO BALANCE THAT
WITH LOCAL CONTROL WHICH IS
SOMETHING I I STRONGLY BELIEVE
AND BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS
LAST WEEK IN THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION YOU GAVE ME -- I AM
GOING TO I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
IT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO IT'S A VERY POOR
NATION NEED TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
I HAVE TO GO BACK AND AND RE
MEET WITH MY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
ARE OPPOSED TO IT SO MOBILE FOR
TODAY -- IF I GET A LOT OF PUSH
BACK AT HOME I RESERVE THE RIGHT
ON THE FLOOR TO DEVOTE THE OTHER
WAY BUT LET ME OBVIOUSLY.
IT SHOULD BE STUDENTS FIRST AND
SO I WANNA GO BACK AND TALK
ABOUT THOSE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES.
AND IS EASY TO SAY NO BUT YOU
KNOW HOW CAN YOU GET TO YASSIN
SO I'M GONNA GO BACK AND WORK ON
THAT AND BE HAPPY BUT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR WELL OKAY THING
ELSE I JUST LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THE KIDS COMMITTEE ALSO KNOWS
THAT I OFFERED AN AMENDMENT TO
CENTER PORTANTINO WHICH SHE WAS
NOT WILLING TO TAKE.
BECAUSE THE SCIENCE ALSO SHOWS
THAT LATE TEENS THAT IT WORKS
BEST FOR PEOPLE IN THEIR LATE
TEENS AND EARLY TWENTIES WHICH
MAKES IT RIGHT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
AND I ASKED HIM TO EXEMPT.
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND JUNIOR HIGHS
SO THAT WAY IT WOULD MAKE IT
WOULD EASE SOME OF THE
TRANSPORTATION -- ISSUES.
AND YOU DO NOT WANT TAKE OUT SO
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU COUNTER
BACK WAS SOMETHING ELSE THAT --
WAS THE WASN'T FEASIBLE MY MIND
SO I DO FEEL LIKE WE'VE TRIED TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE -- BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND I JUST WISH
THAT IT WE CAN WAVE A MAGIC WAND
AND MAKE IT EASY FOR EVERYONE.
AND RESPECTFULLY -- DOCTOR PAN --
WORKING WITH CORPORATE AMERICA
FOR MANY YEARS IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT I DON'T THINK MOST WORK
PLACES WILL JUST THEIR TIME FOR
SCHOOLS I NEVER SAW THAT HAPPEN.
SO WITH THAT -- CENTER POINT TWO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I I WOULD IN -- YES -- I I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT AND THE ANALYSIS DOES THE
YOU -- OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXEMPT OUT MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND I
AND I BELIEVE I CAME UP.
LET ME BACK UP I THINK THAT.
THE CONCERN YOU HAD IS A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN ABOUT GIVING
DISTRICTS FLEXIBILITY TO TO
STAGGER -- THEIR BUS SCHEDULE
AND YOU KNOW I I BELIEVE
ACTUALLY IF WE MADE MIDDLE AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL SINGING AND JUNIOR
HIGHS.
HAVE A MINIMUM STANDARD OF EIGHT
O'CLOCK IN HIGH SCHOOLS EIGHT
THIRTY I THINK.
THAT ACCOMPLISHES THAT GOAL THAT
I WAS WILLING TO TO GO THERE AND
I STILL LAUGH AND CONSIDERING
THAT AMENDMENT AS THIS HOPEFULLY
BILL MOVES OUT TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS A A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION ASK THOUGH.
FRANKLY THE DATA DOESN'T SHOW
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION CROSS DO
INCREASE -- AND I THINK YOU KNOW
I DO APPRECIATE DR PANS CO
AUTHORSHIP IN LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IS A PEDIATRICIAN -- THE DATA IS
CLEAR AND FRANKLY THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION ARE POSITIVE -
AND YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO FOLLOW IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
A WAY TO POSITIVELY AFFECT
PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN
AND CONSEQUENTLY THEIR ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE -- A FORMER
PRESIDENT -- WHO WAS A GOVERNOR
ONCE SAID THAT -- HIS BIGGEST
FRUSTRATION WITH EDUCATION.
WAS THAT EVERY PROBLEM IN
EDUCATION HAS BEEN SOLVED ON A
CAMPUS SOMEWHERE.
AND THE GOVERNOR WAS FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THE CHALLENGE WAS
DUPLICATING THAT SUCCESS BECAUSE
SO MUCH OF WHAT MAKES THINGS
WORK ON A PARTICULAR CAMPUS.
ARE THE ART OF THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND IT'S HARD TO
DUPLICATE.
THAT PART -- AND WHAT MAKES ME
EXCITED ABOUT LATE START IS THS
IS A REPLICABLE DUPLICATE BOWL.
PROVEN WAY TO IMPROVE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
CHILDREN AND ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE IT'S NOT ANECDOTE --
IT'S NOT THEORY IT'S BORNE OUT
BY DISTRICT AFTER DISTRICT ARE
URBAN DISTRICTS SMALL DISTRICT --
AND THE DATA SHOWS IT WORKS -- I
DO WANT TO COMMENT AGAIN ON THE
IMPACT ON LOW INCOME.
CHILDREN AND WORKING FAMILY
HOUSEHOLDS -- AGAIN THE DATA
SHOWS THAT THEY SEE THE BIGGEST
BENEFIT -- AFTER THE CHANGE IN
WITH THE SEATTLE MODEL WE KNOW
THAT ATTENDANCE ACTUALLY
INCREASED.
DIDN'T DECREASE SO WHAT IS BEING
USED AS A NEGATIVE IS ACTUALLY A
POSITIVE FOR THE BILL IN A FIGHT.
COULD CLOSE WITH COMMENTS FROM A
UNIVERSITY BERKELEY -- PROFESSOR
AND HE WROTE I WRITE WITH
DEEPEST SINCERITY IMPLORING YOU
TO SUPPORT.
THE BILL TO DELAY SCHOOL START
TIMES THE SCIENTIFIC EDUCATION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
DATA ARE UNEQUIVOCAL BULL.
AS HE DESCRIBES BELOW IN HIS
LETTER THIS BILL IS A MISSION
CRITICAL TO GIVING ADOLESCENCE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO SLEEP
THEY NEED.
A MATTER WHAT PARENTS DO OR HOW
MUCH THE IMPORTANCE OF SLEEP IS
COMMUNICATED MOST TEENS SIMPLY
CANNOT GET ENOUGH SLEEP.
WITH EARLY START TIME AND HE
CONCLUDED HIS LETTER.
WITH -- THIS IS A LETTER SENT
LAST YEAR.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE SCIENTIFIC
MEASURABLE SLEEP DEFICIENCY IS
SO DISASSOCIATED WITH EARLY
SCHOOL START TIMES RESULTS IN
MARKED.
MENTAL PHYSICAL AN ACADEMIC
DAMAGE HIS WORDS NOT MINE IF OUR
GOAL AS EDUCATORS TRULY IS TO
EDUCATE AND NOT RISK THE LIVES
IN THE PROCESS.
THEN I FEAR WE ARE FAILING OUR
NEXT GENERATION WITH
UNSUSTAINABLE MODELS OF EARLY
SCHOOL START TIME AND THAT WAS
SIGNED BY.
MATTHEW WALKER PHD PROFESSOR OF
NEUROSCIENCE AND PSYCHOLOGY
DIRECTOR CENTER FOR HUMAN SLEEP
SCIENCE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY SO WE'VE
UNITED BOTH STANFORD PROFESSORS
AND CAL PROFESSORS -- IN SUPPORT
AND I THINK FOR THAT ALONE.
WE SHOULD GET AN AYE VOTE AND SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES I CERTAINLY
WILL.
WORK WITH SENATOR WOKE AND
SENATOR CHIANG AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH DR PAN AND CERTAINLY
WITH THE CHAIR AS WELL -- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
WE HAVE A MOTION I THINK BY
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE I KNOW WILK HI WILK I
CHIANG CHIANG I'D RUSSELL GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THE BILL ON CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALRIGHT WE ARE IN FILE ITEM
ORDER I DO NOT SEE SENATOR ALLEN
BUT I DO SEE SENATOR UMBERG
CENTER AMBER COME ON DOWN.
FULLER QUITE DOWN JUST A TAD BIT.
YOU'RE LEAVING IF YOU COULD DO
SO QUIETLY BE MUCH APPRECIATED.
SENATOR UMBERG BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN MEMBERS --
BUT IT WILL BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU AND STAFF FOR PROPOSING OF
IMPORTANT MOMENTS WHICH WE DO
ACCEPT.
I THINK THEY IMPROVE THE BILL OF
THE THE MATTER BEFORE YOU
CONCERNED SCHOOL SAFETY AND
CONCERNS TRAINING.
OF EMPLOYEES SCHOOL SECURITY
OFFICERS -- WHO ARE?
WORKING IN SCHOOL DISTRICT AS
EMPLOYEES BUT NOT WORKING TWENTY
HOURS OR MORE AND THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILLS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
SCHOOL SAFETY PLEASE ARE
ADEQUATELY TRAINED TO DEAL WITH
GIRLS SCHOOL EMERGENCIES.
I I DON'T NEED TO GO INTO DETAIL
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS IN
THIS DAY AND AGE IN WITH THE THE
SAD EVENTS THAT OCCURRED ON
SEVERAL CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES -- WHAT THIS DOES
IS IT REQUIRES THAT ALL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ARE RECEIVING CERTAIN
TRAINING OF THE COST IS
RELATIVELY SMALL?
BUT THE BENEFIT IS HUGE.
SO WITH THAT -- MADAM CHAIR LIKE
TO INTRODUCE A SANDRA BORRERO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WHO'S WITH ME HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER OF BURKE AND I
WILL LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CENTER BORRERO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR -- BURKE
FOR OFFERING SB THREE NINETY AND
FOR HIS COMMENTS I'LL JUST ADD
THAT THE NUMBER OF PART TIME
POSITIONS HAS INCREASED IN
RECENT YEARS.
AS HAS THE ATTENTION TO SCHOOL
CLIMATE AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS -- IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
EDUCATION STATISTICS REPORTED
THAT 5% OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WERE THREATENED OR BULLIED WITH
A WEAPON ON SCHOOL CAMPUS.
THE SCA MEMBERS ALL WANT TO REST
ASSURED THAT ALL SECURITY GUARDS
ARE TRAINED ON BASIC SCHOOL
SAFETY AND KNOW HOW TO RESPOND
IN AN EMERGENCY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ROLE
SO YOU'RE A STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED TO SENATOR BYRD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR -- URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THE BILLS WERE
MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT IN TEN SB THREE NINETY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I
CHIANG WHO ASAL GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
LEAVE THAT PHOTO THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU [inaudible]
.
OKAY -- WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE SITES
DIRECTLY FROM HIM.
A LITTLE OF THE REST OF THE
WORLD [inaudible]
WHICH IS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER A CHAIR GLAZER
GOOD MORNING.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THIS
AMAZING COMMITTEE FOR THERE ARE
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
MEMBERS AS YOU MAY REMEMBER
SEVERAL OF YOU SAW A SIMILAR
VERSION OF THIS BILL LAST YEAR
SB.
THREE TWENTY UNFORTUNATELY AFTER
PASSING BOTH HOUSES FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN VETO THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
SITTING AT THE TIME THAT
STUDENTS HAVING TO TRAVEL A GOOD
DISTANCE OFF CAMPUS. TO ACCESS
MEDICATION ABORTION IS NOT IN
HIS WORDS UNREASONABLE.
AS A WOMAN AND AS A LEGISLATOR
THAT STRONGLY BELIEVES IN EACH
OF OUR ABILITY TO MAKE OUR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT OUR LIVES.
AND ABOUT OUR HEALTH CARE I
RESPECTFULLY AND PROFOUNDLY
DISAGREE WITH OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR.
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES BEFORE
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
THAT I WILL NOT REST UNTIL IT
BECOMES LAW.
MEMBERS SB TWENTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE ALL ON CAMPUS STUDENT
HEALTH CARE CENTERS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO OFFER MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS TO STUDENTS
BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A RECENT
REPORT BY THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THAT
OVER THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
WOMEN.
IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE USED
MEDICATED ABORTION.
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WOMEN
AGE TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR
ACCOUNTED 434% OF ABORTIONS THE
LARGEST FOR ANY AGE GROUP THIS
OF COURSE INCLUDES UNIVERSITY
AND COLLEGE STUDENTS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A TWO
STEP PROCESS WHERE A PATIENT
TAKES TWO SETS OF PILLS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO DAYS.
IT IS FDA APPROVED TO USE FOR UP
TO TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO A UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY MEDICATION ABORTION IS
VERY SAFE WITH COMPLICATIONS
OCCURRING IN ONLY ZERO POINT 3%
OF CASES.
WHICH IS MUCH SAFER THAN MANY
MEDICATIONS SOMEONE CAN BUY OVER
THE COUNTER.
IN A MOMENT YOU WILL HEAR MORE
FROM DOCTOR DANIEL GROSSMAN A
CLINICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER ON ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTION WHO WILL FURTHER
DISCUSS SOME OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESEARCH.
THOUGH MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS PREGNANCY
OPTIONS COUNSELING AND
CONTRACEPTIVES NONECURRENTLY
OFFER ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND IS CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF THE CARE
ALREADY OFFERED AT COLLEGE
COLLEGE HEALTH CENTERS.
SUCH AS DIABETES MANAGEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
IF A STUDENT HAS GO OFF CAMPUS.
ON TO AN OFF CAMPUS PROVIDER
THAT DOES NOT ACCEPT THEIR
STUDENT OR OTHER PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE PAYING FOR MEDICATION
ABORTION MAY BE A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL BURDEN.
IN TOTAL TWENTY TWO UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES ARE MORE THAN THIRTY
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE CLOSEST
ABORTION PROVIDER VIA PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
MEDICATION ABORTION REQUIRES TWO
TRIPS TO HEALTH CLINIC WHICH
COULD MEAN TWO HOURS OF TOTAL
TRAVEL TIME FOR THE STUDENTS AND
UP TO FOUR HOURS FARTHER AWAY
FROM CAMPUSES.
THESE BARRIERS ARE WORSENED
SINCE ONLY 15% OF THE CLOSEST
OFF CAMPUS ABORTION PROVIDERS
ARE OPEN ON WEEKENDS MEANING
THAT STUDENTS MAY HAVE TO MISS
CLASSES EXAMS.
AND WORK TO ACCESS ABORTION
WHICH IS THE SUPREME THE SUPREME
COURT HAS DETERMINED TO BE A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICATION
ABORTIONON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE WOMEN MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN KNOW
THEY'RE PREGNANT UNTIL THE FIFTH
OR SIXTH WEEK OF PREGNANCY.
MEMBERS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS
NOT A SLOGAN BUT RATHER A
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING TRUE
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS DOCTOR DANIEL
CRESSMAN PROFESSOR AND DIRECTOR
OF ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS.
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AT
UC SAN FRANCISCO AND JESSE WAS
ALL IS A RECENT UC RIVERSIDE
GRADUATE -- GET YOUR FIRST
WITNESS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY -- AS
CENTER LEYVA SAID I'M A
PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY AT
UCSF AND I DIRECTOR POLICY
ORIENTED RESEARCH PROGRAM.
CALLED ANSWER ADVANCING NEW
STANDARDS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH WE
PUBLISH TWO STUDIES IN THE PEER
REVIEWED LITERATURE RELATED TO
SB.
TWENTY FOUR THE FIRST LOOKED AT
HOW STUDENTS -- HOW OFTEN
STUDENTS SEEK ABORTION CARE AND
WHETHER THEY FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS STUDENTS ACROSS THE UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES OBTAIN
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
ABORTIONS EACH MONTH?
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT AS MANY AS
FIVE HUNDRED MEDICATION
ABORTIONS WOULD BE PROVIDED
MONTHLY ON CAMPUS IF STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS OFFERED THE
SERVICE.
ACROSS ALL PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES CONSIDERING THAT THE
SERVICE REQUIRES TWO VISITS THE
MEDIAN TIME BY PUBLIC TRANSPORT
ON TO THE CLOSEST PROVIDERS TWO
HOURS ROUND TRIP FOR MEDICATION
ABORTION.
AND UP TO FOUR HOURS FOR SOME
CAMPUSES ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
TRAVELING MORE THAN THIRTY
MINUTES FOR HEALTH CARE RENDERS
THAT CARE IN ACCESSIBLE. FOR THE
SECOND STUDY WE STUDY THE
CAPACITY OF STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS TO PROVIDE MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS AND WHAT THEY
WOULD NEED.
ALL THE UC AND CSU STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES THE
EMPLOYER CONTRACT WITH AT LEAST
ONE PHYSICIAN ON HAND OR A AN
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIAN --
AND THEY ALL HAVE THE NEEDED
PHYSICAL SPACE.
IN ORDER TO OFFER THE SERVICE
THEY WOULD ALL NEED TRAINING ON
THE ULTRASOUND IF THAT'S NEEDED --
AND THEY WOULD ALSO NEED TWENTY
FOUR HOUR TELEPHONE SUPPORT TO
TRIAGE PATIENTS IF THEY DON'T
ALREADY HAVE THAT.
GIVEN THESE FINDINGS I BELIEVE
THAT ABORTION KAREN CAMPUS IS
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND
DECREASED BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WITH THE
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN COMMITTED IT
WOULD BE VERY FEASIBLE. TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION AT STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS THERE'S NO REASON
TO EXCLUDE MEDICATION ABORTION
CARE FROM THE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED AT THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER.
AS SENATOR LABOR NOTED
MEDICATION ABORTION IS SAFE AND
SIMPLE TO PROVIDE OVER THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION U. S. WOMEN
HAVE HAD A MEDICATION ABORTION
AND SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS ARE
VERY RARE.
IN FACT THE HEALTH RISKS ARE
ACTUALLY SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
FOR WOMEN WHO CHOOSE TO CONTINUE
A PREGNANCY TO TERM -- COMPARED
TO THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO HAVE A
MEDICATION ABORTION.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO -- THE FDA
APPROVED A NEW GENERIC FORM OF
MIFEPRISTONE WHICH IS THE
MEDICATION HOUSTON MEDIC AND
MEDICATION PORTION.
FURTHER CONFIRMING THE AGENCY'S
VIEW THAT THIS IS A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT.
YOU SEE AN CSU STUDENTS ARE
ALREADY OBTAINING MEDICATION
ABORTIONS IN THE RARE CASE OF A
COMPLICATION SOME MAY SEE CARE
AT THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER
RATHER THAN TRAVELING TO THE
CLINIC WHERE THEY OBTAINED THE
TREATMENT.
IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING ACCESS
FOR THE SEARCH FOR STUDENTS I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF CARE THAT
STUDENTS RECEIVE AT THE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER.
BY PROVIDING TRAINING ON HOW TO
MANAGE THESE COMPLICATIONS
INCLUDING FACILITY FACILITATING
TIMELY REFERRALS WHEN NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THAT TEST SECOND BEFORE THE
SECOND WHEN THIS UNDER THE
INSTRUCTIONS OF THE REAL CHAIR.
AT TEN MINUTES EACH THAT WAS TWO
TWENTY FOUR SO YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND ABOUT FORTY SECONDS FOR THE
NEXT WITNESS SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS JESSE -- SALAS AND I AM
A UC RIVERSIDE GRADUATE CLASS OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND CAMPUS
COORDINATOR WITH THE JUST CARE
CAMPAIGN AT THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THE JUST CARE CAMPAIGN MOBILIZES
STUDENTS TO EXPAND REPRODUCTIVE
EQUITY ON CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
THIS INCLUDES LIFTING BARRIERS
TO ABORTION CARE.
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR IS
DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ME.
EVERY MONTH AS DOCTOR CROSSMAN
ALREADY SHARED HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR CAMPUSES
FOR ABORTION CARE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET ON AN ON
CAMPUS STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
JUST TWO YEARS AGO I WAS ONE OF
THE STUDENTS.
IN MY THIRD YEAR AT UC RIVERSIDE
I DISCOVERED I WAS PREGNANT.
AS MY DOCTOR I WESTERN HEALTH
CENTER WENT OVER MY OPTIONS I
KNEW I WANTED TO GET AN ABORTION.
BECAUSE I CAN GET MY ABORTION AT
THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
I WAS FORCED TO NAVIGATE
CUMBERSOME CONFUSING REFERRALS
TO OFFSITE CLINICS THAT
ULTIMATELY CAME INCREASINGLY
MORE.
IT DIFFICULT TO LIVE MY LIFE AND
NOT STRESSED BECAUSE BY THE
THREE MONTH DELAY IN CARE
RESULTED ME IN FAILING THAT
ENTIRE FALL QUARTER.
AS A WOMAN OF COLOR CHILD OF
IMMIGRANTS AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TRYING TO ACCESS MY
ABORTION I FACE MORE BARRIERS
THAN I EVER ANTICIPATED.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE TO NAVIGATE THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM OR INSURANCE
POLICIES.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
GET THE CARE I NEEDED OFF CAMPUS
SUCH AS MONEY AND A CAR.
ONCE A STUDENT HAS DECIDED TO
END A PREGNANCY THEY SHOULDN'T
BE FORCED TO GO OFF CAMPUS TO
SEE A PROVIDER THEY DON'T KNOW --
WHEN CARE CAN EASILY BE PROVIDED
ON CAMPUS?
LEAVING CAMPUS CAN MEANS TAKING
TIME AWAY FROM CLASS AN
INTERNSHIP FAMILY TIME OR YOUR
JOB.
IT CAN BE HARD TO RAISE THE
MONEY OR FIND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO A FAR AWAY
CLINIC.
OFFERING ABORTION KAREN CAMPUS
HELPS ENSURE THESE SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS WHO
MIGHT NEED THEM.
AND IS IMPORTANT AND IT IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD ACHIEVING
TRUE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
EQUITY FOR CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT WAS FOUR THIRTY THREE
AND WE'LL GET THE THE OPPOSING
SIDE IF THERE IS ANY THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL RIGHT IT'S THIS IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO
COME UP TO THE MIKE.
CAN GIVE THEIR NAME IN.
AND INDICATE THAT THEY'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE ASK THAT
YOU -- NOT GIVE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY WHICH WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BREVITY AND FOR BEING HERE SO IF
YOU COULD BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING PUSH ON WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND STATE OUR
POSITION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI ADAM HOW TO FEED UC DAVIS
STUDENT AND MEMBER DAVIS COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS ON HERE IN SUPPORT.
HI MOLLY MERMAN UC DAVIS STUDENT
MEMBER OF DAVIS COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
A RUSSIAN AMEND UC DAVIS STUDENT
MEMBER OF THE DAVIS COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI CC YEAR FULL UC DAVIS STUDENT
ALSO MEMBER OF DAVIS BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT.
MY RALLIES IN ALL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGIE MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
TEN A PRICE ON BEHALF OF BLACK
WOMEN FROM ON THIS IS THE
DAUGHTER OF A WOMAN'S HEALTH
NERFED NURSE PRACTITIONER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M OFFER YOU SAID I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CAITLYN OVER TURF A UC IRVINE
STUDENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI EMILY JACKSON I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR AND A PART TIME
STUDENT COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI LYNETTE JACKSON MOTHER
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI HAILEY NIGHT LOW INCOME FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI GRACE CHEN FIRST YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT AT UC SAN DIEGO PARDEE
CST MEDICINES FOR CHOICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI INTO THE DAWN FROM YOU SEE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PHOEBE ABRAMOWITZ DISTANCE
UNITED FREE PRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AT BERKELEY A CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY CHINA EXECUTIVE OF
STUDENTS UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AT UC BERKELEY AND
SAYING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
NUTRITIONAL SCIENCES FOR
PHYSIOLOGY AND METABOLISM HERE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
TWENTY FOUR HI I'M DEANNA
DURANTE I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
IF.
HELLO I'M STEPHANIE TOUR IS A
STUDENT AT UCLA AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE BRUINS HI I'M PAULA -- I'M A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT
AT UCLA AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS.
HI MY NAME IS COURTING BRUSHING
MY CAL STATE LONG BEACH ALARM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI BUT NONE THE PHOTO FIRST CHEN
AT UCLA AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MARIA CARDONA FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME DHAKA
STUDENT FROM UCLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TO SELL UCLA'S STUDENT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL CO WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT -- HUTCHINSON
WITH ACT FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS CO
SPONSOR IN ITS FROM SUPPORT.
I WAS WITH A COPY ON THE ON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD GENERATION
ACTION AT UC RIVERSIDE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
IN GEORGIA WITH PLAN PENSIONERS
IN ACTION AT YOUTH YOU ARE WITH
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AUSTIN JUNE WITH CAL STATE
FULLERTON A STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER SEVEN TEN PRESIDENT OF
THE COLLEGE DEMOCRATIC UC
RIVERSIDE STRONG SUPPORT. TO BE
A MANAGER FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE IN PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M ALLI LEAHY OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS AND WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI THERE AMBER I MEAN THAT FROM
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT ELASTICS.
MY NAME IS SANTIAGO TABULA I AM
A GRADUATE OF UC SANTA CRUZ IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M TEARING THE MORE I GO TO UC
SANTA CRUZ AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'M JULIAN HODGES JUNIOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
CRUZ AND FRIEND OF WOMEN AND SIX
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THIS
BILL WOULD OPENS THE HOT.
SUPPORT.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF A
QUALITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SINGLE AGENT OF UC
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CAPTAIN FEDERAL STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRUCE SO SAYS STUDENT AT SAC
STATE AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HORNETS DOCTOR JENNIFER CHEN
OBGYN RESIDENT REPRESENTING THE
ACLU A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LONG BEEN SEAL STUDENT AT SAC
STATE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE NOVEL PROUD ALUMNI OF UC
DAVIS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FRONTIER NANDO'S -- PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY STUDENT
AT MILLS COLLEGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CARLY VENDOR -- GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ERICA CASEY I'M A
GRADUATING SENIOR AT UC BERKELEY
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI AM DISSOLVE ASK IS A SENIOR
AT UC BERKELEY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ABBY A MEMO UP FIRST
GENERATION.
COLLEGE STUDENTS SECONDARY
GENERATION ETHIOPIAN AMERICAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
LIBBY BENEDICT PROUD UCLA BRUIN
CLASS OF SEVENTY SIX ALSO
REPRESENTING TEACH TRAINING IN
EARLY ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTHCARE INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
DEBBIE BAMBERGER NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND PROUD ABORTION
PROVIDER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE KIND OF FIGHT SIR A JUNIOR
AT UC BERKELEY AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB.
TWENTY FOUR NATALIE MELENDEZ
GRADUATING SENIOR AT UC MERCED
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MERCER MARTINEZ UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MERCED AND AS A
SURVIVOR SEXUAL ASSAULT A STRONG
SUPPORTER SB.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
I'M HOUSTON HERNANDEZ OF A
GRADUATING SENIOR AT LONG BEACH
STATE UNIVERSITY AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI AM CATEGORY SHERRY I'M A
GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M NILE ALLEN BY RECENT
GRADUATE OF UC SANTA BARBARA AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
SPELL THANK YOU.
HI AM CHANNEL IT IS THE FIRST
YEAR YOU SEE SANTA BARBARA AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN ROBERTS I AM
A STUDENT AT ORANGE COAST
COLLEGE I'M REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY YOUNG DEMOCRATS
AND ME TOO MOVEMENT OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
I AM HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT --
AS A SURVIVOR OF COLLEGE RAPE
THANK YOU.
HI I BELIEVE THE VIEW OF US WAS
STUDENTS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AT
UC SANTA BARBARA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
FOR HI AM MARIAM JINKINS AND THE
CURRENT USE YOUR STUDENT NAME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
HI MY NAME IS COLONEL DESIGNS
SOFTWARE UC BERKELEY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
SHANNON HOW THIS NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA WHERE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL PROUD TO SUPPORT.
ALSO I'M A UC BERKELEY GRADUATE.
AND ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY ANGER I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND PROUD GRADUATE OF
UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM OVER SO HELL I'M A GOOD
FRIEND OF JESSE'S AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HI THERE K. ON AS FAR
AS THE UC DAVIS MEDICAL STUDENT
INSTRUCTS.
FOR THANK YOU.
HI RAQUEL SO SIR UC DAVIS
MEDICAL STUDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHECK A BUCKLEY UC
DAVIS MEDICAL STUDENT ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI CARL CAME UC DAVIS MEDICAL
STUDENT AND FORMER REPRODUCTIVE
OPTIONS CONCERT I MEAN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANGELES ART -- ALUMNI OF CSU
SACRAMENTO AND FIRST YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
KEVIN MOORE DOES ALL THE ALUMNI
OF UC RIVERSIDE AND JOHNS
HOPKINS SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND UC DAVIS MEDICAL STUDENT
INSTRUCTS.
DOCTOR JENNY HUNG PEDIATRICIAN
PRACTICING AND THE SOUTH BAY LOS%
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS THANK.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR PRINCE ALL LAWLER ALSO AT
PEDIATRIC RESIDENT -- PRACTICING
IN THE SOUTH BAY AND THE SALEM
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR NEW ATTORNEY
PEDIATRICIAN WORKING IN SOUTH
BAY LOS ANGELES NUMBER OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
TO SHOULD NINE IN SUPPORT.
GEN FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
HI BE AFFILIATED WITH THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
SPONSOR AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARCH PLAN GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY AND REPRESENTING THE
FOUNDERS FOR SB TWENTY FOUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JUGGLING RODRIGUEZ COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ON SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION DIE IN THE HOUSE --
TO TO COME FORWARD MISTER CHAIR
MY NAME IS ANGELA GILYARD IN --
EIGHT I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR
HEALTH POLICY FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND SO WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL WE ARE KIND OF IN
BETWEEN BUT WE ARE DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT OF WOMEN'S RUPERT
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND THE
ISSUE FOR US.
IS NOT ABOUT -- PRO CHOICE WE
ARE PRO CHOICE SO -- WE WORK
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES
GOING FORWARD -- BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
SCALE AT THIS TIME OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANKS FOR SHARING THAT.
AND THAT IS ON THE RECORD SO I
KNOW WE HAVE FOLKS THAT -- ONE A
LINE UP TO THE MICROPHONE IS
THERE ANY -- SAY AGAIN YEAH.
IF YOU IF YOU'RE PART OF THE
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA
ALLOW AGAIN TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH AT THE UP HERE AT
THE AT THE TABLE SO THERE'S ROOM --
IF YOU HAVE THREE WITNESSES YOU
CAN DIVIDE YOUR TIME BUT
ACTUALLY IT'S FOR THE FOUR
MINUTES AND THIRTY THREE SECONDS
TO BE FAIR SO I WILL.
I'LL KEEP TRACK OF THAT I HOPE
YOU GUYS ARE ORGANIZED IN TERMS
OF WHO GOES FIRST.
BUT IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND BEGIN AT USE AS YOU
SEE FIT.
HI MY NAME IS TO MICAH BASSMAN
OCCURRENCE TO UC BERKELEY A MUCH
WHILE YOU KNOW THEM HERE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AND OPEN ASK
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE FOR ME BY MY YOU'LL MY TWO
MINUTES TO MY COLLEAGUE KRISTIN.
OKAY TURNOUT.
ADDRESS MY CONCERNS SB TWENTY
FOUR A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH -- THAT TRANSFORMS LIFE
AFFIRMING ON CAMPUS HEALTH
CENTERS INTO ABORTION VENDORS I
AM CHRISTIAN HAWKINS ON THE
PRESENT OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF
AMERICA.
WE CURRENTLY SERVE MORE THAN
TWELVE HUNDRED STUDENTS FOR LIFE
GROUPS ON COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES IN ALL
FIFTY STATES INCLUDING MORE THAN
NINETY RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS POLLS SHOW WE REPRESENT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR GENERATION
REJECTS THE VIOLENT DESTRUCTION
THAT IS ABORTION WE ENVISION A
NATION WHERE NO STUDENT IS EVER
FORCED. TO CHOOSE BETWEEN HER
EDUCATION AND HER CHILD -- WE
BELIEVE WOMEN AND STUDENTS
SHOULD BE GIVEN ALL THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED ON CAMPUSES.
FOR THEMSELVES OF THEIR FAMILY
THROUGH TITLE NINE ENFORCEMENT
EVEN OUROWN PREGNANT ON CAMPUS
PROGRAM.
IS ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS I COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE ASKING FOR
NOVO ON THIS MEASURE A MASSIVE
DISTRACTION FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES THE TO EDUCATE
FUTURE PROFESSIONALS AND LEADERS
OF OUR STATE AND OUR NATION.
BY DESIGN SB TWENTY FOUR WILL
CREATE CHAOS INCREASE LEGAL
LIABILITY FOR SCHOOLS AND
POTENTIAL LOSS OF STUDENT LIFE
AS WELL AS ESTABLISH A
POTENTIALLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
PROGRAM.
BY LEADING THE CONSCIENCE RIGHTS
OF BOTH STUDENTS AND UNIVERSITY
HEALTH CENTER PERSONNEL.
APPROPRIATE ANALYSIS OF THE
LIABILITY CERTAIN TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL HAS YET TO
BE MADE.
THE COST OF RETOOLING CAMPUS
HEALTH CENTERS INTO ABORTION
FACILITIES INCLUDING PREPARING
FOR THE WORST CASE SCENARIOS OF
YOUNG WOMEN HEMORRHAGING AND
LEADING OUT IN THEIR DORM ROOMS
ARE ON THE COMMUNAL BATHROOM
TOILET.
HAVE YET TO BEEN TOTALED RATHER
THAN JUST BEING A SIMPLE DRUG
PRESCRIBED TO RELIEVE A MY GREEN
OR HEADACHE THE DISTRIBUTION OF
ARE YOU FORTY SIX MUST BE
HANDLED UNDER STRICT MEDICAL
SUPERVISION AS CONDITIONS LIKE
AB ATOMIC PREGNANCY.
AN UNDETERMINED LEADER PREGNANCY
CAN BE FATAL THE FDA UPDATED
THEIR ADVERSE IMPACTS OF THIS
COCKTAIL EARLIER THIS MONTH.
I DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE REPORTED
THERE WERE TWENTY FOUR DEATHS OF
WOMEN ASSOCIATED WITH THE STRONG.
AS WELL AS FORTY TWO HUNDRED
REPORTED ADVERSE AFFECTS
INCLUDING SEVERAL CASES OF
SEVERE SYSTEMIC INFECTION THAT
WERE FATAL.
WHEN THE ABORTION DRUG COCKTAIL
FAILS AS IT DOES 10% OF THE TIME
SURGICAL ABORTION IS THE NEXT
STEP?
THE QUESTION IS ARE CALIFORNIANS
INTERESTED AND OUTFITTING CAMPUS
HEALTH CENTERS TO BECOME
SURGICAL AORTION FACILITIES
WITH THE COMPENSATED PERSONALITY
EXTENSIVE EMERGENCY EQUIPMENT.
UNLIKE SURGICAL ABORTION WHICH
IS DONE IN OUR PATIENTS ADDITION
WHERE THE PATIENT IS CLOSELY
MONITORED IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
DISMEMBERMENT OF THE CHILD
WITHIN HER.
THE ARE YOU FORTY SIX ABORTION
HAPPENS WHEN SHE IS ALONE IN HER
JOURNAL DORM ROOM OR IN HER
COMMUNITY BATHROOM.
ANY WOMAN WHO'S EXPERIENCED A
MISCARRIAGE WONDERSTONE AND THE
PAIN IS UNBEARABLE AT TIMES BUT
INSTEAD OF BEING RUSSIAN
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR SUPPORT
MEDICAL MONITORING AND PAIN
RELIEF.
SHE IS TOLD TO REMAIN WHERE SHE
IS AT THE BLEEDING BECOMES TOO
HEAVY TO SIT ON THE TOILET NOT
LOOK DOWN AND FLUSH.
AND GIVEN THAT BOTH THE UC AND
CSU HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH STUDENT FEES IS NOT JUST
POSSIBLE BUT LIKELY THAT
STUDENTS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WILL ULTIMATELY BE PAYING FOR
THEIR CLASSMATES ABORTIONS.
FURTHER NO PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN
MADE IN THIS PROPOSAL TO PROTECT
THE CONSCIENCE RIGHT TO STUDENTS
OR HEALTH CENTER PERSONNEL WHO
DON'T WANT TO FIND TOILET BOWL
ABORTIONS.
CONSIDERING THE EXPENSE OF LOS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
FLOW OF THE WAS SERRA WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT FOUND THAT THE
STATE CANNOT COMPEL PRO LIFERS.
TO SERVE AS SALES TEAMS FOR
ABORTIONS. ONE CAN EQUALLY
PRESUME THAT THE SUPREME COURT
IS GOING TO HAVE SOMETHING TO
SAY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FORCES PEOPLE TO PAY FOR AND
PARTICIPATE IN THESE CHEMICAL
ABORTIONS ON CAMPUS.
IT'S CONTROVERSIAL BILLS BEING
FORCED FOR DESPITE THE FACT THAT
ABORTION IS AVAILABLE WITHIN
FIVE TO SEVEN MILES OF EVERY
SINGLE COLLEGE CAMPUS IN THE
STATE A FACT THAT THE FORME PRO
CHOICE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
JERRY BROWN.
NOTED LAST YEAR.
THERE IS NO EDUCATIONAL REASON
TO EXPOSE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS TO SUCH A RISK AND
LIABILITY IT TAXPAYERS AND
STUDENT EXPENSE ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF OTHER AVAILABLE TURN
TIPS WE HAVE.
OKAY A DORM ROOM A COMMUNAL
BATHROOM TOILET IS NO PLACE TO
EXERCISE THE POWER CHOICE I ASK
YOU TODAY TO REJECT THIS RISKY
COSTLY AND DANGEROUS PROPOSAL
OKAY THANK YOU SO THAT HAS USED
UP ALL THE TIME IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE A SUMMARY.
COMMENT SHORT I'LL GIVE YOU THAT
OPPORTUNITY OTHERWISE YOU GUYS
ARE ALL TOGETHER YES OKAY THEN
YOUR TIME HAS BEEN COMPLETED.
WELCOME TO YOUR THE OTHER
MICROPHONE AND AND AND ANNOUNCE
YOUR OPPOSITION IF YOU WISH OKAY
SO -- THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO SHARE THEIR OPPOSITION IF YOU
GO TO THE MICROPHONE INDICATE
YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR POSITION -- AS YOU HAVE
HEARD -- YOUR ADVOCATES AGAINST
OF MADE THEIR PITCH SO WE ASK
YOU TO JUST -- DO NAME AND AYE
AYE AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH SO
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS.
NOT.
A POLICY SPENT OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MONEY SO -- MORALIS I
SUPPOSE AT A SUPPORT ABSTINENCE
AND I OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR VERY MUCH.
HI MY READ THE CHRISTIAN I'M A
NURSE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THERE'S OTHER METHODS THANK YOU.
BRIAN BRECHT MEDIA UC SANTA
BARBARA CLASS OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
I OPPOSE THIS BILL -- BILL I
WOULD USE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M PRETTY HILLARY PASTOR SHILOH
TABERNACLE CHURCH AND I PERCENT
PERSONALLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
THE END REFERS IMPOSE THIS BILL
AND I'M A PARENT OF A COLLEGE
STUDENT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNY SANTANA CO
PASTOR SHADOW TABERNACLE RANCHO
CUCAMONGA WE STRONGLY DEFINITELY
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NOT TELL WHERE I OPPOSE THE BILL.
IN A CORPORATE AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
I'M SANDRA SHILOH TABERNACLE
CHURCH I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIA SILVIA AND I'M
ALSO CO PASTOR AT CHANNELS.
MINISTRIES AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SANDRA MARQUEZ
ON THE UC DAVIS GRADUATE.
AND THEN ALSO BAYSIDE CHURCH
MEMBER I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE DEFENSE.
UNBORN.
SO I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
I AM IRISHMAN DOES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GALINA MULLER AND I'M
A GRADUATE OF HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AND I'M JACQUELINE PERSON AND I
AM A UC DAVIS GRADUATE AND I PUT
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PHYLLIS BAY
HUGH I'M A MOTHER TO YOU SEE
GRADUATES AND THE CONCERNED
GRANDMOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IGOR KNOWS LIFE
I'M FATHER WITH THREE KIDS AND I
ALSO DEACON OF SLOW CHURCH AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TANYA FEATHER
CHECK A POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENTS I HAVE FOUR KIDS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELENA DRIVING
YOKE AND I OPPOSE AS BE TWENTY
FOUR I'M LOW INCOME FIRST
GENERATION IN COLLEGE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THINK.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS N. BREED DEAN I'M A
TAXPAYER AND I'M A UNITED
METHODIST WOMAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JC CARPENTER I AM A
WOMAN WHO WAS TRAUMATIZED BY
ABORTION EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND
I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TWENTY FOUR THE BEST THE PROUD
FATHER OF TWO AND I DEFINITELY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY I HAD I'M A
MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER AND I'M
VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE RAIN IS IN JOKES
AND SUCKS THEY GRADUATE AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BEN AND I POSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WE SEE THE MATING
FORMER LONG COME COLLEGE STUDENT
AND MOTHER OF FOUR FORMER
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS REBECCA LATER UP AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MAGGIE WILLIAMS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS IN A CHRISTIAN CHECK
ON THE CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HI MY NAME IS
MILLER AND A STRONG GRIP WAS
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA BE DONE I
HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS AND THE SHOW
GOING OPPOSES AS BE TWENTY FOUR
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE PRATT.
I AM THE MOTHER OF THREE
CHILDREN I AM A CAL POLY
GRADUATE TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND A
MASTER'S GRADUATE FROM UCSB.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I RECEIVED
HEALTHCARE REPORT ACT OF HEALTH
CARE AT CAL POLLY.
KAHL CENTER THAT NEARLY.
TOOK A WAVE MY FERTILITY AND MY
RIGHT TO HAVE CHILDREN AND I HAD
TO HAVE IT IS TO HAVE A FAMILY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINA QUESTIONS JOKE AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN THE BOND A REGISTERED NURSE I
CARE FOR YOU FOR WOMEN WHO HAVE
CHEMICAL ABORTION EV SUFFERERS
OF A LOT OF HEMORRHAGING OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI HI MY NAME IS ANDREA CREWS
AYE OPPOSED IS SUPER STRONG THE
BILL TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARK PERSON A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CLARENCE LOUIS ST
MERRY'S.
VACAVILLE CATHOLIC CHURCH
MINISTRY LEADER.
I STRONGLY.
DISAPPROVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CARLY HEIL RESPECT LIFE ST
MERRY'S BACK CALL CALIFORNIA AND
THANK GOD MY DAUGHTER DOES NOT
GO TO COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME'S LUCAS INTERCOM OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SERGIO LITERATURE
COBB STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S ARM I'M
CURRENTLY A MIDDLE SCHOOL A
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL NOT ONLY THIS BILL I OPPOSE
ANY KIND OF ABORTION.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PHILIP WAS TROUBLE I
HAVE SEVEN KIDS AND I STRUNG IT
UP WITH THE DEAL.
HI MY NAME IS RUTH PARIS I AND
MY TEACHER MOTHER OF FIFI HAVE
TO GRADUATE I STRONGLY
DISAPPROVE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ELIJAH CAM I AM AN
INCOMING FRESHMAN AT FRANCISCAN
UNIVERSITY OF STEUBENVILLE AND I
OPPOSE SENATE BILL.
TWENTY FOUR HI MY NAME IS ANDREW
MUCH I AM A CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I OPPOSE SENATE BILL
[inaudible] TWENTY FOUR MY NAME
IS SAMUEL CAM AND THE AYE
OPPOSED SENATE BILL.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS AMPLE
DISCIPLINE CA I AM FIVE ZERO
NINE SO AM I OPPOSE THESE BILLS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER TO SLING CO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND YOU COULD -- DIFFERENTIAL
CUCAMONGA I OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR THERESA A GOVERNOR
CAN ATHEISTS AND DEMOCRATS
FOUNDER OF PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS LEADING
A SAFE I STRONGLY SUPPORT LIFE
IN THIS POSSIBILITY OF APPLES
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RALPH MORE LADDIE.
MEMBER OF SAINT ROSE PARISH CELL
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO A NINETEEN
SEVENTY GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS VERY
DANGEROUS AND UNNECESSARY BILL.
MY NAME IS CINDY MUCH AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IN A BOX IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR STUDENTS FOR
LIFE OF AMERICA REPRESENTING
FIFTY STUDENT GROUPS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR MORNING JOHN SPEROS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
MOMENTO STUDENTS FOR LIFE.
MY NAME IS -- STEVEN HOLCOMB
ISN'T HEN AS A PARENT WHO
ABORTED THE CHILD IT IS NOT WART
REMOVAL HEY STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
MY NAME IS JUDY -- TOLD AND OUR
OLDEST GRANDDAUGHTER GRADUATES
FROM A CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY
THIS YEAR HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE WAIT PERIOD.
THAT MY DAUGHTER HAD.
SHE WOULD HAVE AN ABORTION.
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLOORS WITH
A CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GABBY LARA SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS FOR LIFE --
PUBLIC RELATIONS OFFICER
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIANA MIRANDA AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF STUDENTS
FOR LIFE AT SAN JOSE STATE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RICKY SILVA A LIVING
YOUR RATE THE GIRL CAPITAL AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF SERIES FOR
LIFE IT SOUNDS THE STATE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CAMILLE CISNEROS
AND I'MTHE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COORDINATOR WITH
STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA
REPRESENTING FIFTY NINE STUDENT
GROUPS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND HOFFMAN I'M
A MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND I'M HERE
TO SAY AN ADAMANT OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNY SHUTE FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANE AUTO I'M A JESUS
FOLLOWER I CHOOSE LIFE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA -- SOCIAL
MEDIA COORDINATOR FOR FIVE SEVEN
CISCO AND I URGE ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE
NO OR ABSTAINED ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VICTOR LOCAL AND
THROWING.
UP POLLS HE'S BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS THE GHOST
GONNA POST THIS BILL.
I AM I'VE INCLUDES CO CHILDCARE
PROVIDER FATHER OF FOUR I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
WE NEED TO TURN ON THE THE I AM
[inaudible] FOR LIFE.
I AM FOUNDER COULDN'T SOFTEN
OPPOSES THE SB.
TWENTY FOUR ENGINE AS SOON AS IN
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL IN.
STE STRONGLY ANTI EVERYTHING.
MY NAME IS CHERYL BURKE CARD --
MY MOTHER HAD CONSIDERED HAVING
AN ABORTION.
AND IT WAS NOTTHAT EASY TO DO
WITH THAT TIME AND I'M GRATEFUL
THAT THEY CHOSE LIFE I'M GLAD TO
BE HER.
MY NAME IS SERRA POND I'M A
MOTHER OF FIVE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS NAOMI VAN
WHITE I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
REPRESENT CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WHICH IS THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN ACROSS OUR STATE. TO SAY
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THE
UNBORN BABIES NEED A RIGHT TO
CHOOSE LIFE [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- MILENA MENDOZA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE OTHER CORNER FROM SACRAMENTO
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
A NAME IS RUTH RADHA AND I AM
FOR AND I'M FROM GRANITE BAY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS AN HONOR
AND A STRONGLY OPPOSES.
I'M VERONICA RADHA MOTHER OF
NINE CHILDREN.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DANIEL RODHAM.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM GABRIEL ROTH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO STEVE PATTON REPRESENTING
BISHOP PIE MAY SOTO AND THE
DIOCESE OF SACRAMENTO ASKING.
YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO OR TO
ABSTAIN ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI JESSICA AND IT'S ABOUT OKAY
SO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A SPELL
AND ASK THAT YOU DO THE SAME.
HELLO MY NAME ELAINE THEY'VE
DEFINED OF AND I AM STRONG
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A LEASE AB FAN OF A
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOU WANT TO SPEAK ALSO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA AND THIS IS
HOPE AND I HAD TO CHOICE TO DO
IT OR NOT TO DO IT BUT I DID A
GOOD CHOICE HER NAME IS HOPE.
AND I HOPE YOU GUYS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL HOPE YOU GUYS MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS NEED TO SORT OF DO
COME I'M PREGNANT AND I AM
CALLED TO ROOF -- OF KIDS BOOKS
AND I'M STRONG LEVELS THIS BILL.
I LIVE OVER THERE -- SOME DOUBLE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FRANCESCA ROSE BARSKY
MOTHER OF TWO MY FIRST BABY I
WAS ENCOURAGED TO GET AN
ABORTION I'M GLAD I DIDN'T AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND VIRGINIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OLGA I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO DAUGHTERS AND AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VERA.
I OWN BOSS THE BILL AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS OXANA AYE
OPPOSED.
THE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANISHA SOFTER I HAVE
FIVE CHILDREN AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
MY NAME.
IS ABOVE WILL.
THIS BILL IS NOT GOOD.
I'M IN A POSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS BILL.
THE GOLLY.
I GOT IT IS STILL AND KILLED
CHILDREN AND POSITION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON.
HI MY NAME IS THE JENNA A
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THE TWENTY
FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
COVERING UP I'M CREATION AND
MOTHER OF FIVE AND I'M OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA I COVER FOR
KIDS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I WILL TEMA DODIG I WAS BUILT.
TWENTY FOUR HELLO MY NAME IS THE
LIMITED CONTINUE I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL SB TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A REALLY A PACK AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME STEVEN PRATT AND A
COUPLE A STATE GRADUATE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL I AM IN
OUR GRAND MOTHER OF FIVE
CHILDREN AND HAD TWENTY
GRANDCHILDREN I BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY DANGEROUS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'LL ADVICE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL SCHAEFER.
FATHER OF SIX AND THE HI --
GRADUATE OF JAIL POP UP KILL US
I'M SORRY BERKELEY.
AND THIS BILL THANK YOU JUST ADD
ANOTHER CONFUSING THING TO MAKE
IT EASIER ACTUALLY AGENDA EVERY
PERSON NEXT PERSON IN LINE.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN KELLER
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE O THE
AUTHOR -- WE I'M WITH CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL -- WE DID FILE
A AN AMICUS BRIEF IN THE NET FOR
THE TO SERRA CASE LAST YEAR AND
I HOPE WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
AGAIN WITH THE RIGHT -- BUT WE
STAND PREPARED VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN DIRTY ON BEHALF OF RIGHT TO
LIFE ESSENTIAL CALIFORNIA AND
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AT FRESNO
STATE OPPOSING BILL.
THANK YOU.
A GREAT BURKE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MERRY STRUCK CATHOLIC WOMAN A
JOY.
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ROSE MERION TURNS FORMER OB
NURSE FORMER COLLEGE NURSE
FORMER CHILDBIRTH EDUCATOR
[inaudible]
OUR I OPPOSE.
SB TWENTY FOUR LIABILITY
LIABILITY LIKE YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PERSON IN LINE.
HI MY NAME IS SECTORS KILEY I'M
A PHYSICIAN RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ALL WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE IT INCLUDING ABORTION IS
HEALTH CARE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT PERCENT ATTIC FROM
ROSEVILLE AND I HAVE THREE
DAUGHTERS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS A LOCAL INCOME MODEL
FIVE KIDS AND I'M STROKE.
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARINA GOGA I
HAVE THREE KIDS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A LOT ABOUT
SOMEONE FROM ROSEVILLE I HAVE
FOUR BOYS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SO LONG OF THE JOKE I
HAVE FOUR KIDS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT HOW THEY SHAILA
FROM SACRAMENTO I AM A MOTHER OF
FIVE KIDS AND A STRONG WEB OF
THIS BILL.
HE HERE NOW IS AN OPPOSED HIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME HAY MEDICAL LASER
BARGAIN MAZA.
STUDENT [inaudible]
THE MY CHILDREN THE STUDY IN
COULD IT CHOPPED SCHOOL.
I OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
OUT EAGER FATHER OF TOOL HOW TO
ONE MY TAX DOLLAR TO WORK FOR
ABORTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU POSES BILL THANK YOU.
LIFE IS GIVEN BY GOD NOT BY JUST
JUST RIGHT SO YOUNG LEE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I YOU HE NEAR THE UNTIL POSES
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING OUT.
HEY MICHAEL AND HE OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA AND I
MOTHER OF THREE KIDS AND I AM
VERY PRO LIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL OKAY THANK YOU
FOR COMING OUT MY NAME IS MONEY
NOT I AM POLLS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M VICTORIA I HAVE A POLLS
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALL THEY ASK YOU AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL AS BE TWENTY
FOUR IT IS DESTROYING THE LIVES
IT TAKEN PLATE AWAY THANK LABOR
AND MONEY WAS JUST GIVING NAMES
IN OUR POSITIONS PLEASE MY NAME
IS SUSAN MAC THIS AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOUBLE CANNELLA AYE
OPPOSED IS BUILDING.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS VICTORIA
IT'S LA SHOW AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
Q. MY NAME IS EMMA CAM A LOCK
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HI OPPOSE IS
BETWEEN.
FOUR MY NAME IS WHAT IS GOING TO
LOOK AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VALENTINA COMO LOCK I
OPPOSE THE BILL IS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS IS MEDINA
GOES BUT I'M BOYS THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OLGA PUSH GO AYE
OPPOSED IS BILLED AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME LETTER TO
BRITISH CRIER POST.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS NATALIE
ARNETT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M JUST TIRED IT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT VALID PENSION I
AM MOTHER OF FIVE KIDS ON AYE IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARINE AS A BLOCK ME
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ONLY NAM IRAN AND A
MOM OF TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EUROPE WAS IS BILL.
MY NAME IS A GOOD THING THAT
THEY'RE GONNA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ON A TOTALLY ON
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANA I AM CHRISTIAN
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GALINA AND AYE
OPPOSED IS BEING.
MY NAME SALAS GLADYS OPPOSES
BILL.
MY NAME IS YURI -- POSE THIS
MY NAME IS TYLER BORN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S TINY GLIDERS AND I
MY NAME IS TANYA TO RECALL NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DIANA OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS INEVITABLE SHOOK AND
IN THE POLLS AS BE.
MY NAME IS RITA TO ZERO NICE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HE JUST SECOND THE MICROPHONE
GIVE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THOSE ARE JUST COMING IN.
MY NAME IS KARENA SURGICAL IN A
IS FROM GLOBAL AS A AS BE A
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LARISSA DOBRO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS SANDRA
THE ROLE I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU FOR THE NAME IS DENNIS
Là FOR CHECK AND OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS EUGENE AND AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL ULTIMATELY.
FOR MY NAME IS TANYA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MISTY ZERO SKIN
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME CITIES THAT IT THAT IT
BECAUSE I AM I AM OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS GENESIS TINA BY POST
HIS BEAT TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HAS LOTS ERA AND
OPPOSES BILL [inaudible]
THANK.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA AND I BOTH
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LEAN I AM A
CHRISTIAN AND I HAVE THREE
DAUGHTERS AND I CARE ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH AND I STRONGLY BELIEVE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT ONLY GOT
IS IN CHARGE OF BIRTH AND DEATH.
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
WE'RE NOT DOING REMARKS REMEMBER
NOT JUST YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IN YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
MY NAME IS NATALIA AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX BIãU I'M A
SAYS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS MENTIONED
THE ROCK AND AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
BORIS NORTH APPLES AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS DAYTONA
POSES BILL.
MY NAME IS VERENA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS.
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY AND I POSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EARL HEVERLEE I
REPRESENT THE ASSEMBLIES OF GOD
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OVER FOUR
HUNDRED CHURCHES IN THE
CONSTITUENCY OF A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO THOUSAND AND WE STAND
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD AT CIVIL SERVICE THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE LOST AN ABORTION ALL THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN HURT I
STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LINDA MIM NOT I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DONNA BURKLE Và AND
I'M A STUDENT AT RC I AM OPPOSED
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS EDWARD GARGAN I'M A
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS THE TEN I'VE GOT OFF
OF A A PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IS B..
TWENTY FOUR HI MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER KISAH IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSES BE.
TWENTY FOUR HI MY NAME IS OLIVER
LESS CRIME A REGISTERED NURSE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR HI MY NAME IS ALINA
GIRL CAN I'M A NURSE ASSISTANT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS COREY PERRY
JUNE I STRONGLY DON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I AM AGAINST AT
HELLO MY NAME JUNE YOU KANSEN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IS BE A FOR YOU.
FOR MY NAME IS SELECT MEDICARE
THIS SITE POST B. O. S. A. B..
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE.
MY NAME IS PRESS COVER PULLS.
TO A POST PLEASE BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS ROSY
AGENT CAM BY HER OPPOSE BILL IS
BIDDING.
FOR THANK YOU THAT.
HAS BEEN FOR YOU.
FOR HI MY NAME IS PETER I'M
OPALS THIS BE TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THIRTY ON THE
FOREMAN I'M A POLLS.
SB.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS TANYA
KOREAN KOREAN OF A NO OWN EYES
V..
TWENTY FOUR I AM A NUMBER THAT
OAK.
NO IS TO BE TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
OLGA POWELL OF I AM A MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN.
I OPPOSE.
SB.
TWENTY FOUR HELLO AYE OPPOSED SB
TWENTY FOUR MINUTES ALEXANDER
PALACE.
MY NAME IS THAT JUST LEFT.
IS B..
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS ON THE X.
A NOR BILL [inaudible] TWENTY
FOUR MY NAME IS VICTOR BUT THE
AREA NOW IS THE TIME.
FOR MY NAME IS EVELYN A BRANCH
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CAPABLE TOOK AND I AM
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE ROUTE OF I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NOW AND SB TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE.
MY NAME THE DEER'S AVAILABLE NOW
IS BEATS WHEN YOU.
FOR MY NAME IS THE CHEN ACTION
CO OPPOSED BILL IS BI POINT.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERY CHAIR IN
CALL OF AND A MOTHER OF THREE
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WELCOME TO TNA OF TO STRANGLE
PLEASE VOTE KNOWN AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR HELLO MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA CORN IF AND AYE
OPPOSED IS B. TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SEX ON THE MAKE IT
AGAIN I OPPOSES BEAT WHEN YOU.
FOR AND THE MISSING THE SONYA
AYE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS JILL
INACTION GUARDIAN CALL MOBILE AS
PLEASE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAY MICHAEL NOT
BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IN IT MY
NAME IS AN UPPER BODY I DON'T
SUPPORT SB [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PETER BUT THIRTY I
DON'T SUPPORT SB.
TWENTY FOUR HI MY NAME THE MAKE
UP HERE SO I DON'T SUPPORT THE
SB.
THIRTY FOUR MY NAME IS THE ONLY
NUMBER OAK ANDI WILL LITTLE AND
BILL SB. TWO TWENTY FOUR MY NAME
IS THIRTY ANOTHER LYNSKEY ON
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE SB.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME'S OXANA
PERCH AND I OPPOSE AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS LAUNDRY
PERCH AND I OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS GALINA
STROLL I OPPOSE BILL AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS ANASTASIA
AVOID CO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS FOR
YOURSELF THAT IS COOL I DON'T
SUPPORT SB.
TWENTY FOUR HELLO MY NAME IS
JULI L. AS A RESCUE AYE OPPOSED
AND STRONGLY OPPOSED AS BE
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM BE RECOMMEND CO AND I
OPPOSE AS BEFORE YOU PARK THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SET LUNCH
OPPONENT AYE OPPOSED VIEW AS A
B. TWENTY FOUR THANK.
MY NAME IS NINA I DON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AS BE TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS INNA I DON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I AM THE THE ROOM IS A AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SAYS BE IS ONE
OF TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS ERIC
JANICK.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS GALINA
JOINING A STRONG OPPOSE IS B..
TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS ANGELINA
EVERY NOOK AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE TWENTY FOURTH THANK
YOU.
HI I'M KARAGANDA ALL IS
PRESIDENT OF SAC STATE COLLEGE
DENS AND IS A SUPPORT LINE BUT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ARE YOU NUMBERS
ARE YOU A STUDENT UC SANTA CRUZ
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I THINK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK SENATOR LEYVA.
ALRIGHT THIS IS THE OPPOSITION
LINED OUT YEAH WE WERE TOLD
RIGHT BUT WE WERE TOLD IF WE
WERE TO SUPPORT YOU'D GET GET TO
THE BACK LINE SO.
MUCH I OR SECONDARY SANTA CRUZ
MOVE REPRESENT A FROM THE SEASON
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING TWENTY
EIGHTY THOUSAND YOU SEE STUDENTS
ALL IN SUPPORT OF STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
HI THIS IS CRYSTAL NINE AT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
BUT I AM SURE WITH A C. BAPTIST
PREACHER AND IN THE NAME OF THE
LORD JESUS CHRIST AND THE FEAR
OF GOD I WITH THE IMMINENT
CONTEMPT.
AROSE THIS WICKED WRETCHED BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
NEXT IS CATHERINE TERRACE SACK
ON THE GRADUATE OF SEX STATE AND
I STRONGLY PASSIONATELY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME CENTER THEY WOULD
ALTHOUGH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AS BE.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALL ITEM STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RUNNING RENTS NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SB.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU THE
PHARMACOLOGIC I AM STRONG
GRAPPLES THIS BILL S. TWENTY
FOUR I THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WE'RE GONNA AND
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING HERE MY
NAME IS LARISSA COST YOU COULD
AYE OPPOSED AS BE TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OLGA SOKOLOWSKI AYE
OPPOSES BE TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU.
OUR IF YOU HEAR THAT GIVE YOUR
VIEWS COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WE'RE ABOUT TO CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING SEE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY AND
YOU'RE IN A POSITION.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU HELLO HI
MAGGIE RIGHT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WE DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT JUST
WHEN TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR THANKS. TO THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR THEIR
ON GOING ENGAGEMENT WITH US ON
THIS BILL I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE DISCUSSIONS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING
IMPLEMENTATION IN KENYA THANKS
VERY.
OLIVIA MICHAEL SUPPOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AMBER BEASLEY I'M IN OPPOSITION
OF THE SPELL THANK YOU AMBER.
ROBIN ROMBERG.
UC GRADUATE.
THIS IS PRENATAL MURDER ON THE
CAMPUS.
JUST JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
JUST YOUR POSITION IS FINE.
ALL RIGHT WELL THAT WAS A THAT
WAS -- AND OTHER OTHER ANYBODY
OUT STILL OUTSIDE.
YEAH GO AHEAD GO AHEAD.
GLAZER REALLY SHRIDER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S FOR
LIFE AND RIGHT TO LIFE KERN
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU.
COME ON UP TO THE MICROPHONE
PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS MEGAN FERAL AND THIS
IS MARIA FRANCIS AND ICE AS A
EDUCATED WOMAN A MOTHER OF A
DAUGHTER.
OF WHO WILL BE A FUTURE COLLEGE
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE -- IN
OPPOSITION WANT TO REGISTER
THEIR THEIR POSITION.
AND IS THE SERGEANTS -- ARE WE
CLEAR ON THE OUTSIDE
[inaudible]
SERGEANTS.
BY MAKE SURE REYES HAD THEIR
CHANCE IT'S GOOD OKAY ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING PORTION OF THIS --
HEARING AND BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND AND COMMENTS.
CENTER LEAVE I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN VERY PATIENT HERE AND HEARD
A LOT OF TESTIMONY IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD BEFORE
WE GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT MISTER CHAIR --
YOU KNOW WE ARE ALL ENTITLED TO
OUR OWN OPINION HOWEVER WE ARE
NOT ENTITLED TO OUR OWN FAX.
WELL I WROTE DOWN ALL OF THE
INACCURACIES FROM THE OPPOSITION
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEM BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE DR GROSSMAN.
ELABORATE ON ONE OF THE
INACCURACIES -- THAT WAS STATED
THAT 10% OF THE TIME A
MEDICATION ABORTION FAILS I
BELIEVE THAT IS INACCURATE.
IF YOU COULD EXPAND ON THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA YES
THAT'S INCORRECT ACCORDING TO
THE FDA APPROVED LABELING FOR
MIFEPRISTONE THAT REVIEWED ALL
OF THE PUBLISHED LITERATURE FROM
UNITED STATES.
FAILURE OCCURS IN APPROXIMATELY
3% OF CASES AND THOSE CASES ARE
JUST REFERRED FOR AN ASPIRATION
PROCEDURE THESE ARE NOT THEM
CASES THAT NEED URGENT ATTENTION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR
LEVIN ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO
ADD TO THAT I'M GOOD OKAY -- ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I HAVE A
COUPLE -- CENTER LATE WITH THAT
THANK YOU -- FOR BRING IN THIS
BILL TO THE COMMITTEE -- AND TO
THE SENATE AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOUR PERSISTENCE -- YOU HAVEN'T
SPOKEN ABOUT -- MAYBE YOU COULD
ELABORATE ON THE ISSUE OF
FUNDING AS IS A COST THAT THE
STUDENTS WILL INCUR OR THERE'S
OR SOME OTHER ARRANGEMENT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
CENTER GLAZER SO THIS --
MEDICATION ABORTION WILL BE PAID
FOR ON CAMPUS EACH CAMPUS WILL
GET TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
FACILITY IS SET UP SO THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
AND THEN EACH INSTITUTION WILL
GET AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE EVENT
THAT THEY WANT TO SET UP A
HOTLINE OR WHATEVER ELSE THEY
MIGHT WANT TO USE IT.
FOR AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE BILL REQUIRES THIS AT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS OF SEED
MONEY BEFORE IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IS THAT RIGHT
CORRECT.
OKAY AND IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD WOULD
MANDATE THIS TREATMENT FOR ANY
ANYBODY WHO -- IS IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE NO THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION -- THIS BILL
ULTIMATELY IS WHAT IT IS IT IS
ABOUT CHOICE NO ONE IS BEING
ASKED TO HAVE AN ABORTION NO ONE
IS BEING FORCED TO HAVE AN
ABORTION.
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WOMEN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
SO IF YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
APPROVE OF THIS PROCEDURE
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO UNDERGO IT THAT IS
CORRECT [inaudible]
GET.
ALL RIGHT WELL I I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT BILL -- ONE PERSON'S
OPINION HALF AND HALF.
I WAS HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT LAST
YEAR AND I'M GLAD YOUR
PERSISTENCE AND AND BRING IT
BACK -- I'M HOPEFUL AS I KNOW
YOU ARE THAT -- WILL GIVE
STUDENTS A CHOICE AND THAT'S A
THAT'S A WONDERFUL THING TO DO
AND TO MAKE IT AS CONVENIENT AS
CAN BE SO THEY CAN MAKE A CHOICE
THAT SO AT THAT WORKS FOR THEM.
SO I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROMCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
SO TO BE A TIME TO GET A MOTION --
ARE YOU OUT OF MY ALLOWED TO
MAKE MOTIONS.
OKAY I'M SHARING BUT YOU'RE NOT.
YES I'D LIKE.
TO ASK YOU CAN EITHER.
OKAY WELL I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO CAME OUT TODAY TO
SHARE THEIR VIEWS IN FAVOR AND
AGAINST CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU
FOR THE GREAT PRESENTATION.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO COME BACK -- TO
RECOGNIZABLE OCEAN -- AND WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THIS --
PORTION OF OUR HEARINGS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH VERY GOOD THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER.
AND I THINK AS I THINK SHE CAN
GET THE OUTBACK I CAN MAKE A
MOTION.
WITH.
YEAH YEAH RIGHT YEAH.
BUT HEY WAIT.
WHAT YOU COME BACK EACH YEAR ON
THE COMMOTION LET'S GET THIS
GOING?
I I THINK -- FOR EVERYBODY HERE
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE A
MOTION IF YOU WANT TO HEAR IT
JUST GIVEN A SECOND DAN DAN.
WHAT TO WATCH HOW THIS WORKS I'M
IN TO RETURN?
HOW TO RETURN THE GAVEL THE
CHAIR LAY THAT THE PERMANENT YOU?
READY AND WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT SB TWENTY FOUR WAS JUST
HEARD TO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
THE BILL.
CHERYL.
SURE LEYVA YES I WOULD LOVE TO
MOVE THIS BILL THANK YOU WE ARE
LEFT IN THE CALL IN SB TWENTY
FOUR IT HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TO SB TWENTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA.
I WILL KNOW WILK NO CHIANG
RUSSELL GLAZER HI THESE ARE AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO CAME
OUT TODAY FULL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION
-- OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
IF YOU COULD -- EXIT THE ROOM --
QUIETLY OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT.
NEXT UP IS ITEM FIVE SP ONE
SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER LEYVA
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CENTER-LLEVO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK OUR GREAT
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING ME
WITH THIS BILL AND MAKING IT.
EVEN BETTER.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY FOR THE
CHILD CARE STABILIZATION FORMULA
WOULD ESTABLISH A SINGLE
REGIONAL EYES STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. FOR
CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS A MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
SERVICES FOR THESE CHILDREN
SPECIFICALLY IT HAS TWO
DIFFERENT UNALIGNED SYSTEMS FOR
REIMBURSING PROVIDERS.
THAT MEET TWO DIFFERENT
STANDARDS THIS BIFURCATED SYSTEM
RATE SYSTEM AND IN ADEQUATE RATE
REIMBURSEMENTS COMPLICATE
EFFORTS TO FUND AND DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CARE.
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT MEET
THE DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF ALL
CHILDREN.
WELL ALSO.
ADDRESSING THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF THE CHILDREN BEING
SERVED.
THIS UNALIGNED TO SYSTEM
APPROACH LIMITS ACCESS BILLS TO
MAXIMIZE PROGRAM QUALITY AND IS
FORCING MANY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OUT OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THE CURRENT
RATE SYSTEM RESOURCES
EXPENDITURES SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED AND EXPENDED IN A
WAY THAT ONE COMPENSATES
TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
COST OF PROVIDING CARE. TO ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THREE
RECOGNIZE THE COST OF MEETING
VARYING QUALITY MEET STANDARDS.
AND FOR INCENTIVIZE HIGH
STANDARDS AND PARTICIPATION IN
RESEARCH BASED QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN JUST
ONE IN NINE CHILDREN ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CARE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY RECEIVE
SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE WE MUST INVEST IN OUR
WORK FORCE CALIFORNIA IS A
DIVERSE STATE WITH THE FIRST
CHILD CARE NEEDS.
OUR STATE IS STRENGTHENED BY ITS
ABILITY TO PROVIDE PARENTS WITH
A CHOICE.
WHEN IT COMES TO SELECTING THE
EARLY LEARNING EXPERIENCES THAT
ARE MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES?
THROUGH THESE REFORMS CALIFORNIA
CAN ACHIEVE A MORE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT CHILDREN AND
IN SUPPORT IS ERIN GABLE WITH
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND ON THE
SNEERING SHIRT WITH CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER.
LADIES RIGHT WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
RUNNING AHEAD OF SCHEDULE OR NOT --
BUT RULES ARE.
RULES ARE TWO MINUTES PER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD AND I WILL DO
MY BEST.
TO STICK WITHIN THE PARAMETERS
I'M I'M DONNA SALINGER I'M WITH
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
WHERE A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES THE LOS ANGELES AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY AFTER WHAT HAS BEEN MANY
MANY YEARS OF WORK IN OUR FIELD
TO TRY TO FIND A WAY TO UNIFY
OUR REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM.
AND I WAS PLEASED TO BE ONE OF
THE CO CHAIRS ALONG WITH THE
ABILITY OF AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER WHAT YOU
SEE BEFORE YOU IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED -- THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA'S
BIFURCATED AND THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE HUNDRED YEAR HISTORY OF
CHILD CARE SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGE TO
MOVE US ALL IN THE SAME
DIRECTION IT'S GOING TO TAKE
MANY YEARS FOR US TO GET THROUGH
THIS PROCESS.
BUT WE BELIEVE BY PUTTING THIS
POLICY FRAMEWORK IN PLACE IT'S
GOING TO ALLOW US TO CREATE ASINGLE LATTICE FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
THAT COMPENSATES PROVIDERS BASED
ON THEIR CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
AND ALLOWS THE STATE TO MAKE
WISE INVESTMENTS TOWARD
IMPROVING OUR STANDARDS OVERALL
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
IT REALLY IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
UNIFICATION IN OUR INDUSTRY
WE'VE SPENT MANY YEARS FIGHTING
WITH EACH OTHER OVER WHO GETS
WHICH PIECE OF THE PIE AND IT'S
A REAL OPPORTUNITY WE BELIEVE.
TO BE LINK ARMS AND MOVE FORWARD
AS A UNIFIED SYSTEM SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION WE
APPRECIATE SENATOR IT LEVELS
LEADERSHIP.
AND ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HI.
HEARING ABLE TO HAVE A FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA YOUR STATE
COMMISSION EARLY CHILDHOOD.
AND AS YOU JUST HEARD FOR MY
CALL FOR MY COLLEAGUE CALIFORNIA
HAS A BIFURCATED REIMBURSEMENT
RATE SYSTEM.
AND THE FIRST GRAPHIC YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU IS A VERY
SIMPLISTIC RIGHT A
REPRESENTATION OF HOW THIS ON
LINE SYSTEM.
OF RATES CURRENTLY WORKS AND
I'LL TAKE YOU THROUGH HOW WE
PLAN TO REVISE THOSE RATES AND
BRING THEM TOGETHER.
IT'S KEY TO REMEMBER THAT THE
LICENSED OR IN MARIN OR REGIONAL
MARKET RATE FUNDED PROGRAMS ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET TITLE TWENTY
TWO HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
AND THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATE PROGRAMS THE S. R. ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET ADDITIONAL
TITLE FIVE CHILD DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS THAT CARRY GREAT
INCREASED COSTS.
THE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OF
THESE ADDITIONAL TITLE FIVE
REQUIREMENTS ARE LOWER ADULT TO
CHILD RATIOS INCREASE TO STAFF
EDUCATION TRAINING FACILITY AND
OTHER CHILD ASSESSMENT
REQUIREMENTS.
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE ALSO EXIST MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE SYSTEM RELIES ON
HISTORIC SNAPSHOT APPROACH WHICH
IS ALMOST THREE YEARS OLD BEFORE
THE NEW SNAPSHOT IS AVAILABLE.
IT'S A MAJOR COST OF BUSINESS
CHANGES LIKE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES AND COST OF HEALTH
CARE NEVER REFLECTED FOR YEARS.
THE SURVEYS ALSO ALLOWED TO
CAPTURE MARKET FAILURE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IN DEEP POVERTY
COMMUNITIES CAN ONLY CHARGE WITH
THEIR MARKET WHICH IS THEIR
NEIGHBORS CAN AFFORD TO PAY.
THIS MARKET FAILURE IS AVERAGED
INTO THE SURVEY'S RESULTS.
SO AB.
SB ONE SEVEN FOUR PROPOSES A
SINGLE REGIONAL ICED
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM FOR
CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES THAT ONE
COMPENSATES ALL TEACHERS AND
PROVIDERS FOR THE TRUE COST OF
PROVIDING CARE. TO RECOGNIZE IS
THE COST OF MEETING EXISTING
VARYING QUALITY STANDARDS THE
STATE HAS PUT INTO PLACE IN
ORDER TO DRIVE CHILD OUTCOMES
AND SAFETY.
AND THREE STABILIZES THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE'S MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING OPTIONS WE ARE CALLING
IT THE CHILD CARE STABILIZATION
FORMULA.
THE SINGLE REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SERVICES WOULD HELP TO ENSURE
THAT THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
MAINTAINED AS ONE EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE SYSTEM.
SERVING VARIOUS PROGRAM MISSIONS
FUNDING ADEQUATELY TO ACHIEVE
THEIR SHARED MISSION TO
SUPPORTING WORKING PARENTS AND
THRIVING CHILDREN BUT MEETING
THE STANDARD SO THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY WE CAN LIKE
WITH THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA CREATE A FORMULA FOR
CHILD CARE.
THAT IS THE DRIVER FOR THE CHILD
AND SYSTEM OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT.
THE SECOND GRAPHIC YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS A VERY SIMPLE
DEPICTION OF SB ONE SEVENTY
FORCE CONCEPTS.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT YOU
MAKE IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE SYSTEM AND
AND MAKE IT THE BASE OF THE
SYSTEM.
AND THEN ALIGN THE ENTIRE CHILD
CARE SYSTEM TO THIS SINGLE
TIERED REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURE.
TITLE TWENTY TWO STANDARDS WOULD
EARN THE REVISED OR A MORE LEVEL
IN THEIR COUNTY WE'RE CALLING
THE BASE RATE.
AND THEN PROVIDERS MEETING
ADDITIONAL TITLE FIVE STANDARDS
WOULD EARN THEIR COUNTIES BASE
RATE WITH AN ADDITIONAL QUALITY
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR FOR THEIR
INCREASED REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT OUR
GROUP I CALCULATED THE
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR CONCEPT BASED
OFF OF THE BIGGEST COST DRIVER
BETWEEN THAT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TITLE TWENTY TO ENTITLE --
FIVE WE BELIEVE IT'S
CALCULATIONS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE PILOT
SECTION OF THIS BILL WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW TO INCENTIVIZE
HIGHER STANDARDS FOR TITLE
TWENTY TWO PROGRAMS.
THIRD GRAPHIC YOU HAVE DONE
EXPLAINS IN A VERY SIMPLE
TRAFFIC -- SO UNFORTUNATE ALL
THIS IS A SIMPLIFIED -- EXPLAINS
THE IMPLEMENTATION DESIGN EVER
PROPOSAL RATHER THAN EXPECT THE
STATE TO ABSORB THE COST OF THIS
NEW RATE SYSTEM OVER ONE YEAR WE
ARE PROPOSING LIKE THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE STATE USE THIS NEW
METHODOLOGY TO CREATE TARGETS
FOR EACH TYPE OF CONTRACT BY
COUNTY.
MEN EACH YEAR THE BUDGET ACT IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL DECIDE HOW MUCH FUNDING
GOES TOWARDS RATE INCREASES FOR
THE ENTIRE CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
AND THEN INCREASES WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY BASED OFF
OF THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHERE
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY FUNDED
AND THEIR TARGET AND THAT WOULD
BE A YEAR BY YEAR BUDGET
DECISION.
SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR WILL MAKE
THESE CRUCIAL CHANGES TO THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE DESIGN AND
CREATE THESE NEW TARGETS FOR
EACH COUNTIES FUNDING RIGHT.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
PERRY WEEDY TOPIC IN A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS ABSOLUTELY
FOUNDATIONAL NOT ONLY FOR
STABILIZING THE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ACHIEVING THE CHILD OUTCOMES WE
WANT FOR THE CHILDREN WHO WERE
IN THE SYSTEM. FOR ACHIEVING THE
VISION THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS SET
FORWARD FOR MORE AMBITIOUS
SYSTEM OF SERVICE FOR ALL
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TEAR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANKS.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER ON BEHALF
ARE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND ARE THOUSANDS OF
FAMILY CARE PROVIDERS WHERE I
REALLY PROUD BECAUSE SPONSORS
THANK YOU.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WE CAN THE CHRISTIANS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE ANGELA READ
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY SHILOH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEED A BC --
AVERAGE HOW CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF U. D. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY AS A CO
SPONSOR WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
OFFER BRING THIS BILL FORD FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEMPERATURES
REPRESENTING CHILD THREE SIXTY
LOS ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ALONG WITH
THE GRAYSON STUDENT AND HELP ARE
BEING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AND
STRONG SUPPORT IT WOULD ALSO
RECOGNITION OF THE LIFTING AND
CHILDREN FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EMILY MATHIS WITH
UT W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
HELLO LITTLE ANY I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
CASINO FOR YOU PULL BACK TO CUT
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
THE THE CHOCOLATE RESOURCE
CENTER YOU DO -- GREAT
PHENOMENAL WORK IN MY DISTRICT
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
OUR CENTER GLAZER.
YES I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FOR OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF PEOPLE WORKED ON IT FOR A
LONG TIME -- AND I KNOW THIS IS
THE FISCAL COMMITTEE OKAY SO I
GET THAT -- BY BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WITH THE COST
OF THIS OF THIS WAS IMPLEMENTED
I WILL WITH THE COST OF THIS BE.
I DON'T KNOW I WOULD SAY A LOT.
CANDIDLY THE LADY'S ISSUE YES
THANK YOU I CAN SPEAK TO THAT SO --
WE ATUALLY DEVELOPED ACOSTA
MODELING TOOL IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND NOT ONLY THE
IMPLICATION STATEWIDE BUT FOR
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES AND CONTRACT
TYPES.
AND IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING FROM
THAT THE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL I IN FRONT
OF YOU WOULD BE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION ANTS
AND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHEN IT'S AT FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE REASON FOR THE RANGE IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T FULLY KNOW WITH
THE CHANGES TO THE ARE MORE
SURVEY WOULD BE UNTIL THEY'RE
DONE?
SO THAT'S OUR ESTIMATE RAIN
CHECK AND PART OF THE REASON
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS OVER
A MULTIPLE YEAR TRAJECTORY IS
THERE ARE CHANGES THAT HAVE TO
BE MADE TO THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATE SURVEY. TO ALLOW THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION SO THIS GIVES THE
STATE THE FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
THOSE FISCAL DECISIONS AS
REVENUES ALLOW.
OKAY AT BECAUSE THE REASON I
ASKED THAT IS THATLOOK IF THE
QUESTION WAS SHOULD WE ADD YOU
KNOW A HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
CHILDCARE SLOTS SHOULD WE PAY
EVERYBODY MORE.
IS THAT OF COURSE THE ANSWER
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT THING.
THAT -- THAT WE CAN HELP WITH --
BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE THESE CHOICES
WITHIN OUR BUDGET RIGHT AND I
THINK THAT THE PART OF THIS THAT.
I GUESS PAS GIVES ME PAUSE IS
NOT REALLY THE RIGHT WORD JUST
THAT IS TRYING TO BRING IT TO IS
THE GROUND THIS IS THAT.
WE'RE MAKING POLICY CHOICES HERE
THAT.
I I GUESS I DON'T UNDERSTAND OR
THEY OUGHT DO THEY CREATE THIS
AUTOMATIC YOU KNOW IT THE
QUESTION TO THAT YOU'RE NOT
PUTTING BEFORE US WOULD USE
WORDS LIKE UNIFICATION IT ON A
LINE.
THOSE ARE THOSE FOR ME AND
THEY'RE TOUGH TO KIND OF
UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE SAYING WE
WANT TO PROVIDE RAISES. TO MORE
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATE I GET THAT
OKAY I GET THAT THAT'S CLEAR AND
THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS THIS
PRESENTATION A LITTLE CONFUSING
TO ME HONESTLY IS THAT I I DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THESE
TERMS MEAN.
IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT ONLY PAY
SOMEBODY IN FRESNO DIFFERENTLY
OR THE SAME AS SOMEONE LOS
ANGELES THAT'S UNFAIR TO PEOPLE
IN LOS ANGELES IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OKAY I I
GET THAT.
AND YOU CAN WE WANT TO
INCORPORATE THE COST OF LIVING
IN THAT CITY THAT THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THAT'S CLEAR TO ME
OKAY -- BUT I I AM FINDING THIS
A LITTLE HARD TO GET MY MY HEAD
AROUND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT AN ISSUE A
PHILOSOPHICALLY ALIGNED WITH
WHAT YOU WANT.
MORE SLOTS BETTER PAY.
YOU KNOW -- A SENSITIVITY TO THE
MARKET PLACE AND WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING AYE AYE.
THAT'S THAT'S EASY FOR ME BUT
I'M JUST SHARING THAT BECAUSE IT
IT'S A GREAT POINT CENTER GLAZER
AND I THINK THE EXAMPLES THAT
YOU JUST GAVE GAVE ME SOMETHING
TO WORK ON IF THIS BILL GETS OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE ON THE NEXT
COMMITTEE HITS -- I THINK PART
MAYBE THIS WILL BE HELPFUL TO
YOU HAVE THE RMR RATE WHICH IS
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE S. AS THE S.
R. OUR RATE THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
AND THEY'RE DONE DIFFERENTLY SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THIS
BILL AND PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG IS WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO BOTH OF
THOSE REIMBURSEMENT RATES THE
SAME WAY.
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
THE SAME FOR TO SAN FRANCISCO
SAN MARINO VERSUS ANOTHER PART
OF THE COUNTRY IT IS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RATES ARE
MORE UNIFORM.
AND MORE ALIGNED SO THE PEOPLE
ARE BEING PAID THE SAME ORDER
THE SAME WITHIN THEIR AREA AND
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT MORE
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CHILD CARE.
RAY AND AND IT'S THAT THAT THOSE
EXAMPLES THAT I THINK ARE.
A JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD ABOUT THIS
SUBJECT OPENING UP MORE SLOTS
OKAY THEN THEN WE SHOULD SAY
THAT AND IF WERE. FIVE WE WANT
TO PAY THEM MORE I GET THAT THEN
WE SHOULD SAY THAT AND IF IT'S
ABOUT -- BE MORE FAIR IN OUR IN
EQUITY OF HOW WE PAY GET THAT
FAIRNESS AND HOW IT AT OKAY WELL
THEN LET'S OWN UP TO THAT TOO
RIGHT IT'S ABOUT ALL OF THAT
OKAY.
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY BUT I DO THINK THAT
IF WE WERE. TO REALLY HAVE A
GROUNDED CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
WERE WE I THINK IT JUST NEEDS TO
BE CLEAR I HOPE YOU CAN WORK ON
THAT ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE ALL
THE GREAT WORK -- SUSTENANCE I
HAVE BY FIRST ALL THE GREAT WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
WELL CAN BILLS BEEN MOVED NO
OTHER COMMENTS.
KING C. NINE SENATOR LEAVING ME
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK.
ITEM FIVE SB ONE SEVEN FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE WILK AYE WILK I CHANGED TO
WRESTLE GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN
[inaudible]
CAN I I LIKE IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE BILL GETS UP A REALLY NON
CALL BECAUSE I'M SURE OUR
COLLEAGUES WILL WHEN ADD ON
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
.
RICHARD YOU'VE BROUGHT FRIENDS.
SENATOR ALLEN WELCOME.
WE'VE HAD A BUSY MORNING HERE IN
THE SENATE EDUCATION ORDERED.
YES -- TO PRESENT ITEM FOR SB
ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
I THINK MANAGER MEMBERS SIR SB
ONE FIFTY EIGHT A SIMPLE CODE
CLEANUP BILL THE REPEALS AN
OBSOLETE EDUCATION CODE SECTION
RELATED.
TO PEOPLE ASSESSMENTS THAT IS NO
LONGER OPERATIVE.
I RESPECT YES HAVE A WELL DONE
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING HEARING THAT'LL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER PAN
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
EXCUSE ME WE HAVE A QUESTION
SENATOR WILK SO CENTER ALLEN
I'VE HEARD A RUMOR IN THE
CAPITAL THE THIS BILL IS NOT
WHAT IT APPEARS TO BE IN THAT
YOU'RE GONNA GOTTEN A MAN ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE SO I WAS JUST.
POINTED OUT SAT [inaudible]
SO.
WELL THIS IS THE REMAINS TO BE
SEEN TO BE HONEST WITH YOU --
AND AS THE ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON A QUITE A BIT HAS
BEEN IN THE AREA OF SPECIAL ED
FIND -- FINANCING.
AND WERE WE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT SOME
SORT OF WORKABLE THING UNITES
SERVED ON THE COMMITTEE WHEN WE
I HAD THE BIG HEARING ON SPECIAL
FINANCE I WILL BE ATTENDING THE
SPECIAL FINANCE HEARING OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
TOMORROW I WHICH I THINK
EVERYONE OUGHT TO TAKE A LONG
HARD LOOK AT SO THAT SO WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING TO COME UP WITH
A WINNING FORMULA -- ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT WE DIG EXAMINE
LAST YEAR [inaudible]
IF THAT.
YOU DIDN'T SEE THAT I WAS THAT'S
PART OF MY CONTEMPLATION -- I
DID I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WE'LL GET THERE NOT IN WHICH
CASE WILL CLEAN UP THIS SECTION
A CODE -- I'M I'M FINE WITH THAT
I MEAN.
SO THOSE I KNOW THIS IS A GREAT
HONEST ANSWER WE OBVIOUSLY THAT
IT'S A IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE OUR
SCHOOLS FIRST OF ALL WE SHOULD
HAVE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FULLY FIND I. D. E. A..
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO FUND 40%
RIGHT NOW SALUTE A TAKE OVER 10%
SO THERE'S FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
GETTING -- BUT THERE ARE
INEQUITIES THERE IS SOME SUPPORT
OF THAT SO THE RUMOR HEARD WAS
TRUE SO THAT'S INTERESTING BUT
IT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY TRUE
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WILL WRITER -- BUT TENSION LEAD
BUT BUT IF WE DO COME BACK WITH.
A SUBSTANTIVE BILL IN THIS AREA
THIS COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A FULL
AND ROBUST HEARING -- OTHERWISE
YOU PROBABLY WILL NEVER SEE IT
AGAIN HAS GONE CONSENT AND WE'LL
JUST RIGHT FIX THE SECTION
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN RIGHT.
AND OF ON OUR RADAR SCREEN FOR
SEVERAL YEARS HI I APPRECIATE I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER THANK.
TO THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR ALAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I DO APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
THAT QUESTIONING FROM THEM MY MY
FRIEND THE VICE CHAIR -- AND
ONCE AGAIN SHOT OUT TO THE
WONDERFUL I SENATE STAFF AND
TEAM.
AND WITH RESPECT FASTER HAVE A
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOR SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE WILK WILK AYE
CHANGE TO WRESTLE.
GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALLEN ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT.
THAT WAS OUR LAST BILL THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IN THIS ROOM
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING -- TO
TWENTY FORTY PRIOR TO THAT WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT CALLS SO MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD DO THAT
BUT YOU KNOW BEFORE THAT SHE
WOULD DO THE FIRST CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WAS TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ARE THERE ANY ITEMS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM SIX SB
THREE TWENTY ONE ITEM NINE SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE ITEM ELEVEN
SB SIX THIRTY FOUR WHICH MAKES
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MOVED THANK
YOU CENTER WORK MADE THE MOTION
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE WELL HI WILK
I CHANGED TO WRESTLE GLAZER.
PLEASE THEIR AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE. FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL WE WILL LIVE
CALLS.
BUT THE CALL ON THE BILLS THAT
WE'VE HEARD SO FAR [inaudible]
BRUCE.
YES I DO.
WE WILL LIVE CALLS AND THEN WE
WILL THREE START EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SENATE AT ONE THIRTY
AND TWENTY FORTY ALRIGHT LET'S
START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
PLEASE.
ITEM ONE SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE HASN'T VOTED
THREE ONE WILK NO WILK NO.
CHIANG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
I BELIEVE THE BILL ON CALL.
ITEM TEN SENATOR UMBERG.
I AM TEN SB THREE NINETY THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
THREE ZERO CHIANG.
LASSELL MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WELL.
FILE ITEM TO LEYVA PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM TO SB TWENTY FOR THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO TWO ONE CHIANG.
TO WRESTLE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BELONG CALL AS
WELL.
THAT'S ALL WE ALSO WE HAVE WE
WILL STAND ADJOURNED UNTIL ONE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME.
WE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL ONE
THIRTY AND WE WILL REMAIN IN
ROOM
THEY ARE OKAY THERE WE GO --
PART BECAUSE PUSHING THE WRONG
ONE SHOCKED AT HOW THAT WORKS.
ARE GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK
TO SENATE EDUCATION WE WERE IN
RECESS WE ARE NOW UNDER RECESSED.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH US
SENATOR GALGIANI SENATOR
GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
WITH SB.
SEVEN FIFTEEN YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS YOU ARE
LUCKY. SEVEN FIFTEEN WOULD
PROHIBIT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FROM ENTERING INTO A
CONTRACT FOR SERVICES WITH AN
ASSET MANAGER. FOR A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN IF THAT PLAN
IS A STANDALONE OPTION AND IS
NOT A COMPLIMENT IN ADDITION TO
A DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL IS
SPECIFIC THAT THIS PROHIBITION
DOES NOT APPLY TO DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN AS LONG AS
THAT PLAN IS OFFERED AS A
COMPLIMENT. TO A DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION PLAN WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE BILL'S
SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I MADAM CHAIR AND HONORED
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY HEINZ
STRIKE FOR A DC W. A LOCAL.
NINETY ONE NINETEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN AND
UC PRESIDENT JANET APPALL
TONNEAU CAN BE IN THE COMMITTEE
OF TO TO RESOLVE A DISPUTE
BETWEEN THEM REGARDING THE
AMOUNT OF STATE FUNDING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WOULD
RECEIVE.
THE RESULT WAS THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN PROMISED TO INCREASE STATE
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN EXCHANGE FOR YOU
SEE ACCEPTING THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE PENSION REFORM ACT
TERMS AND CONDITIONS.
INCLUDING THE CAP ON PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION THE UNIVERSITY
PLACATED AT HIGHER INCOME
EARNERS BY CREATING A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN FOR
COMPENSATION OVER THE CAP.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN YOU SEE
DECIDED TO EXTEND THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN THAT HAD BEEN
CREATED ONLY TO MAKE UP FOR THE
LOST PENSIONABLE BENEFITS ABOVE
THE PEPPER CAP.
EXTENDED THAT DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PENSION PLAN AS AN
OPTION TO NEW EMPLOYEES FOR
THEIR TOTAL COMPENSATION.
THE OPTION FOR NEWER EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYEES TO DECLINE PAYING INTO
THE DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
UNDERMINES THE ACTUARIAL
STABILITY OF THE PENSION AND
THEREBY ULTIMATELY IS POOR
PUBLIC POLICY WE WOULD NOT ALLOW
CALPERS OR CAL STAR IS TO BE
UNDERMINED IN THIS WAY.
SB SEVEN FIFTEEN WOULD AMEND
PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE TO STATE
THAT YOU SEE YOU SEE SHALL NOT
ENTER INTO A PUBLIC SERVICE
CONTRACT WITH AN ASSET MANAGER
FOR A DEFINED COTRIBUTION PLAN
LET UNLESS THAT DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
IS A COMPLIMENT TO THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION AND IT'S NOT A
STANDALONE OPTION.
WE HAVE WORKED ON THIS BILL
SINCE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND ONE
IT WILL NO LONGER BE RETROACTIVE
AND TWO IT WILL EXEMPTS THE
STANDALONE DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PLAN THAT EXISTED BEFORE TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR EMPLOYEES WHO WORK
LESS THAN 50%.
KNOWN AS THE SAFE HARBOR PLAN WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
YES.
I'M JOHN RENDON VICE PRESIDENT
FOR LEGISLATION OF THE U. C. F.
T. THE UNION REPRESENTS
LIBRARIANS AND LECTURES AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M ALSO LECTURING CLASSICS
AT UC DAVIS I SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN FIFTEEN I'M IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS WITH SOME SUCCESS YOU
SEE ADMINISTRATORS HAVE BEEN
OFFERING ALL NEW EMPLOYEES A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO ITS TRADITIONAL
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN. ONE MIGHT
ARGUE WHETHER OR NOT YOU SEE
ADMINISTRATORS BENEFIT THEIR
INTENDED BENEFICIARIES NAMELY
THEIR HIGHEST WAGE OR HIGHEST
WHICH EMPLOYEES WITH THE NEW
PLAN.
HOWEVER WHEN THEY OFFERED AS AN
OPTION TO FOR ALL YOU SEE
WORKERS THEY DO HARM.
THE SHIFT THE RISKS OF
RETIREMENT ONTO INDIVIDUALS
WHILE THE ALLOW RETIREMENT MONEY
TO BE SIPHONED OFF TO WELL
CONNECTED PROFESSIONAL MONEY
MANAGERS.
MOREOVER THE JUDICIAL PENSION
PLAN ON PURPOSE ENCOURAGES
EMPLOYEE RETENTION AND
DEVELOPMENT WITH THIS NEW PLAN
YOU WOULD MEAN YOU SEE
ADMINISTERS FOSTER THE WORST
ASPECTS OF THE CURRENT ECONOMY.
WE'RE AND STRESSED OUT WORKERS
MUST PERPETUAL BE LOOKING FOR
NEW JOBS ELSEWHERE AND EMPLOYEE
DEVELOPMENT IS OUTSOURCED.
FINALLY YOU SEE MINISTRIES WE
CAN THE OLD PLANTS ACTUARIAL
PROFILE BY HURTING PEOPLE INTO
THE NEW PLAN.
AT NEW EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS THE
POWERFUL FINANCIAL FROM FIDELITY
WHICH HAS A CLEAR CONFLICT OF
INTEREST HERE SINCE IT MANAGES
THE MONEY IN THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION ACCOUNTS.
NOW PRESENTS RETIREMENT OPTIONS
I PERSONALLY KNOW ONE PERSON WHO
FEELS TO SEE BY THE PRESENTATION.
SHE REGRETS THAT SHE WAS
CONVINCED TO GO FOR THE NEW
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN BUT AT
LEAST FOR NOW ONCE THE CHOICES
MADE IT IS A RADICAL.
ON BEHALF OF YOU SEE IF.
WHO SOVEREIGN DEMOCRATIC
ADVISORY BODY IT'S COUNCIL WOULD
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
IRISH PASSAGE OF SET OF SENATE
BILL?
SEVEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER WITNESSE IN SUPPORT
MANAGER MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROP CO SPONSORS
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WALKING CHAVEZ VICE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THE CW A NINETY ONE
NINETEEN REPRESENTING SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND UC WORKERS AND WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS SINCE -- I'LL JUST
HAVE THE CW A WORKERS THAT ARE
HERE JUST STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN ONE FIVE SO WE DON'T HAVE.
TO DON'T WE APPRECIATE YOU THANK
YOU.
WE RECOGNIZE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO SHOW SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
COME FORWARD.
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
JUST KIDDING.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA --
THE FIRST THEY MUST RISE TODAY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
OPPOSITION -- IS BASED ON THREE
PRIMARY PRINCIPLES -- THE FIRST
BEING THAT SB SEVEN ONE FIVE
WOULD -- INTERFERE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MANAGE OUR
RETIREMENT FUNDS IN THE WAY WE
SEE IS A FIT AND APPROPRIATE WE
DO THINK THAT -- THERE WILL BE --
TANGIBLE HARM BECAUSE TO
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE DB PROGRAM.
I'M SORRY THE DC PROGRAM IF WE
WERE TO HAVE TO UNWIND I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR SOME MORE ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ACCEPTED BY
THE AUTHOR.
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE TIMING OF
THOSE -- AMENDMENTS IN TERMS OF
BACKING OUT OF BUT AT THE AT THE
MOMENT WE DO BELIEVE THERE WILL
BE HARM TO EMPLOYEES.
SECONDLY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE DC PLAN IS A
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATE
PLANNED OFFERED TO OUR EMPLOYEES
PROSPECTIVELY -- THERE'S BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION THAT THERE'S
BEEN A THUMB ON THE SCALE MADE
SO TO SPEAK BY THE UNIVERSITY IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO BRING FOLKS
ON BOARD.
WE WOULD STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH
THOSE ASSERTIONS -- THE AMOUNT
THAT IS -- REQUIRED OF THE
EMPLOYEE'S IN TERMS OF
CONTRIBUTIONS THE PLAN IS THE
SAME.
BETWEEN THE DC IN THE IN THE
CURRENT TV PLAN -- THE EMPLOYEE
SUED DON'T MAKE A CHOICE OR
DON'T MAKE ELECTION THE POND --
COMPLY WITH THE UNIVERSITY ARE
DEFAULTED INTO THE DB PLAN WHICH
IS HAT YOU WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
KNOW MOST FOLKS TO BE ABLE -- TO
AND THE UNIVERSITY HAS PROPOSED
TO THE IRS THAT OPTION FOR THERE
TO BE AN OFFICE BACK IN. TO THE
TV PLAN AHEAD OF TIME AT A POINT
THE FUTURE WE'VE NOT RECEIVED OF
FORMAL APPROVAL FOR THAT --
OFTEN YET BUT WE DO EXPECT TO BE
FORTH COMING VERY SOON SO THERE
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE THAT.
AB SAID.
MADE ELECTION THAT THEY THEY
RETHOUGHT LATER ON TO TO MAKE A
CHOICE -- IN TERMS OF ANY
STEERING AGAIN FOR THE STEERING
OF FOLKS INTO A CERTAIN PLAN
VERSUS ANOTHER I SEE THE
UNIVERSITY DOES OVERSEE AND
REVIEW THE SCRIPTS SO TO SPEAK.
THAT -- FIDELITY USES TO WORK
WITH EMPLOYEES WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY ARE ALWAYS NEUTRAL IF --
YOU WANNA LOOK AT OUR WEBSITE
AND NOTICED THAT WE AGAIN
ADEQUATELY EXPLAIN BOTH OPTIONS
AND DESCRIBED IN A NEUTRAL
FASHION.
THIS COMMITTEE BE WELCOME TO DO
SO -- IN ADDITION WITH REGARD TO
AGAIN OUR OUR VIEW THAT THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYEES WE NOTE THAT --
LOOKING AT PAST SEPARATION DATA
FOR SOME OF OUR LOWER WAGE
WORKERS WE SEE THAT THE AFTER A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD TIME ARE --
SEPARATION DATA IS SOMETIMES IN
THE RANGE OF OF THE HIGH THIRTY
NINE TO LOW 40% OR HIGHER.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE GOT IS FOLKS
WHO PERHAPS MAY NOT INTEND TO BE
OF THE UNIVERSITY.
FOR THE ENTIRE THEIR CAREERS AND
IN THAT CASE THE DC PLAN
ACTUALLY BENEFITS THEM.
IT BENEFITS THEM BECAUSE IF THEY
CHOOSE THE DP.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE IN IN --
UNIVERSE IMPLEMENT FOR FIVE
YEARS THE VAST UNDER THE DC PLAN
THEY CAN TAKE THE UNIVERSITY
CONTRIBUTIONS AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH THEM.
AFTER JUST ONE YEAR.
AND THEN LASTLY -- WE WOULD
AGAIN ARGUE THAT -- FOR
OPPOSITION TO SOMEONE FIVE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THESE ISSUES
SHOULD BE RESOLVED AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE.
THE FACT IS THAT -- HIM SEVERAL
UNIONS HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE THIS THIS PLAN
OFFERING AS WELL AS A FEW
EXPRESS CONCERNS ABOUT WAGES
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS AND
CONTRACTED OUT SO THOSE ARE ALL
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON AT THE
PARTY WERE NOW WE BELIEVE THAT
SUPER PLACE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU IS
OUR NATIONAL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR WILK HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS -- CHIANG ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
SENATOR GALGIANI -- I AM A HUGE
PROPONENT THE DEFINED BENEFIT
PLANS -- DC PLANS A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION.
THEY MAY BE THE SAME --
CONTRIBUTION FOR BALL BUT WHAT
MAKES A DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN SO
MUCH BETTER IS WHEN YOU POOL ALL
OF THAT MONEY THEN THE RISK IS
NOT ON THE WORKER OR ON THE
EMPLOYEE.
EVERYONE ABSORBS A LITTLE OF
THAT SO IN MY PERSONAL OPINION I
THINK WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PRESERVE.
OUR DEFINED BENEFIT PLANS I
THINK THIS BILL GOES A LONG WAY
IN DOING THAT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK YOU DID AN EXCELLENT.
FOR ME.
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE WELCOME DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
WOULD YOU DO A COURTESY MOTION.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT -- MISTER VICE
CHAIR OF COURTESY MOTION BY THE
VICE CHAIR SENATOR WILK MA'AM
SECTOR THIS CALL THE ROLL ITEM
TWELVE ITEM TWELVE SB SEVEN ONE
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR LEYVA HI.
I WILL.
WILK NO CHANGE.
TANGO LASSELL GLAZER OF CHOIR
AND WE BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU WANT TO
PRESENT YOUR NEXT BILL CENTER
GALGIANI YES PLEASE ALL RIGHT SB.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN PERCEIVE WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SB.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WHAT
ESTABLISH THE STUDENT HOUSING
AND FOOD HARDSHIP PLAN TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
UNDER THIS PROGRAM LEFTOVER
MONEY DEPOSITED IN THE GENERAL
FUND BY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS
ATTENDING A PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTION.
OR EXPERIENCING HOUSING OR FOOD
HARDSHIPS TO APPLY FOR EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE.
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURITY IS
A PERSISTENT PROBLEM AND
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
OVER 50% OF CSU STUDENTS FACE
HUNGER OR HOUSING AND SECURITY
AND 11% OF USE OF CSU STUDENTS
HAVE FACED HOMELESSNESS AND THE
LAST YEAR.
ANY SURVEY OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS NEARLY 60% OF THE
STUDENTS HAVE DIFFICULTY MEETING
THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
EACH WEEK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HELP ALLEVIATE THESE NEEDS SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN FOCUS ON THEIR
SCHOOLING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER WILK THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
CLEARLY THERE THERE'S FOOD AND
SECURITY -- I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE THAT.
SO I'M CURIOUS.
WHERE THE NEXUS IS BETWEEN THESE
FUNDS AND THE PROGRAMMING AND
THEN HOW MUCH MONEY TYPICALLY
WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN A?
ON AN AVERAGE YEAR DO YOU NOW I
DON'T KNOW THAT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT PER YEAR BUT IT IT
ACTUATE SAN.
SIMEON DOES.
AND AND TO DATE WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS THOSE EXTRA DOLLARS
AND JUST GOING INTO THE GENERAL
FUND SO INSTEAD OF THEM POINT OF
GENERAL FUND WERE SAYING TO PUT
THAT INTO THE SPINE.
AND THEN WE'RE LEAVING IT UP TO
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
ON HOW TO DEFINE WHAT A HARDSHIP
IS IN WITH THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WOULD BE AND HOW MUCH
THAT.
POOL OF MONEY WOULD BE SO THAT
THEY WILL BE NIMBLE ENOUGH.
TO AND ADAPT AND MAKE AVAILABLE
MONIES THAT.
ARE DIRECTLY IS SOCIALLY WITH
WHAT'S ACTUALLY BEING.
DIRECTED INTO THE AT A LATER
DATE COULD YOUR STAFF GET BACK
TO MY STAFF WITH.
LIKE WHAT ME IT'S BEEN IN PAST
YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY SO I HAVE AN IDEA AND
I'M CONCERNED.
ABOUT I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WORKCENTRE
TRAINING COURSE OF VERY GOOD.
WE ARE TO CLOSER ABOUT JOHNNY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU EITHER
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF BILLS THE
MOVE BY SENATOR WELCOME MADAM
SECRETARY THIS CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
CHIANG CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RAZOR
WIRE AND COOLEY THAT BELONG CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I SEE SENATOR CABALLERO COMMA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE SENATOR PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB.
THREE SEVENTY ONE MEASURE THAT
ADDRESSES THE ALARMING NUMBER OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN STRUCK BY
VEHICLES WHILE GOING TO AND FROM
THEIR SCHOOL BUS.
DURING EVERY SCHOOL DAY IN
CALIFORNIA SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN RIGHT A SCHOOL BUS TO
AND FROM SCHOOL.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF PEOPLE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES THERE ARE TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD NOR THE STATE SCHOOL BUS
STOP LAW.
AS A SPEED BY SCHOOL BUSES AS
CHILDREN APPROACH -- EXIT.
THIS BILL WOULD AMEND THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE TO
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
OPTION.
THE OPTION TO INCORPORATE SCHOOL
BUS STOP LAW VIDEO TECHNOLOGY.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT STOP VIOLATORS.
SB THREE SEVENTY ONE CONTAINS
PRIVACY JUDICIAL PROCESS SIGNAGE
REQUIREMENTS AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
VIDEO TECHNOLOGY CAN BE UTILIZED.
THIS BILL ALSO PROTECTS SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS AS WELL AS SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES FROM ANY INCREASED
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY DEPLOYED ON THE BASS.
THEY ARE DRIVING THESE PRACTICES
ARE TAKEN FROM SIXTEEN OTHER
STATES WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY IN
IMPLEMENTED THIS VIDEO
TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TRAFFIC SAFETY
LAWS IN PLACE FOR THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN THE LAW REQUIRES
DRIVERS TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE
FLASHING RED LIGHTS.
AND THE STOP ARM ON THE SCHOOL
BUSES.
DRIVERS BY LAW ARE REQUIRED TO
STOP BEHIND THE SCHOOL BUS WHEN
DRIVING IN THE SAME DIRECTION AS
A BASS.
AND BEFORE A BUS WHEN DRIVING IN
AN OPT OPPOSITE DIRECTION THE
FACT THAT CHILDREN TODAY
CONTINUE TO BE STRUCK BY DRIVERS
WHO DO NOT FOLLOW THE LAW
INDICATES MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES SCHOOL
DISTRICT WITH ANOTHER TO ALL TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN SAFETY BOTH
INSIDE THE SCHOOL AND ITS
VICINITY.
THIS PUTS CHILDREN SAFETY FIRST
AYE AYE I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY AND THERE
ARE THIS THIS BILL WAS TROUBLE
REFERRED.
ALL.
RIGHT NOW I CAN MEET.
AND SO THERE WERE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT -- THAT WERE --
TAKEN IN TRANSPORTATION AND
JUDICIARY AND THEIR I THINK THAT
YOU SHOULD HAVE A COPY OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- MY APOLOGY ON IT
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT WAS ON
WAS BASICALLY TO MINIMIZE.
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TRY TO MAKE MONEY
OFF OF THIS THIS IS IT THAT'S
NOT WHAT IT'S IT'S SO AND NUMBER
TWO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT REVIEW
BEFORE ISSUING A CITATION IN
OTHER WORDS IT GOES.
TO IT'S A LAW ENFORCEMENT
CITATION IT'S NOT ISSUED BY THE
SCHOOL.
ON AND AND THE THE AT THE FISCAL
INCENTIVE WAS THAT THE CONTRACT
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE MANUFACTURER SUPPLIER CAN'T
INCLUDE AS VISION WHERE THEY GET
COMPENSATION BASED ON THAT IT'S
JUST THE PURCHASE OF THE
EQUIPMENT AND THAT'S IT.
KATHY BRING IN CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY
AND HEALTH AND AND ON YOUR POINT
SENATOR.
ARE WE ALSO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
FEES.
THAT CAN BE CHARGED IF YOU'RE
STOPPED BY A POLICE OFFICER
BETWEEN YOUR FINE AND YOUR COURT
FEES AND OTHER THINGS IS GOING
TO BE ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
ARE WE CONTEMPLATE A FEE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
ACTUALLY.
NOTHING FOR THE FIRST NINETY
DAYS SO THAT PEOPLE ARE
INSTRUCTED THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
VIOLATE THIS LAW.
AFTER THAT YOUR FIRST VIOLATIONS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS YOUR
SECOND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THREE TIMES YOUR STRIKE IS OUT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE SAME
KIND OF FEE THAT YOU'RE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WOULD GIVE
YOU.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FAIR WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
STOP.
I'M SURE YOU'VE ALL SEEN THIS IS
NOT AN UNUSUAL THING YOU STOP
BECAUSE YOU SEE THE FLASHING
LIGHTS THE STOPS ARM AND YOU
STOP WELL WE WERE KIND ENOUGH
NOT TO SEND YOU THE VIDEOS OF
WHAT HAPPENS IN OTHER STATES WHO
HAVE CAPTURED WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN THEY DON'T STOP? ONE FAMILY
AND I FORGET I FORGET THE STATE
I'M SORRY STEVE WILL KNOW OP
THREE SIBLINGS.
CUT DOWN IN A CROSSWALK BECAUSE
NOBODY STOPPED DESPITE THE ARM
AND THE FLASHING LIGHTS.
SO THIS IS THIS IS A BILL THAT
SAVES LIVES AND THAT'S WHAT OUR
COALITION LOOKS OUT WE WANT.
TO REDUCE WHAT IS NOW THE NUMBER
ONE KILLER OF CHILDREN WHICH IS
NON INTENTIONAL INJURIES.
AND REDUCE THAT SO THAT IT'S NO
LONGER THE THE FATE THE FATAL
OUTCOME THAT WE SEE.
ALSO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS THE THE SCHOOL BUS
DRIVERS.
THANK GOODNESS FOR YOU BECAUSE
YOU DO SUCH AN AMAZING JOB.
THEY ACTUALLY GO OUT THERE FIRST
WITH THE STOP SIGN RIGHT TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRAFFIC
STOPPED.
BUT YOU'VE ONLY GOT A SIGN.
YES THAT'S CORRECT CENTER
[inaudible]
FOR SORRY.
SENATOR PER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION THAT IS CORRECT OUR
MEMBERS TO HELP -- CROSS
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STREET A
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVEN ONE BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
OUR SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS TO SAFELY
TRANSPORT THE STUDENTS FROM THE
STOP ACROSS THE STREET.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YEAH I'M MY NAME IS
STEVE BARROW AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY KATHY BREAKAGE WE GOT
TO INTRODUCE OURSELVES. TO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN SAFETY
AND HEALTH I'M HERE IS THE CO
CHAIR OF THE STATE'S
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY PREVENTION
STRATEGIC PLAN PROJECT WE'RE
LOOKING AT EVERYTHING FROM
DROWNING SUFFOCATION.
TRAFFIC GETS INCIDENTS TO GET
THOSE NUMBERS DOWN SOMETIMES
IT'S A LOST MOST THE TIME
WORKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TRYING TO HELP LOCAL -- PARENTS
AND STUFF LEARN HOW TO DO THIS
SO I'M JUST HERE TO TO SAY I TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS --
AND JUST TO REMIND YOU THIS
HAPPENS THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION TIMES IN OUR STATE THERE
ARE PEOPLE THESE ARE NOT CARS
JUST CREEPING BY A SCHOOL BUS OR
DRIVING FULL SPEED.
AND IF WE COULD SHOW YOU THE
VIDEOS OF WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR
CHILDREN NOT THE ONES WHERE THEY
GET HERE BUT THE ONES WHERE
THEIR CHILDREN ARE WAITING AND
WATCHING THE CARS ZOOM IN FRONT
OF THEM.
YOU'RE KINDA GET IT BUT THERE
ARE THOSE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
KIDS GO THROUGH EVERY DAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT I'M I'M I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT MY BOARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
COME FORWARD PLEASE.
YOU CAN MAKE SOME ROOM FOR HER
AT THE TABLE PLEASE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA -- I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON OUR CONCERNS -- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
PROCESS -- THAT SAID TO SOME OF
OUR SPECIFIC CONCERNS REMAIN TO
BE ADDRESSED AND I I WANTED TO
MAKE NOTE OF THOSE -- OUR
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL ARE TWO
FOLD -- FIRST WE HAVE PRIVACY
CONCERNS -- AS TO WHAT THE RULES
WILL BE FOR SHARING USE AND
RETENTION OF OF THE THE
RECORDINGS THAT THAT ARE MADE BY
THE SCHOOL BUS CAMERAS -- SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED -- BY THE AMENDMENTS --
SOME HAVE YET TO BE ADDRESSED --
CAN WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT -- THE
TICKETS COULD HAVE PARTICULARLY
ON ON LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS --
TO GO BACK TO THE SAFETY
CONCERNS FOR A MINUTE -- WE
SPECIFICALLY ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE USE OF
AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE METER
TECHNOLOGY -- WHICH CAN BE USED
TO COMPILE DATABASES OF
INFORMATION CAPTURED BY SCHOOL
BUS CAMERAS THAT THEN CAN BE
USED TO TRACK THE LOCATIONS OF
VEHICLES AND PEOPLE ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE VEHICLES -- NOR DOES
THE BILL INCLUDE SPECIFIC
PROHIBITIONS ON THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
FROM SHARING THE INFORMATION
THAT IS COLLECTED ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE POLITICIANS ON THE VENDORS
OF THE EQUIPMENT SORRY I'M
SHARING THAT.
MEANT [inaudible]
THAT DATA -- FINALLY -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE DANGERS OF
COLLECTING THE DATA ARE
HEIGHTENED BY THE LONG RETENTION
PERIOD AND I NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO
SHORTEN.
FROM CURRENT NINETY DAYS TO
THIRTY DAYS WE BELIEVE THAT
DON'T STILL.
LONGER THAN IS NECESSITATED BY
THE USE FOR WHICH THE VIDEO WILL
BE PUT -- IT'S OR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT FORTUNATELY THERE
THERE ARE NOT VERY MANY
INCIDENTS OF INJURIES TO SCHOOL
CHILDREN FROM -- HAILING FROM
VEHICLES THAT HELL TO STOP
BEHIND SCHOOL BUSES -- AND WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT THE
PROTECTION LOOKING FOR THE
DANGERS.
PRIVACY RESULTING FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY OUTWEIGHED ANY
POTENTIAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
ALL RIGHT THERE THE MICROPHONE.
I'M HERE JUST MY MY OWN THEN
FIND.
I'M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL CATIONS LUCKY FOR MY
COMMITTEE ARE LOWER INCOME AND I
ALSO LOVE SUFFER WORRIED BUT IF
THESE TWO BECAUSE IN MANY CASES
PEOPLE FROM MY COMMUNITY ALL.
DON'T TRUST THE POLICE.
YES THERE ARE SOME BAD APPLES IS
NOT YOUR SOME GOOD ONES SENT.
OVER IN FREEZER VIEWS
HISTORICALLY THE THE LAW FOR THE
HAS BEEN KIND OF ALL RIGHT THERE
WITH THE BOND ORDER.
IS NOT EQUAL FOR A BURKE UPPER
CLASS COMMUNITIES AND THIS HOPE
YOU CAN BOMB.
WHAT AGAINST THIS SORT OF MANY
MISSILES SOME?
LAKE ACLU'S MORE RIGHT ON THE
SPOT AND DOES REALLY ON WAS A
TIME GONE FORTH MAYES THIS IS A
REPRESENT EVERYONE EQUALLY --
THIS WILL BE CONSIDERED.
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSER CABALLERO.
SKEWS ME CENTER DRAWS A YES.
YEAH I JUST WANNA ALSO NOTE --
PERCENT OF VIOLENT WHO --
ADDRESS THESE -- THESE ISSUES AS
WE MOVE FORWARD HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE MORE CHANGES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN MADE.
SENATE HAVE AIR WHICH I IT IS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTO
JUDICIARY SO THAT'S WHERE THE
SECOND ON YOUR THREE STOP TO OUR
RIGHT.
RIGHT OKAY SO BUT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE AND I APOLOGIZE I
HAVE TO STEP OUT GOOD EQ BUT
SENATOR WILL WILL IS CHEERING
FOR ME.
VERY MUCH WELL I THE THE THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE --
THIS IS THE USE OF THAT
TECHNOLOGY -- TO HELP.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IF IF IF IN FACT
I'M A POLICE OFFICER SEE SOMEONE
DO THIS THE FINE IS GOING TO BE
AT A WHOLE HECK OF A LOT MORE.
ON IT AND AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS REALLY IS TO GET COMPLIANCE
WE WANT PARENTS TO STOP BEHIND
BUSES WE DON'T WANT THEM --
BLOWING THROUGH AND SO I'M WE WE
TAKE THE THE CONCERNS THAT THE
ACLU HAVE.
HAVE HAS REYES VERY SERIOUSLY
WE'VE MADE SOME -- WE'VE AGREED
TO MAKE SOME AMENDMENTS -- AND
WE'RE WERE VERY MINDFUL OF OF
THE CONCERNS -- SO WILL.
WILL WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON IT.
THANK RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU NEED A MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CHIANG.
BURKE BE YOU CALL THE ROLL.
I TO BE THREE SEVEN ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
LEYVA WILK HI WILK I CHANGED.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
SO -- THREE OH LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR MEMBERS THAT ON THE COMPANY
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT OUT.
GOOD LUCK AND YOU DISH.
BOB NEXT ITEM THIRTEEN S. B.
SEVEN ONE SIX BY SENATOR
MITCHELL [inaudible]
YES.
AND THE CHURCH RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS TO PRODUCE.
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE YOU I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO THE BILL.
SEVEN SIXTEEN WHICH WILL TAKE A
CORRECTIVE STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT INCARCERATED YOU WILL HOLD
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA HAVE
ACCESS TO A COLLEGE EDUCATION OR
CAREER VOCATIONAL TRAINING.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRED YOU LITTLE
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE POST
SECONDARY PROGRAMS OR THE
EASIEST.
STATUTE ONLY REQUIRES COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ND THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE A FULL HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM TO YOUTH IN CUSTODY.
OF NOT COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL
ALTHOUGH THERE IS NO STATUTORY
OBLIGATION TO SEE A WITH PROVIDE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION PROGRAM
FOR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES IN
CUSTODY.
STATE REGULATIONS DO REQUIRE
COUNTY PROBATION TO ENSURE THAT
ALL YOU FOR THEIR FACILITIES ARE
TREATED EQUALLY WITH REGARD TO
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THE YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS STATES THAT YOUTH IN THE
J. F..
HAVE THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE A
QUALITY EDUCATION.
THE YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS DOES
NOT PLACE AGE OR GRADE LEVEL
IMITATIONS ON THESE RIGHT.
I AM AWARE OF CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
WE HAVE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SEE
ISSUES IN UC'S IN PROBATION. TO
ADDRESS POLICY COMMENTS STATED
AND PAID FOR THE **** REGARDING
SCOPE OF SERVICES REQUIRED BY
THE LANGUAGE ARE AND THE FACT
THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
REQUIRED TO DETAIN YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO QUOTE A FULL ARRAY.
OF POST SECONDARY ACADEMIC AND
CARRILLO TECH EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
I AM CLEAR THAT A FULL ARRAY IS
BROAD AND VAGUE LANGUAGE AND
WE'RE GONNA WORK VERY HARD.
TO GET SOME CLARITY.
WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE JACQUELINE
RODRIGUEZ A STUDENT AT COLLEGE
OF SAN MATTEO.
M. LUCY CARTER POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR THE USE LAWCENTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
RODRIGUEZ I FIRST WANT TO
JUVENILE HALL WHEN I WAS TWELVE
YEARS OLD AND IN SEVENTH GRADE.
I GOT OUT FOR A MONTH AND THEN
WENT BACK IN AND LITERALLY DID
THREE YEARS I DO WHEN I'LL CAM
GROUP HOMES THE JUVENILE HALL OR
ON THE RUN.
WELL I WAS IN THE CAMP EDUCATION
WAS SO HARD FOR ME IT WAS ONE
CURRICULUM FOR EVERYONE AND I
WAS LEARNING WHAT OTHER GIRLS
WERE LEARNING EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE MUCH OLDER.
THEN A LOT OF THE GIRLS
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL WHILE
THEY WERE STILL INCUSTODY.
AND AFTER THE GRADUATION THEY
STILL CAME TO COURT SCHOOL WITH
THOSE BUT THEY SAT IN THE BACK
OF THE CLASSROOM AND DID NOTHING
BUT COLORING AND WRITING IN
JOURNALS.
OR WRITING LETTERS OR THEY WENT
OUTSIDE IN THE GARDEN THEY HAD
NOTHING TO STUDY NOTEBOOKS ARE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS WERE OFFERED
TO THEM.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS FOR
BECAUSE I BECAME CLOSE TO THOSE
GIRLS AND I NEED THEIR POTENTIAL.
THEY TELL ME THE GOALS AND THE
DREAMS THEY HAD ONE WANTED TO BE
A DOCTOR ANOTHER A PROBATION
OFFICER.
BUT I WOULD SAY TO THEM THERE'S
NO HOPE FOR US WHO IS GOING TO
HELP US.
IT DIDN'T GIVE ME MOTIVATION
BECAUSE THESE INTELLIGENT GIRLS
HAD JUST FINISHED HER HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND THERE WAS
NOTHING FOR THEM TO DO WHAT THAT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THEM GOING TO
COLLEGE BUT THEY GOT NOTHING TO
HELP.
BUT THEY GOT NOTHING TO HELP
THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT
WHILE THEY WERE STILL INSIDE NO
RESOURCES NO REAL OPPORTUNITY.
AND NOW I KNOW THAT ONLY TWO OF
THOSE GIRLS WENT TO ON TO
COLLEGE AND THOSE TO STUDY
COSMETOLOGY.
NOW IN MY THIRD YEAR OF STUDY I
COLLEGES ON THE TAIL AND I AM
HOPING TO RECEIVE ASSOCIATES
DEGREES AND FOUR SUBJECTS.
WHAT I EXPERIENCE AS I DID PUSH
ME TO ONE A COLLEGE EDUCATION
BECAUSE I WANTED TO BREAK THE
CYCLE RIGHT THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE?
EDUCATE MYSELF AND BE A ROLE
MODEL FOR MY KIDS.
NOW BEING A COLLEGE STUDENT I'VE
ALREADY FOR ANYTHING I'M SO
EXCITED TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND TO
LEARN TO LEARN FROM OTHERS AND
TO HELP OTHERS LEARN FROM ME.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AS THE SEVEN
ONE SIX BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
ALL YOU TWO ARE INCARCERATED HOW
FULL POTENTIAL LIKE ANYONE ELSE.
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY EVEN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES THAN EVERYONE ELSE
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY ARE GOING
TO AND THE POSITION THEY ARE AND
AS THE SEVEN ONE SIX PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO GO TO COLLEGE BREAK THE
CYCLE AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
OUR SOCIETY.
ASK YOU TO VOTE OR IS AS THE
SEVEN ONE SIX THANK YOU.
HI YES I'M LUCY SOCIO CARTER
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER.
AND YOU'VE HEARD MISS
RODRIGUEZ'S TESTIMONY ABOUT THE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES AND SHE
WAS IN HALL IN CAMP WITH.
AND THE LACK OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO FURTHER THEIR
EDUCATION.
HER EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE.
THERE'S A GROWING PERCENTAGE OF
YOUTH IN CUSTODY IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES WHO HAVE THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS OR EQUIVALENCY.
AB TWENTY THREE OH SIX WHICH WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ALLOWS YOU. TO COMPLETE THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA IF THEY'RE
IN A FACILITY WITH THE MINIMUM
STATE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS LOSS RESULTING IN MORE AND
MORE YOUNG PEOPLE IN CUSTODY.
WHO HAVE THEIR DIPLOMAS BUT NO
POST SECONDARY PROGRAMMING?
OTHER PERCENTAGE IS AS HIGH AS
50% IN THE STATE RUN FACILITIES
10215% IN THE COUNTIES
ANECDOTALLY.
I'VE BEEN A HALL RECENTLY WHERE
FIVE OF EIGHTEEN YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY HAVE THEIR DIPLOMAS AND
NOTHING TO DO.
I'M I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
HAVE SOME PROGRAMS.
A POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN PLACE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY IN CALIFORNIA
YOU.
THESE NEW PROGRAMS ARE MODELING
WHAT A PROBATION HIGHER
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIP CAN LOOK
LIKE AND THEY'RE USING EXISTING
RESOURCES IN THE INSTITUTIONS.
I'M.
AND I WANT TO SAY ALSO THAT
THESE STUDENTS ARE LIKE OTHER
STUDENTS THERE WILL BE YOU KNOW
THEY STILL HAVE TO MEET
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
YOU'RE ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL
AID -- THEY JUST HAPPENED TO BE
STILL IN CUSTODY -- AND THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO RE
ENVISION THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FUTURES.
SO BY SUPPORTING SENATE BILL
SEVEN ONE SIX YOU'RE HELPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO RIGOROUS
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO JUST ABOUT.
I'M I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE ACLU CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M I'M HERE FOR ANOTHER BILL
BUT BECAUSE THEY LISTEN TO THIS --
I CAN ASSURE HURDLE IT AT HE
THOUGHT OF SOMEONE NOT HAVING
YOUR FOURTEEN IS THAT I DO I'M A
SENIOR AND I'M GOING TO COLLEGE
NEXT YEAR.
AND I JUST -- CAN'T THINK OF
SOMETHING THAT SOMEONE COULD DO
TO DESERVE NOT HAVING FUTURE
LIKE THAT [inaudible]
AND YEAH I I JUST I JUST CAN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING ONE CAN DO TO
DESERVE THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THESE PEOPLE WERE IN CUSTODY
THEY ALREADY.
DON'T HAVE THEIR PRESENT IN
THEIR HANDS AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR TO TAKE THEIR FUTURE.
TO SO.
ALRIGHT.
IS THERE IF IT WASN'T MY PLACE
TO TALK BUT MY NAME IS
PARTNERSHIP COREY AND I SUPPORT
THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WONDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRY MORE OIL
WITH THE CSU AND WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
BUT WE LOOK LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSOR ON THE ISSUES RAISED IN
THE AND ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU I ALSO QUICKLY WANTED
TO LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT A
PAMELA GIVES OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY -- OFFICE OF EDUCATION
ASKED FOR ME TO DO ME TOO ON HER
BEHALF IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
SYDNEY NOW.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER CHIANG.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL AND I WOULD
LOVE TO ADD ON IT'S CALLED HAPPY
TO HAVE ME THINKING VERY MUCH.
IN A DRAWS -- DOES BEEN MOVED
THANK YOU I TO LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR HAVE TO HAVE YOU
AND BECAUSE I I VISIT JUVENILE
CAM YEAH.
AND MOST PEOPLE ARE THERE I MEAN
THEY DID SOMETHING GET THERE BUT
IT WAS CAUSED BY TRAUMA YEAH.
THE PLACE THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE
CITY WHEN THEY LEAVE THERE AND
GO BACK TO WHERE THEY CAME THE
PLACES WHERE THEY'RE SAFE AND
HAVE THE BEST LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT IS WHERE THEY'RE AT
AND TO HAVE ALL THAT DOWN TIME
AND NOT ALLOW THEM TO TO BETTER
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY WANT. TO
BETTER THEMSELVES MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE TO ME.
SO THIS IS THIS A GREAT BILL I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE DIDN'T DO IT
SOONER.
BUT WE NEED WE NEED TO DO IT AND
WITH THAT IF YOU CLOSE AS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- TO THE
WITNESSES INTO THE MEMBERS YOU
KNOW THIS BILL CAME ABOUT I WAS
IN WE WERE AT OFF SITE SENATE
DIEM CAUCUS.
I'VE LOST TRACK OF HOW MANY
YEARS AGO NOW AND THE YOUNG MAN
WAS A PART OF A STAKEHOLDERS
GROUP WHO WAS ON THE PANEL CAME
AND TALKED ABOUT HIS LIFE
EXPERIENCE HE WAS THEN IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND HE ELOQUENTLY TALKED ABOUT
JUST WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT --
BEING IN A HALL BEING THEY CAN'T
AND NOT HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE WHEELS STARTED TURNING
I'M FROM THAT EXPERIENCE -- I
PUT TOGETHER A YEAR LONG
WORKGROUP.
WHERE I AND MY STAFF TOUR CAMPS
IN JUVENILE HALLS ACROSS THE
STATE?
CONVENE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION PROBATION APARTMENTS
WE LOOKED AT MODELS THAT WERE
WORKING.
FORM TO OPINIONS ABOUT MODELS IT
DIDN'T THAT'S BEEN A YEAR LONG
REALLY KIND OF LEARNING THE
PROCESS -- THIS BILL IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE COALITION THAT WE
BUILT TO THAT YOUR LONG
WORKGROUP PROCESS -- AND LIKE
YOU SAID IT'S IT'S SO OBVIOUS --
AND YET IT IS NOT HAPPENING
ACROSS THE BOARD STATEWIDE WE'VE
GOT SOME PILOTS THAT ARE WORKING
WELL BUT WE WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THAT -- KIDS
WHO ARE NOT IN LA FACILITIES DO
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE AND I'D ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN ONE SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA WILK I WILL
I CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE AND CURRENTLY
THREE OH WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
AND I'M CONFIDENT YOU WILL HAVE
THE VOTES AND AN EARLY CAN
GRADUATION TO CREATE A VERY MUCH.
OKAY AT THIS POINT WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL.
I GUESS WE'RE START WITH ITEM
ONE WORKER WAY THROUGH.
ITEM ONE SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE TO CHANGE.
CHIANG NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
SO THAT CONTINUES TO BE ON CALL.
ITEM TWO SB TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE ONE CHANGE.
TANGO.
DUTY TO WRESTLE.
WHAT I SAW I?
WITH WIRE.
I KNOW RIGHT SO THE CURRENT
VOTERS FORTY TWO SO IT IS OUT
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
FOR THE MEMBER TO ADD ON ITEM
THREE SB EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO THE RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE MCGUIRE.
OKAY SIR AT SIX ZERO SO IT'S OUT
AND WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
THE NUMBER.
BY THE WAY IS CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE THAT'S WHY HE'S YEARS.
I DON'T THINK ANY SLACK IN A
ITEM FOR SB ONE FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO THE
FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I'VE WORKED
HERO CHANGE.
CHANGE I ASAL.
RUSSELL AYE.
SO THAT WILL BE OUT AS WELL SIX
OH I'M LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
NUMBER.
ITEM FIVE SP ONE SEVEN FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHURCH
BURNING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHANG.
CHANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE MCGUIRE.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT SICK SO BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
NUMBER TO ADD ON CONSENT
CALENDAR.
I HAVE -- WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'VE VICE CHAIR VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL I
REQUIRE.
SO THAT'S SIX OH AND LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THE MEMBER TO ADD ON
THAT ITEM SIX SP.
THREE TWO ONE ITEM NINE SB THREE
A THREE AND ITEM ELEVEN SB.
SIX THIRTY ONE ITEM SEVEN SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CARE VOTING NO I SURE.
I THREE ONE RUSSELL [inaudible]
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
SO THAT CONTINUES TO BE THREE
ONE AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT --
TEN MEMBERS ADD ON ITEM EIGHT SB
THREE SEVEN ONE THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASSED TO JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR HASN'T VOTED VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'D.
THREE ZERO LEYVA LASER WIRE AND
I REMAIN THREE ZERO AND LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
ITEM TEN SB THREE NINETY THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D LASSELL RUSSELL I'D.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT WITH THE SIX
A VOTE AND WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR THE MEMBER TO ADD ON ITEM
TWELVE SB SEVEN ONE FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE WAR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE.
CHAIR VOTING NO -- WANTED TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER.
WIRE CAN.
SO THAT IS AT TWO TWO AND WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON YEAH
.
I AM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
THREE ZERO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GLAZER REQUIRE AN OKAY
SO THAT IS -- FOR SO THE BILL
WILL BE OUT BELIEVE THAT ON CALL
FOR MEMBERS.
IN OF THE SERGEANTS TO TRACK
DOWN.
ARE MISSING MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE WERE IN RECESS WE
WILL RECONVENE THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE -- WE HAVE A
FEW BILLS ON CALL WE'RE WE
STARTING MANIMALA SECTOR WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
SENATOR TO RAZA PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE SB SEVEN FIVE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE THREE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
FOR THAT BILLS OUT.
FOR THREE OKAY PERFECT OKAY ALL
FILE ITEM -- TO LEYVA SB.
TWENTY FOUR ITEM TO SB TWENTY
FOR THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
FOUR TWO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
TWO TWO FIVE TWO TWO THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THREE PORTANTINO SB.
EIGHTY SIX FILE ITEM THREE SB
EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIVE
LEYVA SB.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR OKAY MISS FOR
PARDON ME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OUT FILING FOR ALLEN SB.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT ITEM FOR SB ONE
FIFTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE WAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE NOW WE WILL GO TO
FIVE AT THE BILLS OUT WE WILL
NOW GO TO HIGHLAND FIVE LEAVE A
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ITEM FIVE SB
ONE SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED
HER VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT OF FILE ITEM.
SEVEN SENATOR PORTANTINO SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM SEVEN SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NO VICE
CHAIR VOTING I THREE ONE DUE TO
WRESTLE GLAZER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
OKAY FOR ONE WE WAS TO LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL.
UP CLOSE TO HIM.
OKAY CHECK WILL CLOSE THAT OUT
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM EIGHT CABALLERO SB.
THREE SEVENTY ONE ITEM EIGHT SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY WITH THE
RIGHT WITH THE CHAIR HAS DEVOTED
BY SURE VOTING I THREE ZERO
LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN. ZERO CALL. FOUR
ZERO LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR UMBERG SB.
THREE NINETY ITEM TEN SB THREE
NINETY THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. SEVENTY THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO OF FILE ITEM
TWELVE CENTER GALGIANI SB.
SEVEN FIFTEEN ITEM TWELVE SB
SEVEN FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO -- TO TO GLAZER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE NO PAN [inaudible] THREE
TWO READ IT TO BELIEVE THAT BILL
ON CALL FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
SENATOR MITCHELL SB.
SEVEN SIXTEEN ITEM THREE SB
SEVEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR HAS DEVOTED VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'D.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. ONE TWO
THREE FIVE ZERO AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL AS WELL.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN CENTER
GALGIANI SB.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT ITEM FOURTEEN
AS BE SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FOUR ZERO GLAZER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL AS WELL.
NOW TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS.
WELCOME SIX SENATOR MITCHELL SB
THREE TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE EDUCATION -- THAT'S
OUR EDUCATION COMMITTEE BILL
SITE SB -- THREE EIGHTY THREE
FILING ELEVEN CENTER GLAZER SB
SIX THIRTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- CONSENT
CALENDAR LEAVE THE VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
ALL RIGHT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS OUT WE HAVE A COUPLE BILLS ON
CALL SO FOLKS THAT NEED TO VOTE
IF YOU COULD COME ON DOWN HERE
THAT WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED
.
THERE WOULD.
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED
BILLS FOR
YOU TO ADD ON TO WE'RE GONNA
START WITH -- FILE ITEM EIGHT
CENTER CABALLERO SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I TO ME SB THREE SEVENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FOUR ZERO POLICE --
PLEASE THERE I AM PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL WE
ARE MOVING TO FIND TWELVE
GALGIANI. SEVEN FIFTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
TWELVE SB SEVEN FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. TWO TO THREE A
GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE NO HAN. TO LEAVE THAT
OPEN.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SENATOR
MITCHELL SB SEVEN SIXTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE AFTER MEMBERS ITEM
THIRTEEN SB SEVEN ONE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR
GALGIANI SB SEVEN TWENTY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
FOURTEEN SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE THERE I AM PAN.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT BILL THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER.
I KNOW.
SO I THOUGHT WE'D RECORDED --
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT YOU HAD NOT
VOTED THAT IS CORRECT.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
YEAH SB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WAS AN
EXTENSION.
RIGHT WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS AN
OBSESSION.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CALL ME UP
MEMBERS ITEM SEVEN SP THREE
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING NO VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FOUR ONE RUSSELL GLAZER.
GLAZER NO.
NOT YET NO PROBLEM IT'S ONE OF
THOSE DAYS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THE VOTE SO WE HAVE
OPEN.
PLEASE RECEIVE MADAM SECRETARY
ITEM EIGHT SB THREE SEVENTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY WITH CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO
PAN.
THAT BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO EXCUSE ME.
SIX ZERO ITEM TWELVE SB SEVEN
ONE FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING NO.
TWO TWO FOUR PAN.
SO THAT BILL FAILS I WILL ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION FOR THE
AUTHOR SHOULD SHE WISHED THAT
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN ONE SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO PAN.
THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THEMOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I SIX ZERO PAN.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT SIX
ZERO AS WELL.
AND OF THAT WILL CONCLUDE SENATE
EDUCATION THANK YOU DIE HARDS
WHO ARE STILL HERE.
AND WE STAND ADJOURNED